REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
TO ORDER. AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
ADMONITIONS AND INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW WILL BE OPERATING
TODAY LET ME GO THROUGH THAT.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATORS MAKE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE- AND TODAY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE EXPECTED
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM I AM
JOINED NOW BY SENATOR FOR.
BOGUE AND WE EXPECT SENATOR MEN
SHORTLY. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS SHE USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
pCAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY- THIS ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE IS ONE OF THOSE
TWO ROOMS AND ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THE OTHER ROOM. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT'LL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I CAN
SEE IT ON THE SCREEN NOW AND I
ONE OUNCES NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MORE WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
YOUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
AGAIN PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
NEEDING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN ADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LIKE TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
TO ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY ARE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. WILL DISCUSS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION PROPOSALS
IN THE MAY REVISION- THIS WILL
INCLUDE PROPOSALS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE IN HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW. THAT TOMORROW'S
HEARING WE WILL COVER THE MANY
REVISIONS K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION PROPOSALS THESE ITEMS
ARE INFORMATIONAL AND NO VOTES
WILL BE TAKEN TODAY PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE ALL AT ONCE AT
THE END OF THE HEARING NCE
WE'VE COMPLETED ALL DISCUSSION
ITEMS. THIS HAPPENS TO BE THE
ELEVENTH OF OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HELD SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF FEBRUARY WE
ACTUALLY HEARD EACH OF THESE
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA PRIOR
TO THE MAY REVISE AND I'VE
ASKED EXTENSIVE QUESTIONS ON
THOSE SUBJECTS THEN NOW IS THE
TIME TO LOOK AT WHAT THE MAY
REVISE IS DONE AND IN SOME
CASES IT'S INTRODUCED A FEW NEW
ISSUES. IN OTHER CASES IT'S
GIVING US CLARITY ON THE ISSUES
THAT WE ALREADY HEARD. AND SO
LET ME ASK US AND ROAD SHOW
BOTH DO YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. SHE DOESN'T- BUT
BELIEVE ME WILL BE READY TO
HEAR FROM YOU LATER IN THE HAIR.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE
HEARINGS. AND THE FIRST. ISSUE
IS LIBRARY SUPPORT. THE PANEL
WAS JENNIFER LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
GREG LUCAS TO STATE- LIBRARIAN
BRIT BRIANNA BRUNCH FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. AND WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE IN THAT ORDER
AND I THINK THAT- THE WITNESSES
TODAY HAVE REALLY BEEN ASKED TO
FOCUS ON THE MAY REVISE AND
THEN THE DIFFERENCES ARE
UPDATES- GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
HEARD THESE ISSUES BEFORE. SO
WE WILL BEGIN WITH- JENNIFER
LOUIS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBER AT JENNIFER LEE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE ME REVISION PROVIDES ONE
POINT TWO FOUR MILLION ONGOING
AND A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT
FOUR ONE TIME GENERAL FLYING.
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
FOR A LOCAL LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE BROADBAND ACCESS
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES AND
LIBRARY PROGRAMS SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES
PRACTICALLY RESIDENTS IN
UNDERSERVED AND UNDER RESOURCED
COMMUNITIES. MEMORY REVISION
BECAUSE THE FOLLOWING
INVESTMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME YOU'RE NOT FINE TWO WORDS
LOCAL LIBRARY INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS. AND THE SECOND TIME.
INVESTMENT IS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FINE
FOR FEDERAL E. RATE
MAXIMIZATION FOR BROADBAND
ACCESS THE THIRD ITEM IS SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FINE
FOR BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY. THE
FOURTH IS FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FINE FOR LITERACY
FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
AS WELL AS SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL PLAN
FOR K. TWELVE ONLINE HOMEWORK
HELP DESK. YOUR LOCAL LIBRARIES
AS WELL AS FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FINE FOR CIVIL
LIBERTIES EDUCATION GRANT
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION WE HAD TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND
TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
ONGOING JOURNAL FUNDS FOR K.
TWELVE ONLINE STEAM DATABASES.
AS WELL AS ONE POINT SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FINE
AND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR ONGOING JOURNAL FINDS TO
SUPPORT SYSTEM TECHNOLOGY FOR
VISUALLY IMPAIRED CALIFORNIANS.
AS WELL AS THREE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR ONGOING
JOURNAL FINE FOR DATA AND
SYSTEMS LIBRARIANS AS WELL AS A
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HOMELESS
YOUTH PROJECT PROGRAM MANAGER.
AND LASTLY WE HAVE TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
FOR CULTURAL HERITAGE AGENCIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WILL
HOLD ALL QUESTIONS TILL. ALL
THREE PEOPLE HAVE PRESENTED THE
NEXT PERSON IS CHASING CONSTANT.
TOURISTS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
PANEL SO. A GOOD MORNING CAN-
THERE'S A CONSTANT SLUDGE AND
OFFICE BEFORE I DIVE INTO THE
LIBRARY PROPOSALS I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON A THEME THAT YOU'LL
HEAR US REITERATE THROUGHOUT
THE HEARING TODAY. AND THAT IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
SUBMITTED A LOT OF PROPOSALS
COVERING MANY DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES AND ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. I MEAN A
LOT OF CASES THESE PROPOSALS
HAVE VERY LIMITED INFORMATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS VERY
LITTLE TIME TO ASSESS THEM
BASED ON THIS LITTLE
INFORMATION. AND THEN EVEN
WHERE INFORMATION DOES EXIST
FOR THESE PROPOSALS- IT'S
OFTEN- PRELIMINARY OR
INCOMPLETE. DESPITE THAT A LACK
OF INFORMATION WE THINK THERE
ARE PROPOSALS WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD START MAKING
DECISIONS ON THESE PROPOSALS-
EITHER THE PROPOSALS HAVE
MERITS AND ARE WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. WELL THEY RAISE ISSUES
FOR CONSIDERATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE ONE AWAY. OR THE
PROPOSALS ARE PROBLEMATIC
PROBLEMATIC ENOUGH THAT YOU
COULD REJECT THEM WITHOUT-
NECESSARILY GETTING MUCH MORE
INFORMATION. AND THEN THERE ARE
PRPOSALS WHERE- THAT PROPOSALS
AND CONCEPTS SEEM REASONABLE
BUT THERE IS SOME INFORMATION
LACKING- AT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT TO GET MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE AUTHORIZING-
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR- LIBRARY
ITEM WE THINK THAT YOU SEE OLD
ALL OF THESE KINDS OF PROPOSALS
HERE. I JUST WALK THROUGH A FEW
OF THE MAJOR ONES. ARE MY
DIRECTOR TENSION TO THE VERY
FIRST BULLET ON LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE ON PAGE TWO OF
YOUR AGENDA. ON A LIBRARIAN FOR
STRUCTURE IS SOMETHING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT
IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A- CONSIDERATION-
FOR THE SENATE'S BUDGET. SO
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE
THE WE THINK THEY HAVE
GOVERNORS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL- PROVIDES A
POTENTIALLY GOOD STARTING POINT
TO WORK FROM. THAT SAID WE DO
HAVE SOME RECOMMENDED
MODIFICATIONS TO THIS IF THAT'S
AN THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE
TO PURSUE. FOR EXAMPLE WE
RECOMMEND LIMITING THE SCOPE OF
THIS- PROPOSAL TO- CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ANOTHER FACILITY RATED RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE ARE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATED PROPOSALS- FOCUSED ON
BROADBAND ACCESS AND WE'D
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT- THERE'S NO
DUPLICATION AMONG ITS DIFFERENT
GRANT PROGRAMS. WELL I THINK
THERE ARE SOME PROPOSALS HERE
THAT YOU COULD CONSIDER
REJECTING- FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
LOOK UNDER THAT SUB HEADING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING. THE
FIRST TWO PROPOSALS ENGLISH AS
A SECOND LANGUAGE IN AN ONLINE
TUTORING. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THESE ARE SUPPORTING
ACTIVITIES THAT- SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ALREADY
COVER THE STATE PROVIDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THESE
PURPOSES- WE DON'T SEE THE
RATIONALE IN CREATING A
SEPARATE PROGRAMS FOCUSED- ON
LIBRARIES- LARGELY DUPLICATING
THE SERVICES WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECT THESE ONES. AND THEN
FINALLY WE THINK THERE ARE
PROPOSALS THAT- SEEM-
POTENTIALLY REASONABLE CONCEPT
THERE'S JUST- NOT A LOT OF
INFORMATION ON THEM AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE
YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF US SMALLER
INITIATIVES OR WE THINK THIS IS
THE CASE. THIS IS AN EXAMPLE A
LOT OF THESE PROPOSALS- AT
POSITION OF AUTHORITY TO THE
STATE LIBRARY BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT PROVIDED
MORE DETAILED WORKLOAD ANALYSES
ON THESE POSITIONS. ARE
DESCRIBING- THEIR ACTIVITIES
AND ALSO WALKING THROUGH WHAT
ALTERNATIVES WERE CONSIDERED IT
FOR EXAMPLE- WHY EXISTING STAFF
CANNOT ABSORB THESE ACTIVITIES
WE RECOMMEND- GETTING MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THESE
PROPOSALS BEFORE AUTHORIZING
FUNDS FOR THEM. NOW I HAVE A
FULL AGENDA TODAY SOMEWHAT FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME I'LL LEAVE MY
JUST GOT MY COMMENTS THERE. BUT
HAPPY TO EXPAND ON ANY OF THESE
DURING YOUR DAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO GREG LUCAS TO STATE WHAT
BURNS. I THANK SENATOR. WELL
WE'RE ALWAYS HAPPY TO PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION. ANALYSTS IF
THAT HELPS THEM IN THEIR
ASSESSMENT- I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT- ANY
ITEMS YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
HAVE- QUESTIONS ABOUT QUESTIONS
ABOUT I MEAN I THINK JENNA J.
SOME SORT OF LAID OUT THE- IDMS
IN THE GENERAL. COURAGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE ONE
QUESTION AND I AM NOT SURE
MAYBE THE STATE LIBRARIAN IS
THE BEST TO TAKE A SHOT AT IT.
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BROADBAND PROPOSALS THAT- BARB-
INCLUDED HERE AND WHAT WILL THE
PROCESS BE TO DECIDE- WHO MOST
HAS NEED AND HOW ARE YOU OLD
SORT OF DISTRIBUTE THIS LIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONEY. HELLO WHAT'S
WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS IF THIS
IS LEFT IN THE BUDGET EXACTLY
THE WAY THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED. SO GREAT BREAKING THE
TWO ITEMS RIGHT SO THAT THERE'S
A THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR.
GRANT PROGRAM INVOLVING
BROADBAND FOCUSING ON THE
FACILITY'S FIRST THE INTENT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TO GIVE
UP THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS-
ON ON AN EQUITY BASIS WITH A
50% MATCH. AND SO. IN OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS I MEAN WE USE A
VARIETY OF DETERMINERS BUT A
KEY YARDSTICK. MAYBE I'M OUT OF
PER CAPITA SPENDING IN A
JURISDICTION- FOR LIBRARIES SO.
TO SO THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT SO WHAT. EXCUSE
ME ON STUMBLING OVER THIS BUT.
SO THE LEAST RESOURCE LIBRARIES
RIGHT WOULD BE GET FIRST CALL
ON THAT MONEY AND THAT'S
PRIMARILY SMALL AND RURAL
LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS AND
POCKETS OF URBAN AREAS WITH
HIGH AND LOW INCOME- AND LIKE
POPULATIONS AND IF THERE
pRESOURCE THEN YOU'RE REQUIRING
A 0% MATCH IS THAT GOINGTO BE
SOMETHING THAT SCREAMS PEOPLE
OUT BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO GO
TO THE WASTE RESOURCE AND THEN
THEY DON'T HAVE THE 50% MATCH.
WELL WELL. I MEAN. YEAH THAT'S
THE CATCH TWENTY TWO RIGHT I
MEAN THE LEAST RESOURCE PEOPLE
HAVE THE LEAST ABILITY. TO MAKE
THE MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
HOWEVER I MEAN THIS PROPOSAL
HAS- WALKING GIVES US THE
ABILITY. TO REDUCE RIGHT THE
AMOUNT OF- MATCHING FUNDS THAT
SHOULD BE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
GRANT PROGRAM. AND THEN ONE
OTHER QUESTION I'M SORRY TO GO
INTO THE WEEDS. A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN THEY'RE THAT SMALL AND
THEY DON'T HAVE MUCH CAPACITY
THEY DON'T HAVE EXTENSIVE
CAPACITY TO COMPLETE
APPLICATIONS IS THERE GOING TO
BE A WAVE THAT. THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SCREENED OUT OF
THIS BY ANY PROBLEM IN THE
BUILDING TO DO THAT. UP TO TWO
YEARS AGO- WE RECEIVED A NUMBER
OF- MEMBERS REQUEST INVOLVING
LIBRARY PROJECTS AND SO WE
CREATED A APPLICATION PROCESS
AND REPORTING PROCESS TO HANDLE
THOSE MAPS- WE TRIED TO MAKE IT
AS EASY TO COMPLY WITH THAT AS
POSSIBLE WHILE MAINTAINING THE-
YOU KNOW THE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE TO COLLECT HER I THINK
IT WOULD BE SIMILAR. I MEAN TO
BE. IF YOU KNOW THE PROCESS
THAT WE WENT THROUGH WITH SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY ON THE FELTON
LIBRARY- I MEAN IT'S IT WOULD
BE IN THE WAY WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT NOW IT WOULD BE COMPARABLE
TO THAT ROOM- SORRY TO DRAW ON
A- ASKED INCARNATION BUT WHEN I
WAS RESOURCES SECRETARY AND WE
FACED THIS. WE WOULD HAVE
PEOPLE DO LETTERS OF INTENT.
AND IF THEIR LETTER OF INTENT
WHICH WAS VERY BRIEF
DEMONSTRATED NEED THEN WE'D
WORK WITH THEM ON THE CAPACITY
WE WOULDN'T LET THE APPLICATION
SCREEN THEM OUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE ALREADY THERE SO- I
APPRECIATE. YOUR RESPONSE WHEN
WE ASKED THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THAT COULD BE A GREAT DAY THAT
COULD BE A GREAT WAY TO
FACILITATE JAMAICAN SO KNOCK
DOWN SOME BARRIERS SO. GREAT
THANK YOU HAPPY TO CHAT OFFLINE
ABOUT THAT. DO THE OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. I
DO- CENTRED ROADSHOW BOOK. I'M
AND THIS IS FOR THE LIBRARY- I
JUST HAVE A QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO THAT THE CONCERNS
THAT THE LA- HAD WITH REGARDS
TO THE- ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS AND- K.
TWELVE ONLINE HOMEWORK HELP
DESK- WITH SCHOOLS ALREADY
BEING PROVIDED ARE. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROVIDING
LOGISTICAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON
THEIR REMARKS. I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING SENATOR-
THERE'S SO MUCH DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND FAMILIES
AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS THAT BEARS MULTIPLE
PATHS TO SUCCESS AND I THINK
PART OF GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO CREATE. AS
MANY PATHS SO TO THAT SUCCESS
RIGHT THE FACILITATE- YOU KNOW
THE DESIRES AND THE GOALS OF%
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIANS SO THE
EXPERIENCE THAT'S GOING ON IN
SO THEY'VE BEEN LITERACY
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. AND
SO THIS PROPOSAL ADDS ENGLISH
AS A SECOND LANGUAGE TO ONE OF
THE ACTIVITIES CONDUCTED BY
THESE LOCAL LITERACY PROGRAMS
AND THE REASON THE PROPOSAL IS
HERE IS BECAUSE ONE- THE STATE
IS SPENDING ABOUT 50% LESS IN
ADULT EDUCATION AND WAS. YOU
KNOW EIGHT OR NINE YEARS AGO
WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN TOOK
OFFICE- BEARS FAN. YEAH THE
EXPENSE- IF I'VE CALLED G.
THERE'S LESS CLASSES AVAILABLE
AND ALSO THERE'S PEOPLE WHO
DON'T- SIXTY DOES WELL IN A
CLASSROOM AND FIRE. AND SO WHAT
WE HAVE REPORTED TO US BY. YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES OF- ELEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY LIBRARIES AROUND
THE STATE IS THAT THERE'S A
STRONG DESIRE- BANDS. OF PEOPLE
COMING TO THE LIBRARY AND
SPEAKING ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE L. AND SO. I MEAN I
THINK IT SPEAKS SO WHAT THAT'S
I CAN'T REALLY IMPROVE ON THAT
AS FOR TUTORING- I MEAN I MEAN
THERE'S- THERE THERE'S A
VARIETY OF PROPOSALS- ROUNDS
AROUND TUTORING I SUPPOSE- I
MEAN I HEARD THE GOVERNOR
ARTICULATE ONE THAT WAS IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE. BUT I THINK
AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO. IF WE
HAVE A NETWORK OF ELEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY LIBRARIES RIGHT
SO WHOSE MISSION IS TO CLOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY GAP. AND OVER
THE PAST YEAR THAT THEIR
PHYSICAL DOORS CLOSE AND MORE
PEOPLE HAVE ENTERED THEM
ENTERED THROUGH DIGITAL DOORS
TO MAKE AVAILABLE TO ANY
STUDENT WHO WANTS IT ANYTIME OF
THE DAY THEY WANTED. ONLINE
TUTORING IN ENGLISH SPANISH AND
MANDARIN. FOUR RIGHT AS A PILOT
PROJECT RIGHT BUT TO MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE FOR. RELATIVELY
SPEAKING THIS MODEST AMOUNT OF
MONEY- THROUGH EVERY PUBLIC
LIBRARY IN THE STATE SEEMS LIKE
IT'S A BENEFIT THAT HELPS
OTHER. ELEMENTS IN THE PROPOSED
MAY BEGIN ONLY IN THE MAY
REVISION SUCCEED BETTER. DOES
THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION- HE
GAVE ME A RATIONALE SO YES
THANK YOU- WHEN YOU PASS ON TO
SENATOR MAN HOPE WHILE I'VE
SEEN MANY QUESTIONS ON STATE
LIBRARIES YEAH I HAD A
QUESTION- AND THIS IS FOR THE
LIBRARY AND ALSO I GUESS
FRIENDLY- BUT- I'M INTERESTED
IN THE BROADBAND ACCESS GRANTS
PROPOSAL. IN A REVISED WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE WAYS IN
WHICH THE CORONA VIRUS A
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN THIS STATE-
AND I GUESS I'M JUST NOT I'M
NOT KNOWING. YOU KNOW WHAT THE
EXISTING ARCHITECTURE LOOKS
LIKE WHAT IS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GET US AND TO
THE LIBRARY DO YOU DO YOU MAYBE
YOU COULD COMMENT ON HOW YOU
SEE THE ROLE OF LIBRARIES AND
ADDRESSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR I'M
HAPPY TO. THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IS EIGHTY. EIGHT PILOTS
TO INVESTIGATE A STRATEGY THAT
WE'VE HAD SOME SUCCESS WITH
OVER THE PAST YEAR. IN WORKING
WITH. K. THROUGH TWELVE OUR
COUNTERPARTS IN THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION SO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OFFERS A DISCOUNT RIGHT IT'S
CALLED THE E. RATE DISCOUNT AND
SO IF YOUR OLD LIBRARY YOU'RE
TRYING TO CONNECT YOU GET ANY
RATE DISCOUNT. IF YOUR SCHOOL
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO CONNECT
YOU GET ANY RATE JUST. SO WE
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT IF WE
FIND A LIBRARY TO CONNECT. AND
THE SCHOOL TO CONNECT AND BUILD
THE PROJECTS AT THE SAME TIME.
THOSE TWO DISCOUNTS HAVE BEEN
SUFFICIENT. TO GET BIDDERS TO
AGREED TO SET TO DO PROJECTS TO
CONNECT PLACES. THAT DIDN'T
PENCIL OUT FOR THEM PREVIOUSLY.
SO THIS THIRTY FIVE MILLION
CHANGE THAT STRATEGY RIGHT SO
THAT I CAN TELL YOU SOME OF THE
PLACES THAT YOU WANT THAT
WE'VE- COLLECTED USING THAT
APPROACH LAST YEAR. SO THIS
PROPOSAL TAKES THAT STRATEGY
AND ENHANCED TELEHEALTH TO IT
WHICH IS ALSO AN ADDITIONAL E.
RATE DISCOUNT. SO IN OTHER
WORDS IF WE'RE ABLE TO CONNECT
PROJECTS THAT WEREN'T PENCILING
OUT PREVIOUSLY BY DOING
LIBRARIES PLUS SCHOOLS. THIS
PROPOSAL AS LIBRARIES PLUS
SCHOOLS PLUS TELESALES. AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
THERE'S ANOTHER POT OF MONEY
HERE ONE TIME MONEY IN A
LIBRARY BUDGET. BUT WE'VE BEEN
USING IT TO MAKE A MATCH RIGHT
TO THAT SO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYS. IT IN ESSENCE
FOR EVERYBODY YOU PUT IN WILL
GIVE YOU A CHANCE. SO WE ALSO
MAKE A MATCHING FUND LIKE WRITE
THE CHECK AND ALSO REDUCE THE
COST OF. CONSTRUCTION AND- SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT GROUP
DOES IS. A STRATEGY TO FIND
PROJECTS THAT. SORT OF HAVE
THAT KIND OF PRIVATE SECTOR. OF
WHICH THERE ARE NUMBERS THAT
WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY DETERMINED
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME TO
FOLLOW UP BEFORE WE GET TO LA-
I GUESS I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT
UNCLEAR STILL FROM YOUR
DESCRIPTION AND FROM- THAT THAT
PAPER THAT WE RECEIVED. WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IS I MEAN YOU'RE
OUTFITTING THE LIBRARIES
THEMSELVES USING SUB DIFFERENT
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS LIBRARIES
THEMSELVES BECOME WIFI HUBS ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING YOU
KNOW WE'VE SEEN CHILDREN
RECEIPT CARDS. THAT ALLOW THEM
ACCESS TO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FIVE G. NETWORKS- YOU KNOW I
GUESS I'M A LITTLE UNCLEAR ON
ON WHAT DECISION I GUESS THE
FOLLOW UP IS ONE OF THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET US ON A
PILOT PROGRAM IS AT ONE LIBRARY
IT TOTALLY OUTFITTED ISN'T. AND
YOU KNOW HOW I WOULD TO WHAT
DEGREE. ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
EXPANDING INTERNET ACCESS- I
CAN TAKE A CUT OF THAT UNLESS
YOU UNLESS YOU WANT TO J. SOME-
IT'S NOT ONE LIBRARY IT'SSMALL
IT'S INVASION DAY AS BEING YOU
KNOW MULTIPLE PROJECTS HOW MANY
I CAN'T REALLY TELL YOU. SO FOR
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS- LIBRARIES
HAVE BEEN CONNECTING WE'VE BEEN
HELPING LIBRARIES CONNECT TO. A
BROADBAND NETWORK THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
PART OF C. S. U. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS. AND SO PART OF THE
PROCESS OF CONNECTING TO THIS
BROADBAND NETWORK IS EXTENDING
BROADBAND PLACES THAT DON'T
HAVE. SO THIS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION TO HELPS RIGHT SO IT'S
CONNECT. AT LEAST TO THIS
BROADBAND NETWORK MIKE OKAY
YEAH THAT THAT IS THAT HELPING
FAMILY CONNECTING LIBRARIES
THEMSELVES THE EXISTING NETWORK
I GOT PRECISELY RIGHT LIBRARIES
PLUS SCHOOLS AND THEN OFFERING
AND THEN A TELEHEALTH
CONNECTION AS WELL AS WHAT THE
INTENT OF THIS PILOT PROJECT.
WITH WITH AN IDEA WHAT THEY
MEAN THE IDEA BEING THAT WITH
THESE MULTIPLE DISK TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THESE MULTIPLE
DISCOUNTS HARDER TO CONNECT
PLACES IN THE STATE WHAT THE
HELL WILL HAVE A GREATER
LIKELIHOOD OF BEING. AND IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE I SAY IT'S A
IT'S A THREE FOR TWO RIGHT.
CANADA ASCEND REMAIN THAT- OKAY
HE'S GOOD I THINK I'M GOOD-
ALTHOUGH LA- HAS ANY COMMENTS
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
THOSE. ASHURA I'LL TAKE A STAB
SO- MAYBE JUST TO REITERATE A
FEW POINTS GREG MADE-
HISTORICALLY LIBRARIES WERE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR- DEVELOPING THEIR OWN
CONNECTIONS TO THE INTERNET BUT
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE STATE
BEGAN AN INITIATIVE TO CONNECT
LIBRARIES TO THE STATE'S
EXISTING- INTERNET SYSTEM FOR
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT SYSTEM
INCLUDES HIGHER READING K.
TWELVE AND IT'S OVERSEEN BY AN
ENTITY CALLED SCENIC- AND
SUPPORTING THIS INITIATIVE
THERE'S SOME ONGOING COSTS
INCLUDING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- TO PAY FOR THE CONTRACT
TO SCENIC. BUT THERE'S ALSO
SOME OTHER STATE IN PREVIOUS
YEARS AS PROVIDED SOMEONE TIME
FUNDS- TO ASSIST LIBRARIES AND
CONNECTING TO THE INTERNET AND
ALSO FOR LIBRARIES THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET TO
EXPAND THEIR- BROADBAND
CAPACITY. IN YOUR AGENDA THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT GRANT
PROGRAMS THERE'S- THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ONE AND IN
THE SIX MILLION DOLLAR ONE. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THE SIX
MILLION DOLLAR ONE IS- A BIT
MORE TYPICAL OF THE PREVIOUS
GRANTS THAT WERE PROVIDED IS
FOCUSED ON. CONNECTING
LIBRARIES TO THIS MORE MORE
LIBRARIES OF THE SYSTEM AND
THEN EXPAND FOR LIBRARIES ARE
CONNECTED IN. CONNECTING TO
EXPANDING THEIR BROADBAND
ACCESS. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT MOST LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS
ARE CONNECTED TO THE SYSTEM BUT
NOT ALL BRANCHES BRANCH
LIBRARIES ARE SO- THAT WOULD BE
SORT OF THE FOCUS IS GETTING
THOSE REMAINING BRANCHES
CONNECTED. AND THEN ALSO
SIMILARLY FOR SOME
JURISDICTIONS EXPANDING THEIR
BROADBAND CAPACITY. HELLO ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT- IN
YOUR YOUR GENDER I THINK
DESCRIBE THIS LATER BUT THERE'S
SOME. ADDITIONAL UNSPENT
FUNDING FROM PREVIOUS GRANT
AWARDS IT'S ONE POINT THREE
MILLION- IT WOULD BE REALLY
APPROPRIATE IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
ADOPT THE REAPPROPRIATION- BUT
THAT YOU GET MORE CLARITY AS
TO- WHAT THEY- REMAINING NEED
IS AND WHETHER- IN ALL THE SIX
MILLION TO BE SPENT IN THIS
YEAR OR- THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THIS YEAR WITH THE
REAPPROPRIATION AND- REDUCING
THIS ONCE THOSE UNSPENT FUNDS
ARE FULLY SPENT DOWN. ON THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL- I UNDERSTANDING IS IT
IS THIS IS A SOMEWHAT NEWER
INITIATIVE THAT'S INTENDED TO.
FURTHER EXPAND INTERNET ACCESS
THROUGH. COLLABORATIVE SPAM
WITH SCHOOLS IN TELE HEALTH
AGENCIES. AND HERE WE JUST HAVE
A LOT MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL- IT'S A LITTLE
UNCERTAINTY LAST HOW MANY
CLAPPERS WITH THIS WITH SUPPORT
IT'S ON. CERTAIN TO US HOW MUCH
MORE FEDERAL E. RATE WOULD BE-
DRAWN DOWN AS A RESULT OF THE
PROPOSAL. I MEAN IT'S ALSO
INCLUDING LAST- WHAT THE STATE
FUNDS WOULD SPECIFICALLY COVER
AND- BY THIS FUNDING IS NEEDED
RIGHT WHY THESE AGENCIES- CAN'T
FIND THESE ACTIVITIES FROM
THEIR OPERATIONS. THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE PROPOSALS WERE STILL
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON BUT THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T- FULLY PROVIDED ALL THE
INFORMATION ON THIS ONE. I
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THIS PANEL WE APPRECIATE IT LET
ME MAKE JUST A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS. R. ONE IS THAT- NOTE
TO LA O'S OPENING COMMENTS.
ABOUT EVERY ITEM IN AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THAT IS TRUE
WE'LL TAKE A HARD LOOK AT EVERY
ITEM. SECOND CHECK IN PRIOR
HEARINGS WE TALKED ABOUT MAYBE
NET YEAR LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNANCE OF THE LIBRARY AND
SEEING IF THERE'S A WAY. HER TO
REVIEW IT SINCE IT'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF DECADES THAT IS JUST
CHANGE BIT BY BIT HANFORD. THE
ISSUE OF- A FUNDING REQUEST
FOR. RENEWING THE GRANT PROGRAM
THAT EXISTED BEFORE. FOR L. G.
B. T. ARCHIVES CAME UP AND I
SUPPORT ADDING THAT. THERE WAS
A CONCERN EXPRESSED SINCE THEN
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A BROADER
GROUPS. ARE INCLUDED AND I
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT CONCERN
IN THIS CASE. THERE'S A BIG
CATCH UP IN ON WANTED NEEDED
MAYBE NEXT YEAR. WE CAN LOOK AT
A DIFFERENT GROUPS DIFFERENT
ARCHIVES AND SEE IF THERE'S AN
ISSUE AND WITH THAT- WILL COME
BACK IN A FUTURE HEARING. FOR
THE DECISIONS ON THIS ITEM BUT
IT'S BEEN REALLY HELPFUL OF
THIS DISCUSSION AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY. THAT WAS
HERE TODAY. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO WHICH IS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. OF THE PANEL IS
BRIAN RUTLEDGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICER
CEO BURTON AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE HERE
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. SO LET'S GO IN THAT
ORDER AND BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR SENATORS BRIAN
RUTLEDGE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF.
PROPOSALS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK
AND SAVE SOME TIME FOR
QUESTIONS. THE FIRST IS A 2%
BASE AUGMENTATIN OF SIXTY NINE
POINT THREE MILLION. ONGOING
GENERAL FUND THAT WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO THE 3% A HUNDRED
AND THREE POINT NINE MILLION
BASE AUGMENTATION WE PROPOSED
AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO
EFFECTIVELY WE'RE PROPOSING TO
COME UP TO A 5% TOTAL BASE
AUGMENTATION FOR BUDGET YEAR.
ALSO THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE
FEBRUARY EARLY ACTION AGREEMENT
WHERE YOU SEE. WHAT IS NOW TO
RECEIVE THREE HUNDRED TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND WHICH REFLECTS OUR- THE
LEVEL OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT PRODUCTION. SO I'LL
NOTE THAT THIS THIS BASE
AUGMENTATION FROM A REVISED
IT'S ALSO PREMISED ON THE SAME
EXPECTATIONS YOU'LL RECALL FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THAT'S
THAT'S THAT THE UC WILL ADOPT
POLICIES TO INCREASE ONLINE
OFFERINGS AT TEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS ABOVE PRE COBIT LEVELS
THAT. DO YOU SEE WILL IMPLEMENT
A NEW DUAL ADMISSIONS PROGRAM.
AND THAT YOU SEE WILL HAVE A
REPORT BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DETAILING OUR PLANS TO CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. MINOR AMENDMENT WE'RE
PROPOSING IT MAY IS ON THE
EQUITY REPORT. OFFERED THANKS
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY DUE JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE'RE NOW PROPOSING TO EXTEND
THAT REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THAT GOES FOR ALL
SEGMENTS. ANOTHER ONGOING
ADJUSTMENT THIS IS LARGELY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE IS THAT FOR
THE GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROP FIFTY SIX BACK FILL.
OPPOSING A ONE POINT SIX
MILLION OUR GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION THAT'S TO MAINTAIN
THE JIMMY RESIDENCY SLOT
PROGRAM AT THE TOTAL OF FORTY
MILLION. RESOURCES THAT THERE
YOU SEE HAS TRADITIONALLY HAD.
ANOTHER ONGOING OUR PROPOSAL
WOULD BE TO ELIMINATE THE USE
C. O. P. DO YOU SEE A AND R.
AND YOU SEE PASS LINE ITEM THAT
HAS BEEN SEPARATE FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE. TRANSPARENCY AND TO
ALLOW FOR LEGISLATIVE AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OVERSIGHT
WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING SOME SOME
BUDGET ILL LANGUAGE TO NOW
ATTACHED TO THE HOUSTON MAIN
ITEM THAT WOULD IN OUR VIEW OF
TACTICALLY PRESERVE ON THE
TRANSPARENCY FROM HAVING A
SEPARATE ITEM. MOVING ON TO
SOME ONE TIME ADJUSTMENTS THE
BIGGEST FOR YOU SEE IS A
PROPOSAL ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS. SO THIS
ONE FIFTY IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THAT WOULD ALL BE FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS. SO AGAIN
THAT'S A GENERAL FIND OUT FROM
G. B. HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE AND
NOW FEDERAL FUNDS OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THE OTHER ANOTHER BIG ONE TIME
PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE IS FORTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FOR
ANIMAL SHELTER GRANTS. THE
FUNDING WOULD GO TO UC DAVIS
SCORED- ANIMAL SHELTER MEDICAL-
THE SHELTER PROGRAM- THAT WOULD
BE TO BUILD ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT INCLUDED A-
THE FIVE MILLION- AUGMENTATION
FOR UC DAVIS TO START THIS
PROGRAM THE FORTY FIVE MILLION.
WOULD ESSENTIALLY LET- UC DAVIS
ROLL OUT OVER FIVE YEARS A
GRANT PROGRAM AND SUPPORT.
SHELTERS ACROSS THE STATE IN
ACHIEVING WHAT IS ALREADY ON
THE BOOKS AS A STATEWIDE GOAL
SO THAT NO TREATABLE OUR
ADOPTABLE ANIMALS WOULD BE
EUTHANIZED. ALL KNOW THAT
THERE'S WE ALSO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THAT
GRANT PROGRAM. ANOTHER ONE TIME
PROPOSALS FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME TO RENOVATE UCLA'S LAWSON
LABOR CENTER FACILITY. ANOTHER
ONE TIME PROPOSAL IS TEN POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE UCSF DYSLEXIA CENTER THAT'S
BUILDING ON PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS IN DYSLEXIA. THIS
WOULD SPECIFICALLY BE FOR-
IMPROVING DEVELOPING AN APT FOR
OUR SCREENING AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. IN ADDITION TO
TEACHER TRAINING SUPPORT AND
DYSLEXIA RESEARCH. ANOTHER
INVESTMENT IS FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME IN THE UCLA ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES CENTER THAT WOULD BE
FOR ANALYSIS AND RESEARCH THAT
PREVENTS I HATE INCIDENTS
RELATED TO API COMMUNITIES AS%
WELL AS- PROVIDE GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO DO THE SAME. THE LAST ONE
TIME INVESTMENT IN YOU SEE%
WE'RE PROPOSING IS ONE MILLION.
FOR THE UC BERKELEY ALTERNATIVE
MEATS LAB TO SUPPORT THE LAB.
SHE ALSO NOTE A COUPLE ARE
ADJUSTMENTS HERE THAT AREN'T-
THEY DON'T INVOLVE THE GENERAL
FUND AMOUNT. PROPOSING TO
EXTEND TO IT TOO. TO UNDO
ELIMINATE THE SUMMER TERM
FINANCIAL AID SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE SO IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE ADJUSTED EACH
BUDGET. THE SUNSET DATE OF THE
SUMMER TERM FINANCIAL AID SO
EFFECTIVELY THIS WOULD IMPACT
BUDGET YEAR WHICH ARE READY
BASED ON GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
SET TO PROVIDE YOU SEE FOUR
MILLION FOR SUMMER ED. THIS
WOULD EFFECTIVELY MEAN THE OUT
YEARS BUT FOUR MILLION IS
ONGOING. YOU'LL SEE SOMETHING
SIMILAR FOR CSU. THE EMERGENCY
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID THAT WE
PROPOSE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING AMENDMENTS
TO THE ELIGIBILITY THE GOAL IS
TO ALIGN WITH AB EIGHTY FIVE.
MAYBE EIGHTY FIVE PROVIDED CCC
STUDENTS WITH CURRENT YEAR
EMERGENCY STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
AND IT SPECIFIED THAT STUDENTS
WERE ELIGIBLE IF THEY WERE
ENROLLED HALF TIME AND IT
EXEMPTED STUDENTS FROM A GPA
REQUIREMENT IF THEY WERE
ENROLLED AND DISABILITY
PROGRAMS CHARMIN MINTS ARE
ESSENTIALLY TO ALIGN WITH THAT
AND THE RESULT WOULD BE WE'RE
PROPOSING TO RESCIND UNDER A
WORK REQUIREMENT. TO CHANGE THE
FULL TIME REQUIREMENT AT HALF
TIME. I TEND TO INCLUDE A G. P.
EXEMPTION FOR DISABILITY
ENROLLED STUDENTS- THAT'S ALL
FOR THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT
EMERGENCY. FINANCIAL AID FUND-
FINDING. THE ONE OTHER MINOR
ADJUSTMENT IS THE BIG ONE AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE PROPOSED A
MILLION. ONGOING RESOURCES FOR-
YOU SEE TO ADOPT A COMMON
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
ALIGN WITH THE OTHER SEGMENTS.
WE'RE CLARIFYING OR PROVIDING
AN AMENDED LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
THAT THE INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL
IT IS NOT TO ADOPT A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM INSTEAD IT'S TO. HAVE
THE SEGMENTS WORK TOGETHER TO
ADOPT THE MOST REASONABLE
PROGRAM. LASTLY AND THIS IS A
BIG BIG PROPOSAL THAT AFFECTS
ALL SEGMENTS BUT IT DOES SHOW
UP IN UC'S BUDGET SPECIFICALLY.
THAT'S WERE PROPOSING ONE
BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
SPLIT BETWEEN BUDGET HERE AT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THAT WOULD BE
TO ESTABLISH LEARNING ALIGNED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
LEARNING ALIGNED LONG TERM
CAREER DEVELOPMENT FOR UC CSU
AND CCC STUDENTS. SO THE WAY
THIS WOULD WORK IS THE BILLION.
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND WOULD
CREATE AN ENDOWMENT
ADMINISTERED BY THE UC. BASED
ON THE PROPORTION OF PELL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AT EACH
SEGMENT YOU SEE WOULD ALLOCATE
THE ANNUAL RETURNS FROM THE AN
ENDOWMENT. AND THEN DOT FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT A STATE FUNDED
WORK STUDY PROGRAM. KNOW THAT
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT STATE
FUNDED WORK STUDY PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD BE R. EIGHT A STUDENT
WITH FINDING DEMONSTRATED
FINANCIAL NEED. THAT ISN'T FROM
AN UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUND.
AND WE'RE ALSO PRIORITIZING
STEM MAJORS IN STEM EMPLOYERS
WITH THAT- WE HAVE THE TRAILER
BILLING WHICH ASSOCIATE WITH
THAT AS WELL SO WITH THAT ALL
ALL SAY WE ARE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DISK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
LA- SO I THINK IT'LL BE HELPFUL
TO THEM I WORK FROM PAGE SEVEN
OF YOUR AGENDA. THIS PAGE SHOWS
A TABLE SUMMARIZING ALL OF THE
GENERAL FUND- PROPOSALS THAT
YOU SEE- IT SHOWS NO PROPOSALS
THAT WERE AND GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BACK IN JANUARY. ON THE
PROPOSALS NOW UNDER MAYOR
VISION AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO- AND I WOULD
JUST NOTE IT'S ALL GENERAL FUND
THERE IS A AN ADDITIONAL AT THE
MOMENT AS HE ADMINISTRATION
NOTED ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- THAT
SADDAM. IS IMPORTANT BUT NOT B.
B. THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. IMAGINE
pDAUNTING TO WORK THROUGH I CAN
THINK OF TIME I WON'T GO
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE PROPOSAL.
I'LL JUST TOUCH ON FOUR KEY
ISSUES- THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
FACING RIGHT NOW. THE FIRST
ISSUE I WILL HIGHLIGHT IS BASED
IN PART FOR YOU SEE. AND THAT
IS REALLY SUMMARIZED IN THOSE
FIRST TWO ITEMS UNDER THE ON
GOING. THAT'S THE THREE OH TWO
MILLION OR ON RESTORATION FUNDS
TO GET YOU SEE BACK TO ITS-
PREVIOUS LEVEL SUPPORT PRE
PANDEMIC. AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL BASE INCREASE UNDER
THE MAY REVISION IT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INCREASING THE
BASE INCREASE FROM 3% 25% WELL
WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTEMPLATE
PROVIDING. A BASE INCREASES TO
UC EVEN ABOVE RESTORATION FUNDS
YOU SEE DOES FACE COST
PRESSURES EACH YEAR AND THIS
YEAR CERTAINLY DIFFERENT- IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THAT BASING CREASE COULD BE WE
THINK A REASONABLE PLACE TO
START- CONSIDERATION FOR YOUR
BASE INCREASE IS- YOU SEIZE.
KEY OPERATING COSTS THINGS
LIKE. EMPLOYEE BENEFIT COST
INCREASES DEBT SERVICE. WHEN WE
SUM THAT UP IT GETS US TO A
LITTLE UNDER EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR A JUST OVER 2% BASED
INCREASE BUT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD PREVENT CONSIDER
PROVIDING- LARGER BASE INCREASE
IN THAT FOR EXAMPLE BY ADOPTING
A 3% PROPOSED IN JANUARY OR THE
5% PROPOSED IN THE REVISION. BY
DOING THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
IT WOULD BE FINDING ADDITIONAL
YOU SEE PRIORITIES LIKE
EMPLOYEE SALARY INCREASES
STUDENT SUCCESS INITIATIVES OR
ENHANCING STUDENTS CERTAIN
STUDENT SERVICES. THAT SAID A
YOU SEE WOULD HAVE FLEXIBILITY
TO WAIVE THESE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES WITH AN UNRESTRICTED
BASE INCREASE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WANTS TO ENSURE
THAT YOU SEE IS FUNDING SOME OF
THESE PRIORITIES WE RECOMMEND
IT SPECIFY THAT IN THE END
BUDGET ACTS. THE SECOND ISSUE I
WANT TO TOUCH ON IS THAT VERY
FIRST ONE TIME PROPOSAL IN OUR
TABLE IT SAYS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT IN THERE. AND
THAT YOU'RE AFTER SO THIS WOULD
BE A BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL.
AND WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO DO IS TO PROVIDE
YOU SEE ONE TIME FUNDING TO
CREATE AN ENDOWMENT THAT WOULD.
THEN SUPPORTS- EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS- THE
SUPPORT WOULD COME FROM THE
ANNUAL EARNINGS FROM THE
ENDOWMENT. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE FUNDING%
APPROACH- INVESTING THE FUNDS
IN AND DOMINANCE- COULD
POTENTIALLY MEAN INVESTING THEM
IN EQUITIES. BUT THIS IS
UNUSUAL FOR STATE FUNDS
TYPICALLY THE STATE INVESTED
FUNDS AND LOWER RISK-
SECURITIES LIKE GOVERNMENT-SECURITIES. ON SO THAT'S A CORE
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER IS SORT OF THE ADDED
RISK- FOR THESE PARTICULAR
STATE FUNDS. ALSO BY EXPOSING
THE FUNDS TO EQUITIES- THE
ANNUAL REVENUE COMING FROM THE
INDICTMENT. COULD BE VOLATILE
AND THAT COULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR CAMPUSES AND FOR
STUDENTS TO THE PLAN EACH YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO RAISES SOME
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS IN OUR
MIND- IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THE WHAT
THE ROLE OF THE STATE VERSUS
EMPLOYERS WOULD BE AND I'M
PAYING FOR STUDENT STIPENDS.
AND IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR HOW THIS
PROGRAM AND INTERACT WITH THE
STATE'S EXISTING FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS. FOR ALL THESE REASONS
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND YOU REJECT IT. NOW
DOES THIRTY SHE WANNA COVER IS
ALL OF THE REMAINING ONE TIME
PROPOSALS HERE AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE MAY REVISION NOTABLY
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF- ONE
TIME PROPOSALS THAT YOU SEE.
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS ARM WE
THINK OUR HIGH STREET
PRIORITIES AGAIN- YOU'VE HEARD
AS MENTIONED THIS MANY TIMES
BEFORE AND HEARINGS WE THINK
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- IT HAS
VERY CERTAIN BENEFITS TO THE
STATE IT FUNDS PROJECTS THAT IF
THEY ARE OTHERWISE COVERED
WITH. INCREASING COSTS IN
FUTURE YEARS. TO ADDRESSING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE HELPS
ADDRESS BUDGET RESILIENCY BOTH
FOR YOU SEE AND FOR THE STATE.
OTHER PROPOSALS COVER UP
PRIORITIES- THAT COULD BE OF
INTEREST TO LEGISLATURE BUT THE
BENEFITS ARE- POTENTIALLY IN
CERTAIN. THINGS LIKE- ANIMAL
SHELTER OUT REACH RESEARCH ON
ALTERNATIVE MEAT PRODUCTS-
RESEARCH ON DEVELOPING NEW
EDUCATION BASED TECHNOLOGIES.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT ALL OF THE
ONETIME PROPOSALS MEANS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S EFFECTIVELY
PROPOSING TO SPREAD IT A ONE
TIME FUNDING OVER MANY
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES THIS
ALLOWS THE STATE TO COVER LOTS
OF PRIORITIES BUT IT ALSO.
SPREADS FUNDS SIMPLY AND
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO ADDRESS ANY
OF THESE PRIORITIES
MEANINGFULLY OR FULLY. ONE
ALTERNATIVE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER IT TO BE A BIT
MORE STRATEGIC AND PRIORITIZE
PROVIDING MORE ONE TIME
FUNDING- FOR A SELECT NUMBER OF
ONE OF PRIORITIES THAT. ARE AT
THE HIGHEST. BENEFIT TO THE
STATE AND OF THE HIGHEST
INTEREST TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THE FINAL ISSUE I WANT TO TOUCH
ON IS ACTUALLY NOT IN THIS
TABLE IT'S A LANGUAGE ONLY
ISSUE AND THAT IS THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S LINE ITEM. NOW
IS STARKLY YOU SEE. HAS HAD THE
ABILITY TO ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT I'M
FROM THEIR APPROPRIATION- BUT A
FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED- A LINE ITEM ON THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT WITH
THE INTENT OF GETTING MORE
OVERSIGHT AND CONTROL OVER THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BUDGET. ON THE ADMINISTRATION
IS NOW REQUESTING TO ELIMINATE
THIS LINE ITEM AND GIVE YOU
SEE- MORE FLEXIBILITY TO MANAGE
ITS RESOURCES ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE WE
RECOMMEND MAINTAINING THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S LINE
ITEM- FOR ONE THING WE THINK
THAT THE COST PRESSURES SMALL
DATE THERE ARE SOME SIMILAR
COST PRESSURES BETWEEN THE
CAMPUSES IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT- THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T. FACE A ROMAN
GROWTH FOR EXAMPLE DOESN'T FACE
COST PRESSURES WERE WITH A
STUDENT ON SUCCESS AND IT
SHOULD HAVE YOUR STUDENT
SERVICES. I THINK IT'S
REASONABLE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANT TO TARGET FUNDS
DIFFERENTLY FOR THESE DIFFERENT
DIVISIONS WITHIN YOU SEE. WE
ALSO THINK HAVING A LINE ITEM
AND IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY WHICH
WE UNDERSTAND THAT
ADMINISTRATION'S RATIONALE OF
PROPOSING NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. WITHIN THOSE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- ARE
WORTHY OF ADOPTING. BUT WE
THINK HAVING A LINE ITEM
FURTHER ENHANCES TRANSPARENCY
BY CLARIFYING HOW MUCH STATE
FUNDING IS BEING PROVIDED TO
THESE DIVISIONS. WE DO
RECOMMEND SOME MODIFICATION TO
THE CURRENT LINE ITEM FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A THERE'S ONE
PART OF THE ONE ITEM THAT
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR A PROGRAM
CALLED YOU SEE PAST. THIS IS A
CENTRALIZED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROGRAM- THAT FOCUS ON THINGS
LIKE PAYROLL AND HUMAN
RESOURCES- SHIFTING THOSE FUNDS
BACK TO THE CAMPUS
APPROPRIATION WOULD ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO FUND THE PROGRAM
BY CHARGING CAMPUSES FEES. WE
THINK THAT MODEL IS A BIT MORE
EFFICIENT IT WAS. IT BETTER IN
SOME DEVICE CAMPUSES TO MANAGE
THEIR OWN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WHEN SUPPORTING THIS PROGRAM.
THIS PARTICULAR ONE FOR FREE C.
PAP THE PARTICULAR WE
RECOMMEND- SHIFTING THAT BACK
TO THE CAMPUSES. AGAIN FOR THE
SAKE OF TITLE ENDED THERE BUT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT. COME UP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL MOVE
TO THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
THANK YOU TERROR ALERTS CITY OF
R. TEN AND- FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA- ALL DRESSED EACH
OF THE ITEMS IN THE AGENDA IN
CHARGE- ON TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSING A 5% BASED
BUDGET INCREASE THAT USED THE
OPERATING BUDGET. IN ADDITION
TO THE FULL BASE BUDGET
RESTORATION THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE CREATURE IN
FEBRUARY. UC REGENTS REQUESTED
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
TO SUSTAIN CAMPUS OPERATIONS
AND PROVIDE POLICY COVERED
STAFF AND FACULTY. 83% SALARY
ADJUSTMENT. WE CONTINUE TO
REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO MEET
THESE GOALS FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THESE FUNDS WILL
ARE THE UC CAMPUSES TO COVER
NEW COSTS SUCH AS RETIREMENT
HEALTH CARE REPRESENTED LABOR
SALARY AGREEMENTS. OUR DESIRE
TO PROVIDE A SALARY ADJUSTMENTS
ARE POLICY COVERED STAFF IS
DRIVEN BY WANTING SALARIES TO
KEEP UP WITH INFLATION. UC
CAMPUSES CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO
THE LOCAL ECONOMIES AND S.
THIRD LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE
STATE IT IS IMPORTANT WE ENSURE
THE WELLBEING OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
IN ADDITION YOU SEE CONTINUES
TO REQUEST- FOR TARGETED
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WE REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE HOUSTON WITH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING TO BEGIN CLOSING
GRADUATION EQUITY GAPS. ALONG
WITH MORE TIME TO ACHIEVE THE
RESULTS. IN ADDITION YOU SEE
REQUEST FORTY THREE MILLION AND
ONGOING INVESTMENTS IN BONNER
WILL STUDENTS INCLUDING
EXPANSION. OF THE SUCCESSFUL
STATE PROGRAM THAT PREPARES
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS FOR
UNIVERSITY EDUCATION. YOU SEE
REQUEST THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME INVESTMENTS FROM
THE STATE. INCLUDING
REPATRIATION OF TRIBAL REMAINS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
TELEHEALTH CAPACITY AND ONLINE.
LEARNING EQUIPMENT AND
PREPARATION. I I'LL CONTINUE TO
THE I'D ON YOUR- WHICH IS USE
YOUR FELINE I- WE'RE VERY.
THANKFUL TO GOVERNOR OR
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFICULTIES TO
YOU STILL P. OPERATIONS CENTER.
AS A RESULT OF PCAOB LINE ITEM.
THERE ARE A FEW NOTES I WISH TO
MAKE ABOUT THIS TOPIC. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS A CHANGE
IN FUNDING METHODOLOGY ONLY.
EXTENSIVE BUDGET REFORMS YOU
SEE UNDERTOOK TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WILL STAY IN
PLACE. ONE OF THESE REFORMS WAS
THE FORMATION OF THE EXECUTIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF
CHANCELLORS VICE CHANCELLORS OF
FINANCE AND OTHER CAMPUS
LEADERS. REVIEW USE YOUR P.
EXPENDITURES AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO PRESIDENT ON THE
USE YOUR B. PROGRAMS AND
EXPENDITURES. THIS GROUP WILL
CONTINUE IN THIS IMPORTANT ROLE
PROVIDING CAMPUS INPUT ON YOU
STILL BE FINANCES. BUT THERE
ARE MANY MORE FARMS SOME OF
THEM TECHNICAL BUT NO LESS
IMPORTANT. THESE REFORMS
INCLUDE Q. C. O. P. RESERVE
POLICY THAT WAS DEVELOPED AND
DOCUMENTED. YOU C. O. P.
RESERVES ARE NOT REPORTED
QUARTERLY TO THE UC REGENTS
ALONG WITH BUDGETED AMOUNT FOR
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES. THESE
PUBLIC QUARTERLY PRESENTATIONS
WILL CONTINUE UNCHANGED. YOU
SEE OKAY EMPLOYMENT DID AN
ENTIRE NEW BUDGET AND PLANNING
SYSTEM. ORACLE CLOUD FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS PROVIDES YOU STEAL
PEOPLE GENERAL LEDGER THAT
ALLOWS THE TRACKING OF PLANNED
BUDGETS AND ACTUAL EXPENDITURES.
WITH FAR GREATER EASE. USING
THIS AND HAS TRACKING SYSTEM
SEE OKAY NOW YOU ACTUAL X.
ABOARD. PROVIDE GREATER ACT.
THESE WERE FOR WILL STATE EVEN
AS DIFFERENT FUNDING
METHODOLOGY IS ADOPTED. OTHER
HELPFUL REFORMS THAT WERE
COMPLETED INCLUDE A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF EACH
USE YOU'LL BE FINE AND ITS USE.
THERE WAS ALSO AN EXPENSIVE
PROCESS TO DOCUMENT EACH
PROGRAM AN INITIATIVE AND
PROVIDE CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
EACH. A LONG LIST OF
IMPLEMENTED REFORMS MEANS THAT
THE UCP BUDGET TODAY IS NOT TO
USE YOUR B. BUDGET OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. TRANSPARENCY
DOCUMENTATION AND DECISION
MAKING YOU HAVE ALL CHANGED
THESE IMPORTANT CHANGES WILL
REMAIN EVEN AS THE FUNDING
MECHANISM CHANGES. AMONG THE
CHANGES FROM THE LINE ITEM WAS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW C. O.
P. UNALLOCATED RESERVES OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN PROVIDED BY
YOU STILL CREATE THE CAMPUS'S
LEADING YOU SEE OKAY WITH
UNALLOCATED RESERVE OF ZERO BY
JUNE TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS DID
CAUSE DIFFICULTIES AND
RESPONDING TO THE PANDEMIC WHEN
YOU C. O. P. COULD NOT BE
NIMBLE AND RESPONDING. TO
EVOLVING CAMPUS NEEDS. THIS
CALL CONSTRAINTS OF HAVING SEE
OKAY BUDGET MAINTAINS OR- SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN WERE VERY MUCH
HIGHLIGHTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR EXAMPLE WITH
HOSPITALS OPERATING CRISIS MODE
THAT WAS NEAT OUR SYSTEM WIDE
CHIEF CLINICAL OFFICER. IN
ORDER TO HIRE SUCH AN
INDIVIDUAL YOU SEE WHAT WE HAD
TO LET GO OTHER POSITIONS IN
ORDER TO FREE UP FUNDS FOR THE
CRITICAL FUNCTION. THIS SLOWED
DOWN HIRING BY MONTH'S END
MEANT THE LOSS OF EMPLOYEES WHO
CONDUCTED OTHER WORK FOR THE
SYSTEM. YOU STILL PAY COULD NOT
USE FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS FOR
EMERGENCY BECAUSE AS A SEPARATE
LINE ITEM WE COULD NOT RECEIVE
A RESPONSE FROM THE CAMPUSES. I
ASK THAT YOU APPROVED THE
CHANGE THAT YOU SEE OKAY
FUNDING METHODOLOGY. AND I'LL
MOVE ON TO THE LEARNING ALIGNED
IN GOVERNMENT NEXT AND I DO
HAVE SOMEONE HERE AS WELL WHO
CAN ANSWER QUESTIONS- WE ARE
VERY THANKFUL FOR THE- TRUST
THAT THE GOVERNOR PLACES AND
USE YOUR INVESTMENT TEAM IN
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT- THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A STATE
FUNDED LEARNING ALIGNED.
IMPLEMENT PROGRAM WOULD HELP
INCENTIVIZE MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR STUDENTS. DOING SO SERVES
THE STATE'S INTEREST BY
CREATING WELL PREPARED WORK
FORCE AS WELL AS A STRONGER
CONNECTION BETWEEN INSTITUTES
OF HIGHER EDUCATION THAT
EMPLOYERS. FURTHERMORE ELIZA ST
I'M PRESIDENT DRAKE'S INTEREST
IN PROVIDING DEBT FREE OPTIONS
FOR OUR STUDENTS. THE FIRST
PART OF CREATING A DEBT FREE
PATH IS MORE FINANCIALLY BUT
THESECOND PART IS CREATING
MEANINGFUL WORK FOR STUDENTS TO
SATISFY THE WORK STUDY
COMPONENT OF ANY FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE. CURRENTLY YOU SEE
CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER
MANAGES APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SIX. HUNDRED AND
SIXTY BILLION EXCUSE ME- IN
ASSETS SO ADDING A ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IS CERTAINLY POSSIBLE
AND YOU SEE HAS A PROCESS IN
PLACE. OR. MANAGING AFFILIATED
ENDOWMENTS. YOU STAND DOWN ARE
ABOUT FOUR POINT 75% INTEREST
PER. AND ALL AND- AND EARNINGS
ARE PAID AT THE END OF JUNE
YEAR. THIS MEANS OF THE PAYMENT
CAMPUSES WILL TAKE PLACE JUNE
TWENTY ONE TWO. I DO THINK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN THE
FIRST COUPLE YEARS MAYBE
SUBSTANTIAL AND I HOPE TO
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE SOON.
WHEN THE INVESTMENT NEEDED TO
GET PROGRAM OPERATIONAL IF
ADDITIONAL- INVESTMENT IS
NEEDED- I DO WANT TO EXPRESS A
CAUTION THE STOCK MARKET CAN
LOSE VALUE AND SOMETIMES.
GREATLY AS WE SAW IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. THIS MEANS THAT
THE INVESTED ENDOWMENT
PRINCIPAL CAN DECREASE IN VALUE
DUE TO FACTORS OUTSIDE IF YOU
SEIZE CONTROL. DURING THE YEARS
WHEN THE INVESTMENT VALUE TO
CLIENTS TO PAY OUT OF THE
PROGRAM WOULD ALSO DECLINE.
TAYLOR THE LANGUAGE- WE HAVE TO
COMPLIANCE CONCERNS. FIRST WE
DO NOT THINK THAT THE PROGRAM
CAN BE LIMITED TO UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS GIVEN THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISIONS OF PROP TWO OH NINE.
AND SECOND WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO PROVIDING THESE FUNDS JOHN
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS BUT WE NEED
TO NOTE THAT ONLY STUDENTS WITH
WORK AUTHORIZATION THEY HAVE
EMPLOYMENT EVEN IF. IT EVEN IF
IT IS STATE MONEY AND- THE
THIRD ISSUE I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION IS WHETHER THESE
FUNDS ARE PLACED IN AN
ENDOWMENT. OR A FUN FUNCTIONING
AS AN INDICTMENT. OF THESE TWO
FUNDS ARE VERY SIMILAR BUT THE
PRINCIPLE OF BEING DOWN IT
CANNOT BE WITHDRAWN EASILY. WE
RECOMMEND YOU APPROVE FUNDING
FUNCTIONING AS AN INDICTMENT IN
CASE YOU WISH TO MAKE CHANGES
TO THE PROGRAM OR RE UTILIZED
TO ONE BILLION PRINCIPAL FOR
NEW PURPOSE IN FUTURE YOUR- AND
THEN. LET ME JUST- QUICKLY
COVER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT OF THREE
TWENTY. THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TOWARDS UC'S
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
PROJECTS. IN OUR EARLIER
REQUEST MISTAKE WE HAD
IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF PROJECTS
THAT WOULD START VERY SOON. THE
REMAINING FUNDING WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO OUR CAMPUS IS
BASED ON A FORMULA. OF IN PARK
SQUARE FOOTAGE AND THE AGE OF
CAMPUS STATES A PORTABLE SPACE.
BERMAIN PROJECTS WILL COME FROM
A LIST OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS ALREADY IDENTIFIED BY
THE CAMPUSES. ARE CRITICAL
PROJECTS THAT ARISE AND WERE
PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN. EVERY UC
CAMPUS. WILL RECEIVE A PORTION
OF THESE FUNDS. THESE FUNDS
WILL ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES- COMPLETE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS AND
INCREASE LOCAL EMPLOYMENT. IN
ADDITION TO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE UC HAS BILLIONS IN
SEISMIC RENOVATION NEEDS AND
BUILDING UPGRADES. WE SUBMITTED
A ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
LIST FOR THESE PROECTS AND THE
GOVERNOR AND IF THE COMMITTEE
HAS AVAILABLE FUNDING JALAN KE
TOWARDS THESE PARTNERSHIPS WE
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT. NEXT LET
ME MOVE ON TO THE INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSALS BY THE GOVERNOR- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S SPACE
IN THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM AND LOOKING TO US FOR
EXPERTISE. JUST A TRUCK TOUCH
ON THESE VERY QUICKLY TO UCLA
LABOR CENTER EXERCISING GLOBAL
BY BUILDING THAT NEEDS TO BE
RENOVATED. UC SAN FRANCISCO
DYSLEXIA CENTER FUNDING. WOULD
HEY THE TRANSLATIONAL
NEUROSCIENCE RESEARCH AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO AND APPLY IT TO A
REAL USABLE TOOL FOR OUR
KINDERGARTEN FIRST AND SECOND
GRADE TEACHERS TO ASSESS
STUDENTS FOR LEARNING
DISABILITIES. CURRENTLY MANY
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
AND UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS WHO ARE EARLY ON IN
THEIR- SCHOOLING. ARE NOT
DIAGNOSED PROPERLY FOR LEARNING
DISABILITIES I'M PROVIDING
TEACHERS WITH THIS TOOL COULD
BE REALLY LIFE CHANGING FOR THE
STUDENTS. THE TOOL- IS GOING TO
BE USABLE ON A SIMPLE COMPUTER
IT WILL BE EXPANDED TO. OTHER
BRAIN FUNCTIONING STAR
FUNDAMENTAL FOR SCHOOL
READINESS READINESS AND READING
A QUESTION C. INCLUDING WORKING
MEMORY LANGUAGE COMPREHENSION
OF START REASONING TASK
SHIFTING AND COGNITIVE AND
EMOTIONAL CONTROL. ATTENTION
EMOTIONAL RECOGNITION AND
EMOTION REGULATION- WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON A SPANISH VERSION OF
THAT RULE SO WE REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL EXPANDS. AND FINALLY-
THE ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES OF
FUNDING IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN A DRAMATIC
INCREASE OF HATE INCIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MAKE CERTAIN
THAT- THESE SORTS OF INCIDENTS
DON'T SPREAD IT AND R.
ALLEVIATED WE REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL OF THESE FUNDS. THE
BERKELEY ALTERNATIVE NEEDS LAST
MONDAY WILL BE USED- TOWARDS
PROVIDING FOOD ALTERNATIVES
WHICH ARE VERY IMPORTANT OR-
CLIMATE CHANGE AND NOW LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO- OUR DIRECTOR
OF DEFEAT CORRECT- ADAMS SHIP
CORRECT SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM KATE HURLEY DR KATE
HURLEY WHO WILL. BRIEFLY.
DISCUSS THE- ANIMAL SHOW PO. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW TO
BRIEFLY SO- PLEASE IT BECAUSE
HAVE A- FOR MORE ITEMS AND A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ON THIS
UNLIMITED TALK SO WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I JUST TRIED A LITTLE
TINY BIT OF CONTEXT SENSING
ANIMAL SHELTERS ARE NOT
COMMONLY DISCUSSED IN THE
COMMITTEE. THE PROPOSAL WAS
ORIGINALLY ENTERED INTRODUCED
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY IN
THE CONTEXT OF MORE ANIMALS
LOSING THEIR LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA SHELTERS AND IN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE LAST.IN
SPITE OF THE STATE'S POLICY
BALL SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT NO HEALTHIER TREATABLE
ANIMAL BE EUTHANIZED THAT WERE
THE MOST POPULOUS STATE IN THE
COUNTRY TO BE FAIR AND THERE
HAS BEEN SOME PROGRESS MADE BUT%
MANY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES SEVEN LEFT BEHIND.
AND RURAL AREAS AND POCKETS OF
URBAN AREAS. AND WE STILL SEE
THE HIGHEST RATES OF INTAKE AND
EUTHANASIA AND ARTS REGIONS
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. AND ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE SERVED BY
SHELTERS THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO KEEP ANIMALS HEALTHY AND
SAFE GET THEM OUT THE DOOR
LIGHTS AND KEEP PETS AND PEOPLE
TOGETHER. AND THEN TO PROVIDE
SOME MORE RECENT CONTACTS THE
COMBINATION. AND WILDFIRES
HIGHLIGHTED THE ESSENTIAL ROLE
THAT SHOT JUST PLAY IN
CALIFORNIA'S CRISIS RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY SHELTERS PROVIDING
CARE FOR PETS AND PEOPLE ARE
HOSPITALIZED WITH COLIN. THEY
FOUND WAYS TO DELIVER IT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOME BOUND SO IT
COULD STAY WITH THEIR ANIMALS
THEY CARE FOR PETS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE DISPLACED BY WILDFIRES
AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A GROUP
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY RECALL. A KEEPING
DANGEROUS INTERNET ANIMALS- OFF
THE STREETS AND PROPERLY CARED
FOR AGAIN WE SAW THE LEAST
RESOURCE CENTER STRUGGLING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE HARDEST
HIT COMMUNITIES. AND AS WE MOVE
INTO THE RECOVERY PHASE WE ALSO
SEE THAT WE ARE SEEING SOME
THREATS AS SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO
GO BACK TO WORK AND OTHER
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH THE ECONOMIC. FALLOUT IN
INTAKE CONTINUES TO RISE AT
SHELTERS SO THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT WOULD PROVIDE BOTH
THE TRAINING FOR OUR PROGRAM.
AND THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TARGETED GRANTS FOR SOLDIERS TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE AND FAMILIES.
THROUGHOUT THE RECOVERY AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU I WAS VERY
ENOUGH. YES HE WORKED WITH YOU
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
QUEST BUT LET ME MAKE A COMMON
ABOUT THAT FOR. IT WHICH IS. I
CHAIRED A MAY SPECIAL ONE I WAS
IN ASSEMBLY AND THE ESTIMATE
FOR THE ANNUAL COST OF THAT
MANDATE AT THE TIME OF THE
ADOPTION OF THE BILL. IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WAS THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THEN
THIS LINE ITEM IS FIFTEEN TIMES
THAT IT IS A FRACTION OF WHAT
THE STATE SPENDS ON ANIMAL
SHELTERS AND SO. THAT THAT IS
JUST A CONTEXT TO BE
CONSIDERED. THE THERE THERE WAS
A LOT OF SUBJECTS ARE RAISED
HERE AND SO WHAT THE BEGIN OF
WITH A FEW QUESTIONS AND THEN
GO TO MY COLLEAGUES. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WERE ME
BEGIN BY ASKING WHAT THE
RATIONALE WAS. FOR KEEPING
ENROLLMENT FLAT AT UC AND NOT
FUNDING ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SURE
LAYERED SO THE MAY REVISION AS
YOU KNOW DOES NOT SPECIFY
ENROLLMENT TARGETS FOR YOU SEE
THIS IS ALSO FOR CSU- WE
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT ROLE MEANT. AT UC AND
CSU IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE OPEN TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH UC AND CSU ON WHAT
A ROMAN TARGETS COULD LOOK LIKE
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE. AS
PRIORITIES FOR THOSE SECONDS.
LET ME JUST MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT BECAUSE WE JUST HAD A
HEARING ON ON THIS LAST WEEK.
AND I THINK THE DYNAMICS WERE
FASCINATING WHICH IS. THE
LEGISLATURE WAS VERY INTERESTED
IN- ANNULMENT CAP THE TWO
CAMPUSES WITH THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF OUT OF STATE STUDENTS WE
HEARD FROM SOME OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS THAT DON'T. WANT
CHANGES AND WE ALSO HEARD FROM
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING DIVERTED
FROM THEIR FIRST CHOICE THAT
OUR- KIDS OF CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. AND SO THE FACT THAT
26% OF UC BERKELEY FOR EXAMPLE
WAS OUT OF STATE STUDENTS IS
JUSTIFIED ON THE MONEY IT
BRINGS BUT THEN A NUMBER OF IN
STATE STUDENTS ARE BEING
DIVERTED AWAY FROM THAT AS
THEIR FIRST CHOICE. AND SO IT
IS ME MOVING PIECES AND IF
THERE IS. TO BE SOME CHANGES IN
THAT WHICH YOU SEE CLEARLY
DIDN'T WANT ONE POINT WE
DISCUSSED THIS LAST WEEK ONE OF
THE WAYS TO CUSHION THAT IS
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AND IMPLY THAT IN STATE
STUDENTS IN A WAY THAT IT
RELEASES THAT PRESSURE SOME
MORE SO. THAN JUST MAKE THAT
COMMENT AND WE WILL GO TO IT. I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE- THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. LINE ITEM
THAT WAS DISCUSSED BY DO PEOPLE.
AND- LET ME GO TO YOU FIRST-
YOU MENTIONED IN THE COMMENTS.
AN AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION
THAT HAD BEEN IMPLEMENTED THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED ITS
OWN LINE ITEM. AT THE TIME OF
THAT AUDIT HAS UC IMPLEMENTED
ALL OF THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SURE
LAYERED- UC HAS IMPLEMENTED THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE STATE
AUDITOR OF THE ONE
RECOMMENDATION BUT THE AUDITOR
WOULD LIKE US TO CONTINUE. TO-
MOORE IS HAVING THE REGENTS
APPROVED A UC ABOUT OPIATE
BUDGET. BY MARCH- FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR- FOR THE NEXT
YEAR AND BECAUSE THE REGIONS
DON'T GET AT THAT TIME HAVE THE
INFORMATION AS TO HOW MUCH
STATE GENERAL FUND THE SYSTEM
WILL HAVE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO DO THAT. YOU SEE
REGIONS DO APPROVE A PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR YOU C. O. P. H.
NOVEMBER- AND WE PUT THAT
FORWARD. TO YOU AND TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR AS A FUNDING
REQUEST. EACH YEAR SO WE ARE
PUBLICIZING OUR FINANCIAL NEED
AND OUR INTENT AS EARLY AS
pDOESN'T GET APPROVED UNTIL
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROVED THANK YOU SEE BYE JEFF
SO. OUR TIMING WISE STAR SOME
ISSUES WITH THAT BUT THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS TOP AND-
IMPLEMENTED. AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. JUST BECAUSE-
THE MOVE THE LINE ITEM. DID NOT
COME FROM THIS HOUSE BUT IF IN
FACT- THERE'S GOING TO BE ANY
CHANGE A THRESHOLD ISSUE WILL
BE. THAT THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE TO HAVE
BEEN MET SO I THINK. THE ROOM
NOT EVEN AT THIS HEARING BUT
MAYBE ONE IN THE OTHER HOUSE
THAT'S WHERE THAT'S GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE OF AN ISSUE. AND
INCLUDED. IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IS- AGATE NATURAL
RESOURCES A. N. R. AND I ASKED
THE QUESTION AT A PREVIOUS
HEARING AND GOT A UNSATISFYING
ANSWER AND IT REFLECTS ON THIS
ISSUE SO LET ME TRY AGAIN. I
THINK THE COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED. IN TRYING TO HELP
COOPERATIVE AGRICULTURAL
EXTENSION THAT GOES THROUGH YOU
SEE TO THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IF THE
FUNDING IS BEEN FLAT FOR TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS THERE WERE MAJOR
CUTS MADE AT THE TIME OF THE
REDUCTIONS AND SO THEY'RE BEEN
VACANCIES IN STEP BACKS AND
GRADUAL CUTS OVER TIME. AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN USING THIS
ECONOMIC SITUATION TO MOVE
AHEAD AND WHEN I PASSED AT A
PREVIOUS HEARING AND I WANNA
TRY TO PARAPHRASE CORRECTLY. IF
WE PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
THAT PURPOSE HOW WE WERE
GUARANTEED IT WOULD GO FOR THAT
PURPOSE. THERE WAS NOT A
PARTICULARLY SATISFYING ANSWER
SO ONLY ASK AGAIN. IF WE WERE
TO PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET. TO
TRY TO REHABILITATE- AG
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION PROGRAM
HOW DO WE KNOW EVERY DOLLAR WE
PUT FOR THAT PURPOSE WE'LL GO
FOR THAT PURPOSE AND THAT'S TO
UC. THANK YOU SIR THE WAY WE
GUARANTEE THAT FUNDING WILL GO
TO A PARTICULAR PROGRAM IS TO
PUT IN- BUDGET BILL TAXED. INTO
A BUDGET BILL WE WOULD ALSO
REPORT TO YOU ANNUALLY- AND YOU
CAN ALSO YOUR STAFF WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE THE PUBLIC
QUARTERLY REPORTING HAPPENING
TO THE REGIONS. ARE ALL YOU SEE
ARE YOU C. O. P. PROGRAMS
WHICH- THAT REPORTING WILL
CONTINUE AND BE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE- BY HAVING. A BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE RATHER THAN A
SPECIFIC LINE ITEM BUT DIRECTED
LANGUAGE YOU CAN- HAVE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS FUNDED AT
ANY LEVEL THAT YOU CHOOSE. AND
WE WILL DEFINITELY HEAR YOU ON
YOUR WISHES AND ENSURE THAT UC
ANR FUNCTIONS ARE FUNDED AT THE
LEVEL YOU WANT. THERE ARE TWO
POSSIBLE FUNDING MECHANISMS
WITHOUT THE LINE ITEM THAT CAN
ALSO BE UTILIZED ONE IS THE
CAMPUS ASSESSMENT THAT WE
UTILIZE PRIOR TO THE LINE ITEM.
WE ALSO HAVE SOMETHING CALLED
CAMPUS SET ASIDES. THESE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED SORT
OF OFF THE TOP OF THE GENERAL
ALLOCATION BEFORE THE FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED FOR OTHER PURPOSES-
WE FIND CERTAIN PROGRAMS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO OUR SYSTEM
IN THIS MANNER. FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE PROGRAMS RECEIVE A- SET
ASIDE. EACH YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE FULLY FUNDED- SO DO
THE AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENT
STATIONS SO WE COULD MOVE AT UC
ANR TWO EIGHT SET ASIDE. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT. THEY ARE
GUARANTEED A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
FUNDING. OKAY I THINK OUR STAFF
MIGHT WORK WITH YOU ON THAT IT
REALLY REFLECTS ON THE ISSUE
OF- BOTTOM. OF THE LINE ITEM
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
WE APPROPRIATE FOR SOMETHING IT
GOES FOR SOMETHING. AND SO. YOU
KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
YOU JUST SAID TO YOU. AND I'M
ALWAYS- A SKEPTIC IN SOME WAYS
BECAUSE IT LOOKED LIKE THERE
MIGHT BE A COUPLE OF LOOPHOLES
IN THERE I JUST WANT TO KNOW
FOR SURE. THAT WITH
APPROPRIATED FOR PURPOSE IT
GOES FOR THE PURPOSE OF WILL
HAVE THE STAFF WORK WITH YOU IN
CASE STARTS BUDGET LANGUAGE
SURE- FULL FURTHER THINGS AND
THEN. MAYBE ONE MORE QUESTION
BEFORE GOING TO MY COLLEAGUES.
MMHM THE THERE WAS THE ISSUE OF
I WOULD REFER TO IT AS A WORK
STUDY PROGRAM BOOKMARK BASED
FINANCIAL AID THAT WAS
DISCUSSED- IN MAY BE STARTING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHY ö
BASED FINANCIAL AID A PRIORITY
OVER DIRECT GRANT AID. WHY WAS
THAT DECISION MADE TO DO IT
THAT WAY. SEOUL SAY THAT THIS
IS IN COMBINATION WITH
CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN THE
STATE'S MOST SIGNIFICANT DIRECT
AID CAL GRANTS SIX CETERA. THIS
IS A SUPPLEMENTARY- PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE AIMED AT THE
OVERALL ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU THE HIGH
LEVEL JUSTIFICATION THERE IT'S
THAT. BIG PICTURE QUESTION HOW
DO YOU TURN ONE TIME. FUNDING
WHEN THE STATE ONLY HAS
RESOURCES ONE TIME- DOESN'T
CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE AND
MAKE THAT AN ONGOING RESOURCE
AND THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD WITH THE
ENDOWMENT CREATE AN ONGOING PAY
OUT. TO STUDENTS IN ALL THE
SEGMENTS AND THAT THAT'S OUR-
THE ALTERNATIVE OF MAKING SOME
ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN DIRECT
AID. WOULD ONLY HAVE THAT ONE
TIME IMPACT ON ON ONE YEAR OF
STUDENTS OR OR YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY ONE COHORT BUT THIS
PROPOSAL WAS FRAMED. TO ATTACK
THE BIGGER PROBLEM OF
AFFORDABILITY AND WE'RE FOCUSED
ON THE THAT BIG QUESTION OUT.
IN ADDITION TO MAINTAINING AND
PROVIDING DIRECT SUBSIDIES
THROUGH CAL GRANT THAT ALREADY
EXIST HOW DO YOU SUPPLEMENT
THAT WITH WITH AN ONGOING
RESOURCE. THANK YOU A FREE
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION AND
THIS ALSO IS A THING WE HAD A
HEARING ON- LAST WEEK. AND I
THINK IT WAS OUR GENERAL
DIRECTION. THAT BROADLY
REFORMED A CAL GRANT PROGRAM
WITH LESS RESTRICTIONS ALLOWING
REENTRY STUDENTS ARE EXPEDITED
PROCESS ALLOWING FOR- FORK
SPENCE'S THAT WEREN'T JUST
FEES. WORK ORDER THAT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY OF DOING THAT
NOW AND I KNOW THAT SME OF IT
IS ON GOING MONEY BUT I THINK
THAT THE- THE COMMITTEE IS
REALLY INTERESTED IN THAT AND
SO I MAKE THAT STATEMENT NOW
JUST WITH THIS ITEM WE'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING THEM STUDENT AID
COMMISSION LATER AND- THERE ARE
MANY PIECES OF STUDENT AID THAT
ARE IN DIFFERENT PARTS. OF THE
BUDGET FOR THE THREE BRANCHES
BUT I WOULD. CALL THAT OUT AS A
AS A CONCERN OF THE COMMITTEE
AS AS WE MOVE THROUGH- OTHER
THINGS. AND LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE- I'M SORRY I HAVE A-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RAISED
HAND. THANK YOU MR CHAIR BACK
OCCURRED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST TO ADD TO MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSAL ONE
OTHER KEY BENEFIT THAT WE SEE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL COMPARED TO
JUST TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL AID
APPROACHES IS BECAUSE IT OFFERS
LEARNING ALIGNED EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICULARLY
GEARED TO UNDER REPRESENTED OR
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS. IT'S OFFERING
WORKFORCE CONNECTIONS TO THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY MAY NOT
OTHERWISE ENCOUNTER OR HAVE AS
NATURALLY AS THEIR FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT FROM AN
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUP. NUMBER
WANTED PRITCHARD THAT COMMENT I
THINK IT DOES IT NEGATE WHAT I
JUST SAID THAT MAYBE IN FACT.
WE DO IT ALL. GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE'S ONE TIME MONEY SO
IT IS REALLY THE BROADER DIRECT
STUDENT AID AND THEN WORK
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE BENEFITS
THAT COME FROM THAT BUT I THINK
WE- THIS IS A ONCE IN A
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO
REFORM THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
IN. IT AND I DON'T WANT TO DO
IT AROUND THE EDGES OF SO WE
WILL SEE WHERE WE GET BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT. I WAS
GONNA GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR QUESTIONS-
WHO- CENTER ROAD SCHAUMBURG AND
THEN SENATOR MEANT. GOOD
MORNING. I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE U. C. M. CAN YOU CAN
USE THE COMMON UNDER
CONSIDERATION OF INCREASING
TUITION BEGINNING FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I'M CURIOUS
AS TO THE OUTSTANDING FUNDS
NEEDED TO- FINDING. NEEDS GIVEN
THE MAY REVISION FOR THE
UPCOMING YEAR- PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED SIX
MILLION IN UNDERGOING FUNDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR UC REGENTS ARE
CONSIDERING A NEW TUITION
FINANCING MODEL CALLED COVERT
BASED TUITION WHICH WOULD
ENSURE THAT WHILE ENROLLED NO
YOU SEE STUDENT WOULD SEE THEIR
FEES INCREASED. THE FEES WOULD
INCREASE- BEFORE THE STUDENT
AND ROLLS AND THEY WOULD KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE COST OF THEIR
EDUCATION WOULD BE. MODEL HAS
NOT YET BEEN ADOPTED NOR ARE
HAS TUITION BEEN INCREASED OR-
OR FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO
THAT IS STILL BEING CONSIDERED
AND THE MODEL MAY BE ADOPTED
WITHOUT RAISING TUITION AS
WELL- THE INTENT OF THE MODEL
IS TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO
STUDENTS FALL THEY'RE INVOLVED
AT THEIR FEES WOULD NOT
INCREASE. AND IT WOULD BE- ALSO
INCREASE THE FINANCIAL AID
AVAILABLE TO OUR POOREST
STUDENTS TO HELP THEM KEEP UP
WITH THE COST OF LIVING SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE OUT
MORE LOANS TO LONGER THERE ARE
GOLD- IF I CAN ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IT. JUST FOR A MOMENT
BECAUSE I THINK. THE CALL WAS
JUST ABOUT THE MODEL AND IN
DEFENSE OF YOU EE. THE
DISCUSSION OF TUITION WAS
INITIATED ON THE AGENDA BEFORE
ANYBODY KNEW WHAT TO MAY REVISE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WAS GOING TO
BE I THINK THE QUESTION IS.
SORT OF WHY RAISE TUITION. A
WITH ALL THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT'S BASE LEVEL FUNDING
THAT'S COMING FROM THE STATE
FOR UC IT. THANK YOU SIR FOR
THE CLARIFICATION- IF YOU SEE
WAS TO RECEIVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO COVER OUR COSTS FOR
OPERATING INCREASES FOR. THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YEAR WE
MAY NOT HAVE NEED TO RAISE
TUITION AND THOSE DECISIONS MAY
BE PUT OFF- FURTHER INTO THE
FUTURE AND THEN THAT. LEADS TO
THE OPENING OF WHAT IS ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO DIVERT THAT DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT WHAT'S IN THE MAY
REVISE IS ADEQUATE. TO NOT. TO
HANDLE THE BASE FUNDING
EXPENSES TO NOT GO TO THE
REGIONS FOR TUITION INCREASE-
IT IS FORTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO PER YEAR WHICH
COVERS- ARE. ARE REQUESTED MOST
OF OUR REQUESTED INVESTMENTS
AND ALL OF OUR MANDATORY COST
INCREASES- BUT FOUR D. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR AT
THE UNIVERSITY WILL HAVE. YET
ANOTHER SET OF MANDATORY COST
INCREASES THAT WILL DISCUSS
NEXT YEAR WITH YOU AND
HOPEFULLY THE STATE'S REVENUES
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ROBUST AND
TUITION INCREASE SAYS- DO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE UNDERTAKEN OR
CAN BE REVERSED. SO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE NOT PERMITTED IN
ANY WAY- THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN
PRIOR YEARS BOUGHT OUT YOU
SEIZED- TUITION INCREASES
AREN'T WHAT ME THANK MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR TROUBLED FOR
LETTING ME DO THAT FOLLOW UP
AND CLARIFICATION WILL GO BACK
TO HER. FOR A REMAINING
QUESTIONS. THIS IS WHY TRUST
EXPERTISE IN YOUR- AND- LAYERED
YOU CAN COME IN AT ANY TIME.
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES. AND
I DO HAVE A QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO- THE MANY ITEMS THAT
WE ARE- FINANCING- IN ARGENTA-
THE ON GOING AND THE ONE TIME
FUNDING AND SO FORTH. I'M KIND
OF YOURS AND I BELIEVE THIS MAY
BE A QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WITH REGARDS TO ACCOUNTABILITY
SO THE STATE IS INVESTING A LOT
OF MONEY IN THESE PROGRAMS HOW
DOES THE STATE HAD TO DO WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- FOLLOW UP AND
MAKE SURE THAT. THESE FINDINGS
ARE- SPENT THE WAY THAT THEY
ARE BEING APPROPRIATED IS THERE
ANY- TOOLS OR ANYTHING IN SUCH
A THAT WILL HAVE IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY. MOVING FORWARD
SAY IN A YEAR TWO YEARS WHEN WE
HAVE A REPORT OR DO WE HAVE A
REPORT THAT COMES BACK AND SAYS
OKAY THIS IS HOW WE SPEND THE
MONEY. YEAH THAT'S A- THAT'S A
KEY QUESTION OF THE LEGISLATURE
FACES EVERY YEAR- WHAT'S THAT
SO LOOK THERE TWO WAYS REALLY
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO ENSURE
THE FUNDS ARE OURS STANDS- THE
WAITING TENS AND IDEALLY THE
LEGISLATURE DOES BOTH THE FIRST
IS TO SPECIFY PROVISIONS IN THE
BUDGET BILL ITSELF THAT DIRECT-
FOR EXAMPLE YOU SEE HOW TO
SPEND THE FUNDS- AND THEN THE
SECOND- TOOL TO THE LEGISLATURE
HAS. IS REPORTING- AFTER THAT-
INITIATIVE HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED-
USUALLY DOES SUBMIT A NUMBER OF
REPORTS BUT FOR A LOT OF THESE
NEW INITIATIVES PARTICULARLY
ONE TIME INITIATIVES- IN ORDER
TO GET INFORMATION YOU NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OTHERWISE THERE
THERE WON'T BE- AUTOMATIC
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE-
THE REGIONS DO- OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS SO SOMETIMES THESE.
INITIATIVES ARE DISCUSSED IN
THE BOARD OF REGENTS AND- THOSE
pLEGISLATURE ALSO HAS THE
ABILITY TO HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS IN
FUTURE YEARS ON THESE
INITIATIVES. I'M ALSO MANY
INITIATIVES IN THE BUDGET
OBVIOUSLY THAT CAN BE THAT CAN
BE QUITE CHALLENGING- TO DO ON
EVERY ITEM SO I TYPICALLY
REPORTING LANGUAGE ON THIS
PRETTY KEY THERE. WHEN IT COMES
TO REPORTING LANGUAGE.
SOMETIMES THERE'S A TEMPTATION
TO HAVE REPORTING LANGUAGE BE
VERY BOILER PLATE. A VERY
SIMPLISTIC BUT- USUALLY IT'S
HELPFUL TO THINK ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE ULTIMATE OBJECTIVES THAT-
THIS INITIATIVE IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND THEN THINKING ABOUT
WHICH OUTCOMES- UNIVERSITY
COULD REPORT THAT- ENSURE THE
LEGISLATURE'S TRACKING THAT
THOSE ULTIMATE UTCOMES WERE
MET. SO THERE ARE SOME OF THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT WILL START. WHEN DO WE
START. REQUIRING THAT LANGUAGE
SHOULD BE ADAM. WELL WE COULD
DO LANGUAGE AS PART OF THE
BUDGET APPROVAL IF THAT'S WHAT
WE WANTED TO DO AND I THINK
THAT THAT CENTER ROAD TROUBLE
RAISES A REALLY REALLY GOOD
ISSUE BECAUSE AS WE MOVE
BROADER IN THIS BUDGET. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S SOME TRANSPARENCY AND
HOW THINGS ARE BEING SPENT AND
WHETHER IT'S ACHIEVING WHAT WAS
REPRESENTED IN THE BUDGET AND-
NORMALLY WE DO OVERSIGHT AND
NORMALLY THERE CAN BE CERTAIN
REPORTS I THINK WE JUST HAVE TO
DECIDE IF WE WANT TO ASK FOR
SPECIFIC REPORTS. FOR WHITE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS OR FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE WANT TO DO BUT IT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION
AND I THINK. I'LL TALK TO THE
STAFF ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S SOMETHING TO BE DONE
THERE. THANK YOU THE SECOND
PLEASE YOUR QUESTIONS SENATOR
MEN. THANK YOU TURN ALERT- I
GUESS I WANT TO START BY JUST.
APPLAUDING IT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR I KNOW OF AND-
PRIORITIES I THINK- RESTORATION
OF IN IN AUGMENT I'VE THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF THESE- I ALSO
WOULD COMMAND ALL- HIGHLIGHTING
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF ANTI
ASIAN HATE. I DO WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF CHAIR LAYERED
ON DO YOU SEE IN OUR PROGRAMS-
IT TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE ALL DEALING WITH THIS IS.
YOU KNOW WHETHER I'S THE
ELIMINATION OF THE U. COP LINE
ITEM. WHETHER IT'S- YOU KNOW
TRYING TO ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR
SPECIFIC PURPOSE HAPPEN HOW DO
WE KNOW IS MY COLLEAGUE- CENTER
TO A TO A BOOK HE SAID. THAT
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE BEING.
USED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSES IN AN EFFICIENT WAY.
OF DOING THAT I JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- FIRST ON THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR ENDOWMENT. I
SEE THE PURPOSE OF THIS IT'S I
THINK VERY INTERESTING
INNOVATIVE AS YOUSAID AND AS A
FORMER LAW PROFESSOR. I KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF WORK BASED
EXPERIENCE INTERNSHIPS
EXTERNSHIPS AND ALLIED- I GUESS
MY MAIN QUESTION AND I THINK
SENATOR. LAYER TO GOT TO THIS A
LITTLE BIT. BUT TO WHAT DEGREE
IS THIS DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND I GUESS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I KNOW THAT
STUDENTS IN THE UC'S WHETHER
THEIR UNDERGRADS AND GRAD
STUDENTS. OUR OUR GUEST AT SEA
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THROUGH ALL
THE DIFFERENT AID PROGRAMS ALL
THE DIFFERENT- PROGRAMS THAT
THEY CAN ACCESS. AND IT CAN BE
QUITE CONFUSING FOR THEM
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS THE
RESOURCES WITHIN THE CAMPUSES
TO CONNECT UP STUDENTS WITH THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF AID THAT
THEY MIGHT RECEIVE. I ALSO KNOW
THAT EVERY TIME YOU CREATE NEW
PROGRAM- YOU HAVE MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WHICH TAP
INTO THAT EFFECTIVELY CREATING
A TAX ON. THE PHONE SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS TO WHAT DEGREE
IS THIS APPROACH- DUPLICATIVE
OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR A PERIL EITHER
PARALLEL PURPOSES OR THIS EXACT
PURPOSE OF FUNDING INTERNSHIPS
AND EXTERNSHIPS. AND I'LL BE BY
YOUR QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND ALSO DO YOU SEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR MEANT. SO THE FROMOUR
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS NOT TO PUT
IT IN FOR IT IS DESIGNED TO
PARALLEL THE EXISTING FEDERAL
WORK STUDY PROGRAM. THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THE FEDERAL
WORK STUDY PROGRAM HAS A- A
BROADER CAME. BY SO OUR OUR
PROGRAM THE STATE FUNDED
VERSION WOULD FOCUS YOU HAVE TO
BE AN UNDERREPRESENTED
BACKGROUND- AS A STUDENT- WHERE
IS THE FEDERAL IS FOCUSED MORE
ON DEMONSTRATED FINANCIAL NEED.
OURS WOULD ALSO PRIORITIZE STEM
MAJORS AND STEM- EMPLOYERS. DID
THE OTHER KEY DIFFERENCE HERE
AND THIS IS THE ROOT OF THE WHY
HAVE THIS PROGRAM AT ALL IT'S
THAT THE FEDERAL WORK STUDY-
TARGETS ONE ISSUE WHICH IS. IF
YOU'RE A STUDENT HI AND YOU
YOU'RE ENTERING AS A FRESHMAN.
AND YOU WORK WITH THE FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM MADE YOU THE IS
PACKAGE AND YOU SHOULD TRY TO
WORK EXPERTS. TOWARDS EUROPE OF
CONTRA. YOU CAN THAT FINANCE
AID FOR THAT THEY YOU. YOU SAW
UP ARE YOU WORK IN THE LIBRARY
FOR FIFTEEN TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK- AND THAT HELPS YOUR YOUR
FINANCIAL SITUATION. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TAKE THAT WHEN
YOU'RE CONTRIBUTING TO YOUR
FINANCIAL AID- CONTRIBUTION AS
AS DESIGNED BY THE FINANCIAL
AID ADMINISTRATORS WITH YOU. WE
DON'T WANT THAT JUST TO BE
YOU'RE GETTING AN HOURLY WAGE
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT SO THAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY LINKED UP WITH
AN EMPLOYER THAT'S EITHER IN
YOUR MAJOR OR- OR IT HAS
INDICATED TO THE UC CAMPUS THAT
THEY'RE POTENTIALLY GOING TO
HIRE FUTURE UC GRADUATES. SO
WE'RE TRYING TO LINK THE HOURLY
WAGE WITH ALSO LONGER TERM
CAREER DEVELOPMENT. SIEVE IF
THAT'S ENOUGH I COULD STOP
THERE BUT YET LET ME REPHRASE
MY QUESTION BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND YEAH THIS ISN'T NOT
MEANT TO BE FOR STUDIES IS NOT
WORKING IN THE LIBRARY OR THE
CAFETERIA. IT'S ABOUT
INTERNSHIPS AND EXTERNSHIPS AS
THEIR FAMILIARLY KNOWN AS IS MY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOUR PRODUCT
HERE IS. I GUESS I JUST
QUESTION- BLUNTLY IS. WATER
PROGRAMS ALREADY EXIST
STATEWIDE AND SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S NONE AND
THEN AT THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
WHERE I KNOW THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR INTERNSHIPS AND
EXTERNSHIPS. YOU KNOW HAVE YOU
MAPPED THAT OUT TO WHAT DEGREE
DOES THIS TACK ON TO THOSE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- YOU KNOW I
JUST DON'T HAVE A SENSE I KNOW
THAT MY FORMER EMPLOYER. YOU
SEE AROUND SCHOOL LAW WE HAD
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR INTERNSHIPS AND
EXTERNSHIPS. FOR SOME STUDENTS
I DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF THE
SCALE OF THAT OUTSIDE OF LAW
SCHOOL. OR CERTAINLY OUTSIDE OF
THE UC IRVINE CAMPUS BUT I
GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION-
THAT'S YET THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION I WOULD SAY WE
DEFINITELY TAKE YOUR POINT
THAT. PER CAMPUS THERE'S A
RANGE OF VARIOUS INTERNET
EXTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. THE
KEY DIFFERENCE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND WHY THIS WOULD
BE NECESSARY IS THAT. WHEN YOU
HAVE A FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE
THROUGH THE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM- THOUGH DOES INTERNSHIPS
AND EX EXTERNSHIP CAN OFTEN BE
A SEPARATE FROM THE DESIGN OF
THAT PACKAGE. AND SO THE IDEA
HERE IS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE BUILT IN O. YOUR AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH YEAR YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE TO SAY YOU'RE GONNA
RECEIVE EXPEL GRANT X. CETERA-
AND THEN. THEY'RE GONNA HELP
ALIGN YOU WITH THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT'S GOING TO CONTRIBUTE PART
OF YOUR OVERALL- FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE AS YOUR YOUR WORK STUDY
CONTRIBUTION. SO THAT'S JUST
IT'S A MORE OF A CLOSE LINKAGE
BETWEEN THE OVERALL EXISTING
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM. THEN IT
EXISTS WITH NECESSARILY ALL OF
THE INDIVIDUAL. IT'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY SET UP FRONT.
ASSESSOR FOR UP FRONT- OFFERING
RATHER THAN SORT OF SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS EACH SUMMER I TAKE
IT. GREAT YEAH YEAH I GUESS
THAT'S THE THEME IS MORE IT'S
GREATER IT'S BETTER ALIGNS TO
FINANCIAL AID ADMINISTRATION.
GOT IT. I I'M NOT SURE ANY DAY
I THINK YOU ANSWERED MY
QUESTION BUT IF THE YOU SEE HAS
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. OKAY.
MY SECOND QUESTION YOU HAVE
OME YOU KNOW REALLY
INTERESTING AND I THINK- YOU
KNOW IMPORTANT RESEARCH
PRIORITIES THAT YOU ALLOCATE
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR HERE I'M
TALKING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
YOU GOT ANIMAL SHELTERS
DYSLEXIA ALTERNATIVE MEAT AND I
THINK A FEW OTHERS. I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS HOW WERE THESE
RESEARCH PRIORITIES CHOSEN.
OVER ANY OTHER PRIORITY AND- I
GUESS GIVEN YOU KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WILDFIRES RIGHT NOW
WHY WERE THESE SAYING A
COLLECTED AND NOT GIVEN
RESEARCH FINDING WHERE I THINK
RESEARCH IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR THESE PARTICULAR
AREAS. ARE AND WHY WERE SOME OF
THESE OTHER ONES SELECTED. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ALL ALL
I CAN'T SPEAK RESPECTFULLY TO
WHAT'S NOT WHAT'S NOT HERE SO.
NO NO CLEAR JUSTIFICATION WE'RE
NOT GOING TO JUSTIFY WHY IT'S
NOT. IN HERE BUT THE- THE HOW
WERE THESE SHOWS AND THESE ARE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES.
CIVICALLY THE EASIEST TO POINT
TO IS THE ANIMAL SHELTER GRANT
PROGRAM. WE HAD PROPOSED THAT
LAST YEAR. DUE TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY COMPLEXITY. WE DIDN'T
MANAGE TO REACH THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF GETTING A FULLY FUNDED
GRANT PROGRAM. SO THAT'S BACK
IN HERE OF COURSE THE- IS AN
AMERICAN STUDIES CENTER THAT
WAS A UNIDENTIFIED NEED THAT'S
BEEN EXACERBATED RECENTLY AND
SO THAT'S SPEAKING TO THAT- AND
THE SAME WITH DYSLEXIA IS AN
ESTABLISHED ADMINISTRATION
PRIORITY. ABOUT THE RESTORATION
OF LOTS OF PRIORITIES I GUESS-
YEAH YEAH I GUESS MY QUESTION
WRIT LARGE AS WOULD HAVE BEEN.
PERHAPS MORE EFFICIENT THEY
JUST SAID WE WANT TO FIND X.
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS FOR GENERAL
RESEARCH ON WHAT THE UC'S
DECIDE WHERE THAT'S BEST. THE
PURPOSE. I WOULD SAY THIS IS
JUST A CASE OF US TRYING TO BE
SPECIFIC IT AND PRIORITIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- PRIORITIES SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE REPRESENTED IN
THESE THESE ARE PROPOSALS. I
APPRECIATE THAT I ONE LAST
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE JUST
BEFORE YOU GO TO THAT QUICK
QUESTION LET ME ADD. A COMMENT.
SENATOR AND THAT IS I WAS
VISITED BY REPRESENTATIVES FOR
TRULY A BY REPRESENTATIVES OF
UC BERKELEY LAST WEEK. BECAUSE
THEY'RE SEEKING IN THE CLIMATE
CENTER TO DO WILD FIRE RESEARCH
AND ESTABLISH SORT OF A
WILDFIRE SECTION AND THEY WERE.
SUGGESTING THAT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE MONEY MIGHT BE
REALLY HELPFUL TO MATCH TO
OTHER NINE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
MIGHT BE COMING IN AND SO- YOUR
POINT IS REALLY WITH MERIT
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMING AT US
WITH WITH DIFFERENT THINGS EVEN
THOUGH IT MIGHT NOT BE INCLUDED
IN THIS AND IF THERE WERE. MORE
GLOBAL LOOK RESEARCH AND THEN.
WE COULD ACTUALLY DIRECT THEM
TO THEM RATHER THAN COMING TO
US BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN IN THEIR
BUDGET THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO
I THINK THAT WAS IT. A GOOD
GENERAL DIRECTION THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME MAKE THAT COME IN
AND YOU HAD AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION- AND THEN JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON YOU WHAT YOU SAID
YOUR LETTER I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THE ADMINISTRATION HERE'S-
PICKING WINNERS AND- I GUESS
BY. DEFAULT PICKING LOSERS AS
WELL AND- YOU KNOW TO WHAT
DEGREE SHOULD THE STATE
SENATE'SPRIORITIES ALSO MAP ON
TO THIS- PARTICULAR BUDGET IS A
QUESTION BUT- I THINK THAT'S
QUESTION FOR ANOTHER DAY- MY
LAST QUESTION IS GOING BACK. TO
THE BILLION DOLLAR ENDOWMENT.
DO YOU SEE RIGHT. RACE TAKE.
AROUND I AM FORGETTING FOR A
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. THAT
THIS MIHT RAISE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS HAVE YOU HAVE YOU
LOOKED INTO THIS AND ASSISTED
IN FORMING A FINANCE OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK I HEARD
IT. WE APPRECIATE THE ALL SAY
THAT ON THAT POINT IN TERMS OF
OTHER DETAILS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
WE ARE WORKING NOW WITH YOU SEE.
AND WE'RE WE'LL WORK THROUGH
THOSE ISSUES. OKAY WELL
CONSTITUTION PROBABLY CAN'T BE
WORKED THROUGH BUT BUT
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET A GOOD
OUTCOME I THINK SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR MAN AND THANK
EVERYBODY ON THIS PANEL ONLY
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT WHICH IS
THAT- THERE WAS SO MUH IN HERE
AND WE HAVE SUCH A PACKAGE AND-
THAT WE MIGHT NOT HAVE GOTTEN
TO EVERYTHING THAT WAS A MAJOR
ISSUE OF CONCERN AND IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE MIGHT NOT WANT TO
STILL HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND
DECIDE. TO DO WORK TOWARD TO GO
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY AS WE
MOVE INTO THE NEGOTIATIONS TO
SHUT DOWN THE BUDGET- IT'S JUST
THAT- MORE ALREADY WAY BEHIND-
PART TIME BUT IT- AND WE WILL
HAVE TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
I THANK MY COLLEAGUES BECAUSE I
THINK WE GOT A LOT OF THE HIGH
LEVEL ISSUES THAT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK FRANTICALLY
AND UNLIMITD NUMBER OF DAYS WE
HAVE LEFT TO CLOSE DOWN SOME OF
THESE ISSUES. SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM THE PANEL'S
JENNIFER LOUIS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR LEASE
A KING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND RUN STORM
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND WE DO HAVE FOUR
MORE ITEMS INCLUDING THIS ONE
SO I'M GOING TO TRY TO JUST
HAVE PEOPLE BE DISCIPLINED THE
RESPONSE IS GOING FOR. SO WHAT
STAR WITH JENNIFER LOUISE- AND
WE'LL GO IN THE ORDER I JUST
MENTIONED WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE SO AGAIN I MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INCLUDE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
NEIGHBOR VISION PROVIDES NINETY
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING
AND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WHICH
INCLUDES A BASE AUGMENTATION OF
SEVENTY FOUR POINT. FOUR
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
THE MAIN. ALSO PROVIDES THE
FOLLOWING AND- FOR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION A ONE TIME
GENERAL AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING GENDER FUND. TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONING YES YOU HUMBLE
TOOK POLYTECHNIC UNIVERSITY.
AND THE SECOND ITEM IS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE HUNDRED OFF I
JUST SUPPORT THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE STATE AS YOU NORTHRIDGE
CENTER FOR EQUITY AND
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY. AS
WELL AS A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIMEFEDERAL CORONA VIRUS
CAPITAL PROJECT FUNDS. TO THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO SUPPORT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. AS WELL
AS THE REMOVAL OF THE
SUSPENSION DATE FOR SUMMER TERM
FINANCIAL AID THEREBY
CONTROLLING CONTINUING THE SIX
MILLION ANNUAL AUGMENTATION FOR
THE PROGRAM. ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR IMPROVED PER
SHARE. COMMENTS- HELLO. MORNING
SENATORS BE SEEKING I JUST
ANALYST'S OFFICE. INTERESTED
TIME ALSO BECAUSE I'M JUST A
FEW OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS
FIRST YES YOU. STARTING WITH
THE BASE AUGMENTATION. IN A
PREVIOUS KENNEL MY COLLEAGUE
JASON CONSTANT CARS RACING
ISSUS FOR THE- SUBCOMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER REGARDING YOU SEE
SPACE AUGMENTATION AND BY AND
LARGE THOSE SAME ISSUES APPLY
HERE. MUCH LIKE UCCS YOUR FACES
CERTAIN OPERATING COST
INCREASES IN THE BUDGET HERE
SUCH AS EMPLOYEE BENEFITS AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO A NEW STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. DOES COST
ESTIMATED TO TOTAL FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING AND SO
WE WAIT. FOR SUCH SUCH A TREAT
AT FIFTY SEVEN MILLION AS A
STARTING POINT TO MINIMUM
AMOUNT BASED ON MEDITATION TO
PROVIDE. A LIST PROVIDED
FURTHER AUGMENTATION ON TOP OF
THAT IT COULD EXPECT YES YOU
USE THOSE FUNDS ON ON
PRESIDENTIAL HIRING OR OTHER
CSU PRIORITIES. SUCH AS THE
GRADUATION INSTEAD OF. FINANCE
NOTED ALSO A PURPLE TO FIND A
TRANSIT. TO A POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY AT HUMBOLDT STATE.
THIS TRANSITION WOULD HAVE
NOTABLE IMPLICATIONS FOR
CAMPUSES COURSE OFFERINGS
ENROLLMENTS OPERATIONS. ALSO
ITS ROLE WITHIN THE BROADER CSU
SYSTEM. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE CAMPUS IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING A SELF STUDY
REGARDING THIS TRANSITION AND
THAT IT IS CURRENTLY EXPECTED
TO BE COMPLETE THE SEPTEMBER.
GIVEN THAT LACK OF INFORMATION
LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY HAS A
PROPOSAL WE THINK IT WOULD BE
PREMATURE TO FUND THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE THE SELF STUDY IS
COMPLETE AND AVAILABLE FOR
REVIEW. AT SOME RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS TIME ACTUALLY
VISITING IN THE FUTURE. WE DID
ALSO JUST WANT TO RAISE SOME
COMMENTS SPECIFIC TO THE
CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE HUMBLE
PROPOSALS FOR DUEL SENIOR
GENDER LISTED BOTTOM. LINE THE
TOPIC PAGE TIME. THE TWO
LARGEST CAPITAL PROJECTS AS
PART OF THIS PROPOSAL ARE FOR
STUDENT HOUSING. FINDING THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE A DEPARTURE
FROM THE STATE'S CURRENT
PRACTICE OF FUNDING MACROGENICS
IS ALREADY IS THE UNIVERSITY IS
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
HOUSING DINING AND OTHER
SOFTWARE PROGRAMS. I'LL BE
SOUGHT SUPPORT SOMEBODY'S.
THERE IS ALSO SOME FUNDING IN
THIS PACKAGE THAT WAITED OUT
INSTRUCTIONAL SPACE AT THE
HUMBLE CAMPUS HERE WOULD KNOW
THAT THAT CURRENT UTILIZATION
RATES OF EXISTING. CUSTOMERS
FACES IN THE CAMPUS ARE
RELATIVELY LOW. THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF ISSUES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD WANT TO
CONSIDER WHAT YOUR READERS OF
THIS PROPOSAL TRANSLITERATED.
REGARDING THE CENTER FOR EQUITY
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY AT CSU
NORTHRIDGE THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
CONSTRUCT A NEW BUILDING.
BUILDING BUT INCLUDES A SPACE
FOR OUTREACH TO YOUNGER
STUDENTS INCLUDING IN THE K.
TWELVE AREA AND AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL LAB SPACE FOR THE
COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE. SURE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO AWAIT
US ARMONK ITS OTHER PRIORITIES
FOR CAPITAL OUTLAYS YES YOU. IF
YOU HAS THAT SUBSTANTIAL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OF
ABOUT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS RELATING
TO LIKE SAFETY CONCERNS AND-
CAMPUS WIDE OPERATIONS. AND SO
I JUST I DON'T WANT TO WAIT
THAT BENEFITS OF CREATING. NEW
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTING NEW
BUILDINGS AGAINST ADDRESSES
DEFICIENCIES. IN EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH IS THE LAST TOPIC THAT I
WANTED TO RAISE WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL IN THEIR VISION WOULD
BRING THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE I HAVE
MANY REVISION TO THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING I'M
SORRY ONE TIME IN THE BUDGET
YEAR- GIVEN THE SIZE IS SIX
YEARS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG AS WELL AS THAT RESPECT
THESE COSTS COULD. GROW OVER
TIME TO FIND A DRESSED WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER THIS AS A STARTING
POINT AND- BUT WANT TO FIGHT IT
AND BASED. ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED. FOR DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. THANK YOU I'D BE
HAPPY TAKING QUESTION BEFORE A
GRAND TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF CSU. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. I'M RYAN
STORM REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
I'LL TALK ABOUT THREE ISSUES
FIRST THE BASE AUGMENTATION
WE'RE THANKFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR THE RESTORATION OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET CUT FROM LAST
YEAR. FIGHTING ANOTHER SEVENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
BASE TO HELP ELIMINATE THOSE
EQUITY GAPS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT OVER THE SPRING- IN IN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR PRO
OVERALL PROGRAM THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THIS MONEY WILL ALSO ALLOW US
MANDATORY COST INCREASES IN
PARTICULAR ITEMS LIKE EMPLOYEE
HEALTH CARE COST INCREASES
OCCUR EACH YEAR SO GRATEFUL FOR
THAT THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THAT. ON HOW BOLD WE
WELCOME THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR A THIRD POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY AT THE HUMBOLDT
STATE CAMPUS. THE CREATION OF A
POLYTECHNIC UNIVERSITY ON THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST WILL
PROVIDE MORE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE REGION.
HER STUDENTS FOR IN DEMAND
CAREERS. IN THE NORTH COAST
REGION AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATELY TO. AND
LASTLY ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WE WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS PROPOSAL TO USE A STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDS TO ADDRESS
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. BUT WE
ALSO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADD AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDS. TO ELIMINATE
HELP ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT WILL ALSO HELP WITH
ENROLLMENT HOUSING NEEDS AIR
CIRCULATION UPGRADES AND OTHER
VITAL PROJECTS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO QUESTIONS. IN LET
ME ASK FINANCE THE SAME
QUESTION I ASKED YOU SEE WHICH
IS- THE RATIONALE FOR KEEPING
ENROLLMENT FLAT AT CSU WERE NOT
FUNDING AND ROAM ACROSS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT SIMILARLY
FOR THAT QUESTION- JENNIFER LU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE. AND FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ON THE
MAY REVISION DOES NOT SO THIS
VIRAL MOMENT TARGETS FOR BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- HOWEVER WE DO
RECOGNISE THAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT ROWLEY IS A PRIORITY
AND TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE'RE OPEN TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION AS WE MOVE ON. WITH
THAT- BUT YOUR PROCESS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH BOTH SEGMENTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND UNIVERSITY HEALTH RAN ON
WHAT'S WRONG WITH HER IT'S LOOK
LIKE AND NOW IN IN THE FUTURE
AS PART OF A DISCUSSION OF
PARTIES ARE FOR BOTH SEGMENTS
OKAY THANK YOU MY APPRECIATE
THAT RESPONSE AND I'M SURE
WILL. ENJOY HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT WHAT ME
ASK A RELATED QUESTION OF- CSU.
AND THAT DOES YES YOU IS HAD
PROGRAM AND I'M- BECAUSE THE
NAME ESCAPES. RIGHT NOW. TO
ELEVATE THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS THAT GO THROUGH AND
FOR YEARS AND THE PERCENTAGE
SYSTEM WIDE HAS GONE UP IN A
MEASURABLE WAY WHICH THEN. I H.
MORE MOMENT SPACES BECAUSE
PEOPLE MOVING THROUGH IN FOUR
YEARS. WITH THE OR I WAS GONNA
ASK WHAT THE STATUS IS OF THAT
PROGRAM AND I KNOW THAT IN THE
PAST. THERE'S BEEN A SPECIFIC
ALLOCATION FOR IT IS THAT
PROGRAM. COVERED ADEQUATELY
UNDER THE- ADDITIONAL FUNDS IN
THE MAY REVISION FOR CSU. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED FOR THAT
QUESTION THE PROGRAM IS CALLED
THE GRADUATION IS SHIPPED
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT'S A SIX
YEAR LONG ENDEAVOR OF. CREASING
OUR- BASE BUDGET BY ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN AGGREGATE SO THAT'S BEEN A-
I THINK WE ARE NOW- FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR WE
ARE IN THE FIFTH YEAR OF
ATTEMPTING TO FULLY FUND OUR
PROPOSAL WHAT THAT DOES IS THAT
THE DAY HAS A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT. HIGH LEVEL GOALS ARE
MANY SUB LEVEL GOALS ASSOCIATE
BUT I'LL KEEP A VERY HIGH LEVEL
FOR BREVITY'S SAKE ULTIMATELY-
WHEN THE MAJOR GOALS IS TO
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES WRIT
LARGE. AND SO FAR THE PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESS- WE'VE
GONE FROM A FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IN AT 19% BACK
IN. BACK AT THE START OF THE
INITIATIVE AND WE ARE AT THIRTY
ONE FOR R. 31% FOR A FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN YOU SEE SIMILAR SORTS
OF INCREASES FOR OUR ALL OF OUR-
ETHNIC GROUPS OF OUR STUDENTS.
YOU SEE THAT IN TERMS OF
FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
GRADUATION RATES ALL OF THOSE
POSTS HAVE HAVE RISEN AND SO
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD THING. I
THINK THE ONE THING THAT WE
STILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
IS NEARING WHAT WE CALL THE
EQUITY GAP. WHICH IS WHERE- YES
I. IF YOU KNOW ALL OF US. ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE PEOPLE AND
WE WANT ALL STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE AT THE SAME RATES
ULTIMATELY. RIGHT AND SO THAT'S
THE GOAL IN IN IN IN IN THE
CASE OF THE C. ISSUE WE HAVE
DIFFERENT RATES OF PROGRESS
BETWEEN YOUR M. STUDENTS. AND
MORE TRADITIONAL STUDENTS- I
MEAN THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
WHITE OR ASIAN DESCENT. THERE'S
A GAP BETWEEN THOSE TWO. AND IN
SOME INSTANCES ON CAMPUSES ARE
CAMPUSES THAT NARROW THAT GAP
COMPLETE OTHER CASES THEY
HAVEN'T SYSTEM WIDE WE HAVE A
AN OVERALL GAP. IN TERMS OF
YOUR M. STUDENTS AS WELL AS AND
INTEL GRANT ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
SO GETTING TO THE BOTTOM LINE
OF YOUR QUESTION DOES THAT MAKE
DOESN'T MIRROR VISION FULLY
FUND THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
IT DOES. IT FULLY FUNDS WHAT
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES REQUESTED
IN NOVEMBER WHICH WAS ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
TO FULLY FROM THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO END UP
BEING A REAL GOOD CORN SEED SO
TO SPEAK. IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO REACH OUR GOAL AT EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OF HAVING
ALL THOSE EQUITY GAPS NARROWED
OR ELIMINATED. FULLY THAT'S
WITH R. U. R. M. STUDENTS AS
WELL AS WITH OUR PELL GRANT
ELIGIBLE POPULATION STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THAT'S REALLY-
RESPONSIVE ANSWER IN A GOOD
ANSWER AND- DOES THAT MEAN THAT
IN A YEAR OR TWO. WE WILL ALL
BE TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL VERSION
OF THIS GOING FORWARD AFTER THE
CURRENT TIME FRAME AND GOALS
ARE COMPLETED. QUITE POSSIBLY-
THIS PLACE KNOWN AS CALIFORNIA
IS ALWAYS ON THE MARCH TO TRY
TO DO BETTER SO WE MADE LAYER
ON TOP OF THIS A NEW INITIATIVE
COULD EXTEND IT IT JUST
DEPENDS- WE HAVE A BRAND NEW
CHANCELLOR AND HE HAS TO LAY
OUT HIS HIS VISION FOR HIS
ADMINISTRATION HOWEVER LONG
THAT IS. RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE
THICK OF THE GRAND IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN HE'S FULLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ONE THAT WE ARE PURSUING
RIGHT NOW RIGHT AND THEN I HAVE
ONE. LAST QUESTION. FOR YOU THE
CSU SYSTEM. THE GOVERNOR- HIS
PROPOSAL ABOUT. MAKING HUMBOLDT
STATE TO BECOME A POLITICIAN I
REPRESENTED CAL POLY MY MOTHER
GRADUATED FROM THE OTHER CAL
POLY AND YOU GUYS ALL TALKED
ABOUT IT. BUT LET ME ASK THE
QUESTION A DIFFERENT WAY IF. IT
COMES HUMBLED STAGES. HAS ITS
OWN NICHE NOW IS REALLY STRONG
WHEN I WAS RESOURCES SECRETARY
I THINK A MAJORITY OF THE CAL
FIRE FORSTER SAID GRADUATED
FROM HUMBOLDT STATE FORESTRY
PROGRAM- WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE.
THE COURT WHAT WOULD WE SEE.
OUR OUR IF POSSIBLE STATE
BECOMES A CAL POLY WHAT DO WE
SEE. FROM THE OUTSIDE. AS A
DIFFERENCE IN ITS MISSION OR
OUTPUT HOW IT OPERATES WHAT IT
MEANS IF POSSIBLE STATE BECOMES
A COUPLE. WELL OBVIOUSLY
SENATOR- WE'RE AT THE EARLY
STAGES OF FIGURING THIS OUT AS
MY COLLEAGUE MISS KING SAID
FROM THE LA- THE CAMPUS IS
DOING A SELF REFLECTION OR SELF
STUDY. ON HOW FEASIBLE IT IS TO
ADVANCE- COUPLE EIGHT W. I'M
SORRY HUMBLE TO A POLYTECHNIC.
I THINK YOU TOUCHED ON ONE OF
THE MAIN- APPLIED SCIENCES
PROGRAMS THAT I THINK WOULD BE
STRENGTHENED. AT HUMBLE WHICH
WOULD BE THE FORESTRY- SIDE OF
THINGS YOU ALSO SEE AN INCREASE
IN A NUMBER OF ENGINEERING
PROGRAMS- GENERALLY ACROSS THE
STATE THERE IS A COLOSSAL
DEMAND FOR. ADDITIONAL
ENGINEERING SPACE WE OFFER MORE
OF THAT AT HUMBLE. THERE'S ALSO
OTHER NICHE AREAS IN IN THAT
AREA OF THE STATE THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF OCEANOGRAPHY. AN
AQUACULTURE THAT COULD BE
EXPANDED THERE'S A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD OPPORTUNITIES
THERE- AND- I THINK I THINK
I'LL STOP THERE I DON'T WANNA
GET TOO FAR AHEAD OF IT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THE CAMPUS IS REALLY
DREADING THIS INTERNALLY IN
TRYING TO WORK WITH OTHERS IN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO WORK
THROUGH WHAT THE ACADEMIC PLAN
WOULD BE- BUT BUT CLEARLY- AS
THERE IS SO MUCH DEMAND AT OUR
OTHER- A POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITIES- THERE IS ROOM. WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE COULD BE A
THIRD AND IT COULD BE- WELL
SITUATED TO SERVE MORE
CALIFORNIANS IN THAT WAY MON I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE- JUST
NOTE ONE THING OUT OF THE
RESPONSE WHICH IS IT'S BEING
VETTED AND NETWORK. ASKING TO
PROVE WHAT HASN'T TOTALLY BEEN
VETTED IN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WILL TOTALLY BE AND SO I THINK
THAT'S JUST QUESTION WILL HAVE
TO GRAPPLE WITH AND NOT. IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND IT GOES BACK
TO CENTER GROVE CHUG CHUG BUGS
QUESTION OF. OF HOW YOU VET HOW
THINGS ACTUALLY TURNED OUT TO
THE END AND HOW YOU MEASURE
THEM AND SO. THIS IS A VERY
MUCH A MOVING TARGET I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THAT IN THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS. LET ME GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES OR OTHER QUESTIONS.
US SENATOR MAN AND THEN. START
WITH. HERE WANTED TO FOLLOW UP-
ON THE OF FOUR HUMBLED AND- I
THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE A FINE
PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT NEEDS FOR
MORE POLYTECHNIC EDUCATION. BUT
YOU KNOW I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
IT FOR ALLOCATING FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR. CAPITAL NEEDS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. YET YOU KNOW
THAT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A LOT OF
MONEY ARE YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS AS
AS I THINK THE CSU
REPRESENTATIVE MR STORM
DESCRIBED BY EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR. SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES IS WHY DID YOU CHOOSE
TO BASICALLY IT LOOKS LIKE GIVE
THE WHOLE HOG KUMBLE. WHILE-
YOU KNOW NOT. BITING EQUITABLE
FUNDING TO THE OTHER CSU'S
INCLUDING CSU FULLERTON WHICH
IS IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS
THAT. I KNOW HAS ENORMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. H. AS FAR
AS NEW CAPITAL PROJECTS AS FAR
AS JUST UPDATING SOME OF ITS-
OUTDATED FACILITIES- YOU KNOW
WHY HUMBLE AND- WHY NOT. DECIDE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD BE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING SHOULD
BE SHARED MORE EQUITABLY. THANK
YOU CENTERMAN FOR THE QUESTION
I GENEROUSLY WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE FLORIDA THREE
THREE MILLION OF ONE TIME
TOWARD INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRANSITION-
TO ONBOARD THE INCREASED NUMBER
OF STUDENTS IS. THAT WILL BE
ENROLLED WHEN AND IT SEEMS YOU
HUMBLE BECOMES A POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY AND AS- MY COLLEAGUE
RAIN STORM AT SEA AS YOU
MENTION- BECAUSE THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DEMAND BY US
STUDENTS TO ATTEND- COULD THE
CURRENT- POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITIES AT CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND HOPEFULLY COME
OUT AND- THE MINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS- TO
UPGRADE ALL LABORATORIES AND
THE APPLIED SCIENCES AS WELL
AS- AS HOUSING IN PARTICULAR-
ARE IMPORTANT FOR THE
TRANSITION AND TO MEET DEMAND
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR PRIZE AND
THAT INCREASED TO A ROMANCE AS
WELL AS TO ALLEVIATE- THE LOCAL
HOUSING MARKET I'M ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT RISING STUDENTS- AND-
AND THAT'S THE REASON FOR AT
THIS SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
VERSUS YOU HUMBLE. SURE BUT I
GUESS JUST A FOLLOW UP I MEAN
T. S. U. FULLERTON. WHICH IS
NOT MY DISTRICT PROTEST OUTSIDE-
WE HAVE HOUSING FOR THERE IN
FACT THERE STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF.
THEY'RE LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
DO YOU HAVE AN URGENT NEED FOR
LABORATORY SPACE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH. SO ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS YOU
MENTIONED WITH HUMBLE CERTAINLY
EXISTS FOR OTHER CSU'S. SO
AGAIN MY QUESTION IS WHY
PRIORITISE ONE CAMPUS AT THE
EXPENSE OF ALL THE OTHERS.
MEDICATIONS THAT DANCER
QUESTION ANSWER I HAD TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOUR ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. AS THIS YOU HUMBLE M.
IS AT A PARTY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE IT THEY
WERE. RECOGNIZED THAT- HUMBLE
AND IS AND IS IT PRIME- AMBLE
POSITION TO HELP WITH THEIR
WORKFORCE MAN'S PARTICULARLY
AND STAB. AND ECAUSE OF THAT
NEED A NEED- AND THE OVERALL
WORK FORCE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THAT'S THE REASON
WHY FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
MS LOUIS. YOUR COLLEAGUE HAS A
RAISED HAND DID SHE MAY BE
TRYING TO RESCUE YOU RIGHT NOW
SO WHAT. I'LL RECOGNIZE PRETTY
ON APPROACH. I THINK YOU MIGHT
CHAIR I YES FOR IS THAT. A THE
RIGHT SHOT AND I ECHO HER
COMMON AS WELL. THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD ADD IS THAT WE DO
ALSO HAVE DIFFERENT MEANINGS
PATHFINDING PROPOSED. IN THE
BUDGET WE HAD A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THAT IS
STILL A PART OF THE PROPOSAL
AND TO DATE. THERE'S ALSO AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
DIFFERENT MEAT AND SO WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT NEED AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM FOR DIFFERENT
MAINTENANCE MARK BROADLY- WE
SEE THE FORMAT AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID WE SEE THE FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE MILLION.
SPECIFIC TO WHAT THEY NEED FOR
TRANSITIONING- CS YOU HUMBLED
INTO A COLLEGE TECHNICS- SO
BACK IN NICE AND THERE ARE
DIFFERENT NEEDS THE REST OF
THAT THAT SEGMENT- DESK
PROPOSAL IS SYMPATHETIC TO THE
TRANSITION ITSELF I GUESS I
JUST FOLLOW UP AND NOTE THAT.
YOU KNOW YEAH AMONG THE THINGS
BEING FUNDED BY FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS OUR
STUDENT HOUSING WHICH IS
TRADITIONALLY SELF SUPPORTED-
AND OTHER USES THAT. YOU KNOW
SEEM LIKE YOU'RE GIVING THEM
THE GOLD PLATED TREATMENT AND-
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THERE'S
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET.
FOR THE ENTIRE CSU SYSTEM AND
YOU'RE PROPOSING TO DEDICATE
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AGAIN INCLUDING
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE NOT
TRADITIONALLY SUPPORTED BY THE
STATE- TO THE HUMBLE
TRANSITION- IN I WOULD SAY I
WISH I HAD SOME PROBLEMS WITH
THAT NIGHT I'D LOVE TO HEAR
FROM MR STORM IT'S. YES YOU
WANT ON HIS OVERALL PERSPECTIVE.
NOT QUITE ON THE SPONSOR- I WAS
JUST A PLAYING A LITTLE BIT OF
DIGITAL CHALLENGING HERE TRYING
TO FIND MY A NEW BUTTON AND-
ANYWAY REAL QUICKLY- YES
CHALLENGE SENATOR OF COURSE WE
HAVE FOUR BUT AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE MS KING FROM THE LA-
SAID WE HAVE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- AND THERE'S A LOT
OF NEED THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM AND- ON THE ONE HAND-
OBVIOUSLY I AGREE WITH YOU IN A
IN A LOT OF WAYS YOU KNOW MORE.
MORE FUNDING PER OUR REQUEST
THAT YOU'VE HEARD US CALLOUSLY
SUGGESTED WE NEED TO INCREASE
HARD FOR MAINTENANCE BUT THE
OTHER ON THE OTHER HAND TO
THERE'S THIS THIS OPPORTUNITY
HERE WITH AS MUCH FUNDING AS
THE STATE HAS TO DO REAL
VISIONARY CHANGER FOR HUMBOLDT
STATE SO OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO DO IT ALL
AND- WE MAYBE THERE'S A WAY
THAT YOU ALL CAN FIGURE THAT
OUT IN YOUR BUDGET AND MAKE
THAT ALL WORK. BUT THAT THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE BOTH- IT BUT BOTH
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS I THINK-
HUMBLED STATE FOR AS MANY OF
YOU MAY KNOW- HAS HAD ITS
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF KEEPING
ENROLLMENT AT CURRENT LEVELS%
AND THE CURRENT OFFERINGS IS
ABLE TO HOLD AND I THINK THIS-
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY AS A
POLYTECHNIC MAY BE. A
SIGNIFICANT GAME CHANGER FOR
KEEPING THAT- SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT UP IN THE NORTH.
COAST THERE- VIABLE GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. A CENTER OF
TROUBLE DID YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY I HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON
BECAUSE IT OCCURRED TO ME.
DURING THAT DISCUSSION OF THE
POLICIES- I REPRESENT TWO PARTS
OF CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO THE
MAIN CAMPUS BUT ALSO THE
SWANTON AREA WHERE. AL SMITH
WHO WAS ONE OF THE MAJOR
LEADERS OF ORCHARD SUPPLY
DONATED TO THE CAMPUS THREE
THOUSAND ACRES OF TIMBERLAND
DENNIS HOUSE FOR FOUR STUDIES.
AND THE FIRE RAVAGED THAT AREA
IT'S ADJACENT TO BIG BASS AND
BIG BASIN LOST 95% OF ITS-
ACREAGE IN THE FIRE. AND IN THE
PARKS BUDGET WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX MILLION. OF THE
STATE CONTRIBUTION TO MATCH THE
DISASTER FUNDS FOR THE
REBUILDING AND ISSUES AND BIG
BASIN PARK BUT I DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING HERE. FOR CAL POLY
SWANTON AND I KNOW THAT- THAT I
HAVE I WAS THERE BEFORE THE
FIRE AND I WAS THERE AFTER THE
FIRE AND WAS UNRECOGNIZABLE MY
COULDN'T EVEN SEE WHERE. THE
SMALL GAUGE RAILWAY AND SOME OF
THE OTHER CAL POLY BUILDINGS
HAD BEEN THE ONLY CAL POLY
BUILDING THAT SURVIVED WAS ONE
THAT WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
FIELD THAT SOMEHOW THE FIRE
WENT BY. SO MY QUESTION IS WILL
YOU BE LOOKING TO THE STATE IN
ANY WAY FOR A PORTION OF THE
REBUILDING THAT THAT EXISTS
THERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN TIS
BUDGET BUT WE'RE SEEING IT FOR
THE ADJACENT PROPERTY PARK
PROPERTIES. CENTER I THINK I'LL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
PARTICULAR QUESTION. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT I JUST WANT
TO CALL IT OUT BECAUSE IT IS A
CONCERN AND IF. IF WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING IN THIS BUDGET WE
NEED TO KNOW IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS SO. I APPRECIATE THAT LET
ME THANK EVERYBODY THAT WAS ON
THE PANEL FOR THE- THE CSU
PORTION- AND ONCE AGAIN THERE
ARE A LOT MORE THINGS THAT WE
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE TALKED
ABOUT WERE LIMITED ON TIME AND
WE- AND WE WILL HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. IN THE NEXT DAYS
AND WEEKS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE FOR WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND WE HAVE DAN HOW
WERNER. HANDWORK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PAUL
STEEN HOUSE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND WAS SET NEVER READ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
MICHELLE NEWMAN IS HERE FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO WE'LL MOVE TO
THE PANELISTS IN THAT ORDER
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. DAN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I PLAN
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BECAUSE MOST
OF THE MAJOR ADDITION. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE- AT A HIGH LEVEL
ACROSS THE THREE YEAR BUDGET
WINDOWS AND THEIR VISION OF
FLEX JUST OVER ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION. IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES UNDER THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS
PROPOSED TO HELP COLLEGES
WHETHER THE EFFECTS OF
PERMANENT UNDERCOVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. OF REDUCE THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR STUDENTS. AND
SUPPORT HE LONG TERM
OPERATIONAL STABILITY OF THE
COLLEGES. OUR VISION MAINTAINS
SOME MONTHS ALL INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OUR VISION ALSO POSES
NEW INVESTMENTS THAT BUILD UPON
EXISTING EFFORTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES WITH A FOCUS
ON EQUITY. FIRST AMERICAN
OPPOSES THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OF COURSE IN THE
MORNING. A FOUR POINT 005% FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION- FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF ONE POINT
FIVE. PERCENT THIS REFLECTS A
COMPOUND CALLED OF THE
STATUTORY ONE POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THE PORK ON TWO
POINT 31% FROM TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. DESPITE YOUR POSTER
MOVE THE ENTIRE QUESTION IS
DEFERRAL. FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. WHAT ABOUT
YOUR ABOUT YOUR PLUS ONE TO
CRAWL. ORIGINALLY PROPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FURTHER
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO SPEED UP
THE REPAYMENT OF A PORTION OF
DEFERRALS FROM TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SO THE CAR YOUR
CAT BUT YOU'RE NOT FAR OFF.
CAMBER PAYMENT OCCURRED BETWEEN
JULY AND AUGUST AS OPPOSED TO-
JULY NOVEMBER WHICH IS. ABOUT
WHAT IT'S GOING TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR. TO FURTHER HELP
COLLEGES WITH THEIR ONGOING
BASE FUNDING TO THEIR VISION
PROPOSES ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME FOR ATTENTION AND
INVOLVEMENT STRATEGIES. SIMILAR
TO THE TWENTY MILLION AND ACTED
IN THE EARLY MEDIA ACTION
PACKAGE. TO ADDRESS NUMBER
DECLINED ACROSS IN THE COLLEGE
SYSTEM. WANT TO KEEP OF THIS
BUDGET IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME TO SUPPORT
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST TO CREATE.
AN OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES.
ALSO UTILIZES FIFTEEN MILLION
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED FOR- ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST DEGREES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS FUNDING
WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DEGREE PROGRAMS
AT A LEMONADE. ARE THESE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE COST
OF TEXTBOOKS FOR STUDENTS.
THROUGH THE UTILIZATION OF.
OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES.
FIVE NINE INC FUNDING PROVIDED
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST DEGREES.
HELPS REDUCE FORTY TWO MILLION
IN COST SAVING FOR HELP PRODUCE
FORTY TWO MILLION. IN COST
SAVINGS TO STUDENTS JOIN THE
TENSION THAT THIS INVESTMENT
AND HOW CHRISTIANS. THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE PROPOSALS
INCLUDED IN BUDGET. I WILL NOT
HEAR A FEW OF THE LARGER POSES
BETTER NEWS FROM AMERICA ASIA
AND- WHICH ARE FUNDED BY
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND. UNLESS STATED OTHERWISE-
THE BUDGET INCLUDES SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME PER DAY
ONE MOMENT INTENT IS TO
pEXPANSION OF SPEAK OUT WORK-
SEE HAVE AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME TO
FURTHER SUPPORT COLLEGES
SEPARATE TEMPLATE GUIDED
PATHWAYS PROGRAMS. THE MILLION
ON GOING TO EXPAND VOCATIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS- WORK
OPPORTUNITIES AND ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THIRTY MILLION TO ESTABLISH
BASIC NEED CENTERS AND OUR
BASIC NEEDS COORDINATORS AT
EACH COLLEGE. TAKING A LONG
TIME TO SUPPORT GRANTS TO
ASSIST COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD
RESPOND TO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND TRANSITIONING
BACK TOWARD IN PERSON
EDUCATION. FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
ONE TIME TO ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. BY WHICH.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION-
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT
CAPITAL PROJECTS FUND AND THE
REMAINDER IS PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND. 5% RATE INCREASES
FOR THE TWO LARGEST CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS MAKING A COLLEGE
BUDGET. THE STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM AND A
STRONG WORK WORK PROGRAM WHICH
TOTAL. ABOUT THIRTY SIX POINT
TWO MILLION ONGOING IN INDIA A
NEW INVESTMENT. TWENTY MILLION
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY BEST
PRACTICES AS DEVELOPED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S. EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY AND DIVERSITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION ONGOING TO
FURTHER SUPPORTING RESEARCH
THAT IS ON- AND SUPPORT STUDENT
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANT STUDENTS
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND COLLEGES. THAT ARE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THIS
COMBINED WITH EXISTING FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET WOULD ALLOW FOR A
FULL POSITION H. COLLEGE- TEN
MILLION ONE TIME.
IMPLEMENTATION OF A COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION AND COLLECT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TEN MILLION
ON GOING TO THE SYSTEM WIDE
ACQUISITION OF SOFTWARE THAT
VISUALIZES AND CREATING MAPS
OUT CURRICULAR PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS CHOOSING THEIR PATHWAY
AND PER STUDENT ANY HELP TO
STAY ON THE COMPLEX. TEN
MILLION ONE TIME TO PLAN FOR
AND AGAIN DEVELOPING A COMMON
COURSE NUMBER IN SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. FOUR MILLION
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT A
SYSTEM WIDE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM
FOR LIBRARY SERVICES. TO BETTER
MANAGE AND DELIVER DIGITAL
INFORMATION TO SUPPORT TEACHING
AND LEARNING. ONE MILLION TO
SUPPORT- ONE TIME TO SUPPORT
THE MODERNIZATION OF THE TPP
REGISTRY- AND THEN WE ALSO WE
WANT TO PROVIDE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE PROGRAMS AND
THE STRICTLY RECEIVED A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. AT THE
BUDGET YOUR STATUTORY COLD I'M
NOT A ONE POINT 7% OUR VISION
ALSO INCLUDES NEW INVESTMENTS
DESIGNED TO BETTER ALIGN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE
RECORDS PARTNERS. INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME SUPPORT
MANY COLLEGE PARTICIPATION. IN
IRAQ TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS DEVELOP A
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. TEN MILLION
ONE HUNDRED ABOUT ZERO. OR GIVE
UP WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. IN CLOUD
COMPUTING INTERMISSION HI JANE
BEALE'S. AND THEN I WILL ALSO
NOTE- AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD WE
WILL KEEP ON GOING DIRECTLY TO
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AS A RESULT OF THE STATE
APPROPRIATION PERMITS- BEHIND
ON THE FINAL NUMBERS BUT BUT-
THAT AMOUNT SHOULD BE AROUND
FIFTEEN BILLION OVERALL WITH
ABOUT HALF GOING TO. SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES- WITHOUT THANK YOU
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY. I BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE MY
COLLEGE OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. WERE
GOING TO GO ON TO THE LA O'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
AUSTIN HAUSEN WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AS YOU JUST
HEARD THERE'S A LOT HAPPENING
WITH THAT COMMITTEE COLLEGE
BUDGET YOU HAVE TO BE REVISION.
WE SEE- SOME SOME REAL
POSITIVES HERE- SPECIALLY ON
THE TWO BIGGEST- SPENDING
PROPOSALS IN ONE TIME MONEY-
THAT'S MONEY FOR DEFERRALS AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE THINK
IT'S VERY POSITIVE. TO SEE THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSED RETIRE ALL
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DEFERRALS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT THIS COMMITTEE- BACK
IN FEBRUARY WE RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE APPROVES THAT. OUR
MESSAGE ON FUNDING TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
VERY SIMILAR TO THE MESSAGE YOU
JUST HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGETS. WE
THINK IT HAS MERIT AND WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE TREAT
THEM A REVISED PROPOSAL
PROPOSED FUNDING LEVEL AS A
MINIMUM. GIVEN THE SIZE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG WHICH IS
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD FREE UP FUNDS
TO ADDRESS EVEN MORE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR ADDRESS OTHER
COST PRESSURES WHICH MANY
COLLEGES ARE FACING SUCH AS
PENSIONS. BY REJECTING THOSE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. DEEMS UNJUSTIFIED
OR OTHERWISE LOWER PRIORITY FOR
EXAMPLE THE MAY REVISE PROPOSES
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM CODED RESPONSE BLOCK
GRANT BASED ON DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FEDERALLY
FUNDS ARE SUFFICIENT TO COVER
THOSE COSTS SUCH AS COSTS TO A
TRANSITION TO RE. RE OPENED
CAMPUSES IN THE FALL. IN TERMS
OF ONGOING SPENDING THE LARGEST
PROPOSAL COVERS A 4% COST OF
LIVING INCREASE FOR
APPORTIONMENT. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THAT WILL
HELP THE COLLEGES ADDRESS
RISING SALARY BENEFIT NO OTHER
COST PRESSURES. THE VICE
PROPOSES A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND OR OTHER TYPE OF
BASE AUGMENTATION TO SOME
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS OF THE
PERCENT VARIES FROM ONE POINT
7% 24% 25% AND IN MANY CASES
GIMME A CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
WOULD NOT RECEIVE ANY TYPE OF
BASE AUGMENTATION EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF STUDENT
SUPPORT PROGRAMS A STAFF YOU'LL
PERSONNEL- DO YOU HAVE SALARY
BENEFIT COST PRESSURES. SO THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO GIVE A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO THE SAME
SET OF CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR GIVE A
HIGHER. AMOUNT TO THOSE
FORTUNATE TO FIND A LARGER SET
OF CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AND AS
WE HAVE THE ONE TIME FUNDS
LEGISLATURE COULD FREE P
FUNDS- FROM MONEY THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING AN
ONGOING EXPENSES IDENTIFIED
THOSE ONGOING PROPOSALS THAT
ARE UNJUSTIFIED OR ARE LOWER
PRIORITIES LEGISLATURE. AND
PERHAPS USE THAT MONEY
REDIRECTED TO FUND HIGHER COST
OF LIVING- HIGHER COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR TWO
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS SO THERE'S
MANY OPPORTUNITIES HERE FOR
LEGISLATURE TO START ITS OWN
PRIORITIES HERE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IN THE COMING WEEKS
A WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
STAFF TO. COME TO A PACKAGE
THAT'S REALLY REFLECTIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT IT VALUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THEN WE'LL. MOVE ON TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CENTER LARRY
MEMBERS THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION MY NAME
IS LIZ AND- AT I AM THE VICE
CHANCELLOR COLLEGE FINANCING
FACILITIES PLANNING AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ADDRESSING A HARDSHIP FOR
COMPLETE COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC HAS
REQUIRED TREMENDOUS EFFORT BY
STUDENTS FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS IN THE OVERALL
SYSTEM TO RESPOND SWIFTLY AND
URGENTLY. PUTTING STUDENTS
FIRST CONTINUES TO BE THE
DRIVING FORCE BEHIND ALL
ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE CALGARY
COLLEGES. CHRISTY TREATS DID HE
TAKE IT INVESTMENTS PAVE THE
ROAD FORT TO RECOVERY. WE
COLLEGES AND STUDENTS HAVE
SUFFERED THE MOST DURING THE
ACADEMIC AND INTACT THIS IS WHY
I FIRST WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE. FOR THEIR APPROVAL OF
THE IMMEDIATE ACTION PACKAGE.
THOSE INVESTMENTS FOCUSED ON
EMERGENCY AID AND STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AT EIGHT IN THE
FIRST STEPS TO RECOVERY. WE
THINK THAT WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
FOR A MAIN REVISED PROPOSAL
THAT PLAYS A STRONG FOUNDATION
FOR RE EMERGING FROM THE
PANDEMIC. EQUITABLY AND
RESILIENT LEE AND FOR SEEING
OUR SYSTEM AS A AS A KEY
STRATEGY IN THAT PLAN.
INVESTMENTS PRESENTED IN THE
MAY REVISION GENERALLY FALL
INTO SIX CATEGORIES RESTORING
INSTITUTIONAL RESOURCES. I WAS
GONNA MAKE RECOVERY DIVERSITY
EQUITYAND INCLUSION
AFFORDABILITY AND BASIC NEEDS
WORK FORCE AND PATHWAYS. I'LL
COVER SOME POINTS AROUND EACH
OF THESE INVESTMENTS- GROUND ON
RESTORING INSTITUTIONAL
RESOURCES COST PRESSURES FOR
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO GROW AND-
MAKING THE INVESTMENT IN
ONGOING FUNDS CRITICAL WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR FOR
PURSUING- AND PROPOSING THE
FULL PAY DOWN OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION THE DEFERRALS CHAR
COLLEGES. CAME DOWN THE STEPS
TO COLLEGES IT'S A KEY STAT AND
PUTTING THE HARDSHIPS OF THE
PANDEMIC BEHIND US. WE ALSO
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS AROUND THE LACK OF
CLARITY IN THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED COMPOUNDED
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF
FOUR POINT 005% FURTHER WE
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE ACTIONABLE PLANS AND
STRATEGIES TO COPE LOWS
LINGERING AND STUBBORN
EDUCATION OUR EQUITY GAPS.
HELLO HOWEVER WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS AROUND A PROPOSAL
TO REQUIRE DISTRICTS TO
MAINTAIN ONLINE COURSES ONLINE
AND AT LEAST 10% HIGHER THAN
THEY WERE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN. THOUGH WE DO
NOT HAVE CONCERNS WITH OLINE
COURSES AND BELIEVE THEY
PROVIDE MUCH FLEXIBILITY TO
POST TRADITIONAL LEARNERS THERE
IS LITTLE EVIDENCE- TO SUPPORT
THE HARD AND FAST RULE OF 10%
AROUND POST ENDEMIC RECOVERY OF
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES IN OUR
DISTRICTS REQUIRE ON GOING
RESEARCH SINCE AS THEY PREPARE
FOR INCREASED COSTS. AND
RECURRING EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH SAFE CAMPUS REOPENING- AS
A RESULT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO RE ENGAGE AND HELP
OUR STUDENTS RETURN TO OUR
CAMPUSES THESE DISRUPTIONS HAVE
LEFT LINGERING SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES. THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND CONTINUE TO THREATEN
A LONG ELUSIVE EQUITY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AS EVIDENCED BY OUR
ENROLLMENT DECLINES SO AGAIN WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL. AROUND
DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OF OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S THE
SHARED BY- MY ALLEY- COLLEAGUE.
SO WE ALSO- WILL TURN TO
DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE TO HELP
OUR RE OPENING OF CAMPUSES FOR
INSPIRATION INSTRUCTION WITH
KEEPING SAFETY AT THE FOREFRONT
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENT OF THREE ON THREE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN MILLION
ONE TIME AND PROP NINETY EIGHT.
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
THIS ISN'T A STEP IN HELPING US
ACHIEVE. A SAFE FREE OPENING
ADDRESSING OUR BACKLOG. AND
ENSURING THAT WE PROVIDE SAFETY
TO OUR STUDENTS FACULTY AND
STAFF. AROUND EVERY SEE EQUITY
AND INCLUSION INVESTMENTS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES- AND PRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OUR
IMPORTANT WORK TO DISMANTLE
STRUCTURES AND PRACTICES THAT
PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC RACISM. WE
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING
INVESTMENTS IN LINE WITH THE
CHALCEDONY COLLEGES VISION FOR
SUCCESS TO CLOSE EQUITY GAPS
THESE INCLUDE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY INVESTMENT OF
TWENTY MILLION. TO HELP
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES TODAY
VERSUS FIRE FACULTY AND STAFF.
AND TO RETURN SO THAT THEY MAY
REFLECT THE RICH DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENTS. SEE SEE SEE
REGISTRY MODERNIZATION OR WHAT
THE PROPOSED ONE MILLION
INVESTMENT FOR SECURITY
UPGRADES AND MODERNIZATION OF
pDISTRICT REGISTRY TO HELP.
TALENTED INDIVIDUALS FIND JOBS
AND OPPORTUNITIES AND ARE GREAT
SYSTEM. AND A BASED ON
MEDITATION OF TWENTY THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR OUR
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM. THIS IS A CRITICAL
EQUITY PROGRAM THAT IS. EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF OUR CAMPUSES.
AROUND ONE FORCE- WE AS A
SYSTEM ARE THE PLACE THAT
CALIFORNIANS TURN TO DEFINE
WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES I AND
IF YOU FIND A LIVABLE. WAGES AS
A RESULT OF THEIR EDUCATION THE
PROPOSAL HAS VARIOUS WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT WILL TALK ABOUT A
FEW OF THEM. HI ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP SAID REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS THIS IS AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT WE COLLABORATE WITH
CROSS AGENCIES. LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS TWENTY
MILLION INVESTMENT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS CAME BACK TO WORK.
STRONG WORK FORCE HAS BEEN OUR
LONG STANDING COLLEGE AND
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY OUR
WORKFORCE IS STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BASE INCREASE OF 5%
GROUNDWORK BASED LEARNING WE'RE
GLAD TO SEE THE INCLUSION OF AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION FOR THIS
STRATEGY SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON EMERGING. CLOUD COMPUTING
AND ZERO EMISSION- AND I SUPPLY
CHAIN FEELS. AND THEN AROUND
AFFORDABILITY OUT FOR MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS FINANCES HOW ARE
THE MAIN BARRIER TO ACHIEVING
EDUCATIONAL GOALS FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE PREPARING THESE
CONNECTED TO EDUCATION- DURING
THE ACADEMIC AND THIS HAS BEEN
A HUGE CHALLENGE SO WE'RE GLAD
TO SEE VARIOUS INVESTMENTS IN
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST YOU GREASE
INCLUDING. HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME WE BELIEVE
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST AND LOW COST
PATHWAY TO SAVE STUDENTS AN
AVERAGE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PRIOR MODEST
INVESTMENTS IN ZERO TEXTBOOK
COST YOU CREATE AND SAVE
ESTIMATED FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS
TRANSITIONING FROM OUR
DEPENDENCY ON EXPORTS TO MORE
INNOVATIVE MODELS SUCH AS OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES. CAN
SUPPORT THE AFFORDABILITY
AGENDA IN THIS BUDGET AND
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. BROWN BASE
NEEDS AND FEBRUARY. I HATE TO
INTERRUPT THE COULD YOU BEGIN
TO WRAP UP BECAUSE WE'RE-
REALLY WAY BEHIND HERE. AND I
KNOW EVERY ONE OF THESE ISSUES
IS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YES AND THE ONLY THING-
ADARAND BASIC NEEDS THAT WE
HOPE THAT- THE LEGISLATURE WILL
CONSIDER A COMPREHENSIVE
CONCEPT THAT LOOKS AT LOOKING
AT MORE OFFERING THESE SUPPORTS
MORE HOLISTICALLY TOURISTS
STUDENTS BY ENSURING THAT WE
PROVIDE BASIC NEEDS OF FOOD
SUPPORTS AND FINANCIAL AID. A
COMPREHENSIVE MODEL AND THEN WE
SUPPORT THE VARIOUS- PATHWAY
INVESTMENTS IN THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDING GUIDED PATHWAYS
TECHNOLOGY IN COURSE NUMBERING
LASTING ALL ADDRESS THAT IS YOU
KNOW THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
HAS A STACK OF ONLY A HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX. INDIVIDUALS TO
SUPPORT TWO POINT ONE MILLION
SYSTEM SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS
AND A HUNDRED SIXTEEN COLLEGES
SO WE URGE THE CONSIDERATION OF
GREATER CAPACITIES TO SUPPORT
THESE NEW AND EXPANDED
INITIATIVES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- COMMENTS. LET ME
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FIRST THERE'S JUST BEEN SOME
CONFUSION OVER JUST TERMINOLOGY
COULD YOU EXPLAIN. WHAT A FOUR
POINT 5% INCREASE COMPOUNDED
MEANS BY THAT IS IT JUST A FOUR
POINT. 5% INCREASE. SURE DAN
HAD OUR AND OUR ARGUMENT MY
BEST- SO I THINK SPECIFICALLY
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
THAT HAS TRADITIONALLY PROVIDED
AND- STATUTE IS THE IMPLICIT
PRICE DEFLATOR AND SO THE
COUPLE- BASED ON THAT
CALCULATION FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
WAS ONE POINT 7% AT THE
MARAVICH AND- HOWEVER WE
REALIZE THAT A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT WAS NOT PROVIDED TO
THE- APPORTIONMENT FUNDING IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. SO WE ALSO
WANTED TO REFLECT THAT FINDING
OUT THAT THERE IS A VEIL ON
GOING FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET SO IN IN ATHENS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL BE
RECEIVING A FOUR POINT 005%
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR
THEIR PORTION THAT'S MOVING
FORWARD- HOWEVER WE WANTED TO
SYMBOLICALLY NOTE THAT-
DIMINISHES AS OPPOSED TO IS TO
PROVIDE FUNDING. FOR THAT- PORK
ON COLOR IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
OKAY IT'S JUST THAT THERE'S
STILL SOME CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS AND SOME PEOPLE THINK
IT MEANS MORE AND SOMETHING
PEOPLE THINK IT MEANS LESS AND
SO ON THERE. YES IF YOU'D LIKE
I CAN. GO FOR TRANSIT SO I
THINK ALL IT MEANS IS IN THE
CURRENT THE CURRENT YEAR
COLLEGES SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN I
THINK IT WAS AROUND A TWO POINT
3% ALSO LIVING ADJUSTMENT THEY
DIDN'T GET THAT BECAUSE OF THE
TIME WHEN THE BUDGET WAS
ENACTED A YEAR AGO- THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT THE BUDGET
SITUATION. SO FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR THE GUNNERS RISING ONE
POINT 7% SO I THINK. THE IDEA
OF A COMPOUNDED COSTLY JUST IS
JUST. FIRST THE COLLEGES GET A
TWO POINT THREE PERCENT.
INCREASE SO THEY GOT THAT
INCREASE IN ON DEMAND THEY GET
A ONE POINT 7% ON TOP OF THAT
SO WHEN YOU ADD THAT UP IT'S
NOT JUST A 4% INCREASE OR IT'S
ABOUT IT'S A FOUR POINT 005%
BECAUSE IT'S THE- BUDGET YEAR.
COST OF LIVING IS ON TOP OF
THE- THE MONEY THEY GET FROM A
CALL UP FROM THE CURRENT YEAR.
THE MAKE UP CALL LIFE YOU. AND
LET ME TRY TO DIFFERENT WAY.
THAT THAT'S HELPFUL. THAT'S
DEFINITELY TRUE- IF. WE WERE
PRE PLANNED- MAC. TO NILES
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE TWO. IN IN FUNDING THERE
WAS A CUT OF A CERTAIN AMOUNT
AND THEN IT CAME BACK TWO OR
THREE TIMES- I BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S AN INCREASE OVER THE
PRE PLANNED- MAKE FUNDING
WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THAT
INCREASE. SO LEADING- SORT OF
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS- FLAT
THERE WAS NO SPECIFIC CUTS TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET
THERE WAS A- POST. PRODUCTION
AND- WHAT WAS IMPLEMENTED WAS
THAT SHOULD BE AN APARTMENT FOR
ALL. SO FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE A
PORTION THERE WILL BE. A
COMPARATIVE PREPAID DEBIT
CALLS. IT A FOUR POINT 005%
INCREASE OVER THE PREPAID DEBIT
BUBBLES. PERFECT THAT'S WHAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THEN LET
ME ASK- ONCE AGAIN FINANCE.
WHILE WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE INCREASE- IN THE COLA.
THERE'S CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
THAT. HELP SUPPORT STUDENTS
MASSA POINT TO A PART TIME
FACULTY OFFICE HOURS. NONE OF
THOSE RECEIVED A COLA. R. R.
CAN YOU SAY. WHY THEY DIDN'T
RECEIVE A CALL. SURE WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZED THAT
THESE CHEMICALS TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO STUDENTS- DOCTOR LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS WERE PROVIDED TO
THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
TYPICALLY RECEIVED A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. AND BUDGET
HISTORICALLY SO WE SIMPLY
CONTINUE THAT PRACTICE OF
PROVIDING COUNSELING
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY RECYCLE.
AT LEAST THAT'S THE CONSISTENT
WITH THE ANSWER THAT I GOT IN
FEBRUARY. EXCEPT I DIDN'T LIKE
IT THAT. AND IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME THAT JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY
DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT IN THE PAST
THERE CONTINUED TO BE PENALIZED
BECAUSE THEY GIVE GOOD SERVICES
AND VALUABLE SERVICES SO I HOPE
THAT. THAT WE CAN LOOK AT COST
OF LIVING INCREASES FOR
EVERYONE AND NOT JUST BECAUSE
THERE WEREWINNERS AND LOSERS
HISTORICALLY THE LOSERS. ARE
CONTINUE THE NAME OF LASTLY-
THE COMMON COURSE NUMBER RING
IT WAS MENTIONED IN PASSING IN.
WHAT'S THE VALUE WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE GAIN IN SPENDING
THIS AS OPPOSED TO SOMEWHERE
ELSE IN THE AREA. IN THE SYSTEM.
AND I GUESS I SHOULD START WITH
A FINANCING. SURE SO I CAN
CLOSE BY THAT CURRENTLY THERE
ARE DISPARATE NUMBERING SYSTEMS
ALTHOUGH THERE HAS BEEN SOME
WORK IN THE TERRIERS ARE JUST
REMEMBERING SYSTEMS FOR COURSES
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. SO BY CREATING A COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM WE
CANNOT ON THE- MAKE IT EASIER
FOR STUDENTS TO MAP OUT THEIR
THEIR PATHWAY AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT SORT OF COURSES THEY NEED
BUT ALSO IF THEY TRANSFER TO A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
EVEN TO AC IF YOU CAN HELP
CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS AND- MAKE IT A MUCH
MORE SIMPLE PROCESS PER PER
STUDENT DATA GETTING THREE.
BETWEEN A COLLEGE SYSTEM MUCH I
THINK ALIGNS WITH THE PATHWAYS
AND A LOT OF WORK BEING DONE TO
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS SO WE
DID IT IN ONE NOW THE OVERALL
EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS AN
ARTICULATION STUDY WHICH IS
BASICALLY HOW IT'S COURSES
CONNECT IN TRANSFER ABILITY IS
SIX EXPECTED IF YOU DID COMMON
COURSE NUMBER ON. THAT IT TAKES
AWAY A BUNCH OF THE NEED TO DO.
A LOT OF BRICK ARTICULATION
STUDIES. AND MAY. THIS MAYBE
ALL. A DAN AND GO IT WAS A ON
THIS ONE. FESTA HAPPY TO ADD ON
THIS- CORE COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS AND- ANY INSTITUTION
WHERE STUDENTS TAKES THAT
COURSE ON TO KNOW WHAT. WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED WITHIN THAT
COURSE AND SO A PHYSICS CLASS
IN ONE DISTRICT IS- WITH THE
SAME NUMBER THAT CAN BE
EXPECTED TO HAVE THE SAME
LEARNING OUTCOMES AS A PHYSICS
CLASS IN ANOTHER. AT ANOTHER
DISTRICT THAT'S THE BENEFIT IT
ALSO EASES CONFUSION FROM A
STUDENT- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES ME SCENE AND SOME OF
OUR COMPLETION EFFORTS IS THAT
STUDENTS HAVE. AN AVERAGE OF
NINETY UNITS TO COMPLETE AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE WHICH SHOULD
REQUIRE SIXTY UNITS OFTEN THIS
IS BECAUSE THEY TAKE CLASSES
THAT WERE REDUNDANT OR THEY
ULTIMATELY DID. SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT COURSE RING NUMBER
RANG WITH ELIMINATE PEOPLE
TAKING RETURNED CLASSES IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. THAT'S ONE
OF THE BENEFITS YES. HELLO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION SO ON
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER
OTHER SENATORS ANY QUESTIONS.
US SENATOR MAN. I JUST HAD A
COMMENT I WANTED TO- ECHOED THE
COMMENTS OF THE CCC
REPRESENTATIVE ABOUT THE ONLINE
LEARNING REQUIREMENT- PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC HI I DON'T PRETEND
TO BE FULLY STEEPED IN D.
PEDAGOGICAL RESEARCH OUT THERE
BUT- I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THE CONSENSUS IS THAT THERE ARE
DRASTIC DIFFERENCES IN THE
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES BETWEEN IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. AND ONLINE
LEARNING AND WE'VE JUST GONE
THROUGH A YEAR AND A HALF LONG
ALMOST YEAR AND A HALF LONG
EXPERIMENT WITH A LOT OF DATA
POINTS- AND I AND I THINK AT
THIS POINT IT SEEMS TO ME TO BE
RAFTS TO BE REQUIRING A 10%
INCREASE IN ONLINE LEARNING.
WHEN IT THE DATA SUGGESTS THAT
THAT'S UNFAIR AND WE'RE ABOUT
TO GET A LOT MORE DATA ANALYZED
TO THAT EFFECT SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THERE MIGHT BE A BETTER
POLICY PATHWAY TO CONSIDER
HOLDING OFF ON THAT RATHER THAN
CREATING A WHAT IS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS AN ARBITRARY
PERCENTAGE NUMBER THAT DOESN'T
SEEM TO HAVE A VERY STRONG
POLICY BASIS BUT- THAT'S JUST
MY TWO CENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAN SINGH NO OTHER
QUESTIONS- LET ME MAKE SORT OF
A CLOSING COMMENT BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN THERE'S A LEVEL OF
COMPLEXITY IN THIS BUDGET TO
THAT OUR TIME DID NOT ALLOW US
TO FULLY EXPLORE TODAY- BECAUSE
I THINK. APPRECIATED THE
EXPLANATION ABOUT THE- THE
COLON YOUR HERE. PURCHASE THE
FACT THAT THE DEFERRALS ARE
PAID OFF HERE BUT FOR SOME
REASON THEY'RE NOT PAID OFF IN
K. THROUGH TWELVE- AND THE
THERE ARE SOME ONGOING ISSUES
WANT TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT TO CALL US FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS. AND I THINK EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED
IN THIS BUDGET IT DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY FROM A COUPLE OF ISSUES
THAT WE WANT TO. AN ON GOING
BASIS AND MAYBE NEXT YEAR LOOK
AT WHICH IS. THE HISTORIC-
ATTEMPT OVER THIRTY YEARS TO
CHANGE THE FULL TIME PART TIME
PERCENTAGE. AND ALSO THE
FORMULA WE ARE NOT ADDRESSING
THE FORMULA WE HAVE A TWO YEAR.
HOLD HARMLESS STILL IN PLACE
BECAUSE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS GO OVER FINANCIAL
CLIFF IN TWO YEARS IF WE DON'T
REVISE THAT. IT WAS MY HOPE
THAT THAT WE LOOK AT THAT IN A
MORE PERMANENT FIX. I KNOW
THERE'S A CONTRACT WITH A
CONSULTING FIRM TO LOOK AT THE
OVERALL FORMULA RATHER THAN
JOSH. I'D TRIED TO FIX IT FOR
THE WINDSORS AND HOLD HARMLESS
AN ON GOING BASIS SO MAYBE.
THAT CONSULTING WORK WILL HELP
US GOING INTO NEXT YEAR BUT
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT JUST
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED WE JUST CAN'T KEEP
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
AND WHILE WE'RE KICKING THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD BECAUSE IT WAS
PRE DECIDED FOR TWO MORE YEARS.
TO DO THE HOLD HARMLESS- I
THINK THAT NEXT YEAR WE HAVE TO
FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AND BY CALLING IT OUT NOW
NOBODY WILL BE SURPRISED OVER
THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS AND WE
TALK ABOUT IT IN. AND TRY TO
GET THERE. BUT WITH THAT. ARE
WOMEN JUST THANK EVERYBODY- FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE AND WE HAVE LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS IN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS WILL MOVE TO ISSUE FIVE
WHICH IS MY REVISION. ALSO FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE HAVE GABRIELA
CHAVEZ FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LISA KING FROM THE LA
O'S OFFICE CENTRIC BREMNER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND I KNOW THERE ARE
OTHERS AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
SO LET'S GO IN THAT ORDER. AND
WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REPRESENTATIVE. MORNING
CHAIR LAYER AND MEMBERS THAT
WERE LIKE CHILD WAS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BYE THIS
MONEY WILL BE BRIEF AND FOCUS
MOSTLY ON THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS- THE MAY REVISION
PROVIDES ONE BILLION ONE TIME
FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT FINES TO SUPPORT WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED AS A
RESULT OF THE COPA NINETY
PANDEMIC. THE PROPOSAL WILL
ALLOW THE RICE'S STUDENT A
COMMISSION CEASE ACT TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO DISPLACE WORKERS TO
THE UC. AND AS EXTENSION
CENTERS UC CSU AND CCC
CAMPUSES. GRANTS WILL RANGE
FROM ONE THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND COULD BE USED TO COVER
COSTS A PAST SECONDARY PROGRAMS
HIGH QUALITY TRAINING PROGRAMS
OR TO START A BUSINESS. HE SAID
WILL DETERMINE THE GRANT AMOUNT.
MUST PRIORITIZE THE NEEDIEST
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS AND MUST
PROVIDE AT LEAST HALF OF THAT
FUNDING TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CARING FOR
A DEPENDENT CHILD. HI AT THE
CHRISTIAN INSTITUTIONS ARE
ENCOURAGED TO MATCH GRANTS USE
OTHER INSTITUTIONS SIG AGE
SHOULD BE USED TO SELL
SUPPLEMENT AND NOT TO SUPPLANT
OTHER SOURCES OF EIGHT. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROVIDES AN
INCREASE OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FIND ONE TIME
FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. THERE IS ALSO A
TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS AUGMENTATION- WHICH
EFFECTIVELY OUT THE RICE'S
INTERNS WHO PARTICIPATE AND
TEACHING CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM. THE
TRAILER BILL ALSO AMENDS THE
DEFINITION OF A HIGH NEED FAIL
TO INCLUDE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION THERE ARE SEVERAL
CASELOAD I JUST MEANT TO
DIFFERENT CULTURAL PROGRAMS AND
THE MAY REVISION ALSO UPDATES
BECAUSE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS. BASED ON THE
LATEST AVAILABLE INFORMATION
FROM THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
SPECIFIC DETAILS DOWN QUESTIONS
ON THESE UPDATED COSTS. OR IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON THE
OTHER- THE REVISION PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WILL MOVE TO THE LA
O'S OFFICE. INTERESTED TIME
ALTHOUGH THAT'S JUST ON THE
LARGEST PROPOSAL. THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. WHICH IS THAT
ON STATE EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP TRAINING
GRANTS PROGRAM THAT THE ONE
BILLION DEBT. IT'S JUST.
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
FIRST IT ISN'T WELL CONNECTED
WITH THE STATE'S BROADER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM
INCLUDING PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS IN SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCIES. FOR CONTENT MANAGER
ASKED MANY OF THE BARRIERS TO
RETRAINING THAT DISPLACED
WORKERS FACE SUCH AS NOT
KNOWING WHAT SHOPS RETRAINED
FOR HOW TO ACCESS THAT TRAINING
ACCESS. SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH
AS CHILDCARE. PROGRAMS QUITE
DIFFERENT NATURE FROM OTHER
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION
MINISTRIES SUCH AS THE COMPOUND
PROGRAM WHICH CAME UP EARLIER
AND SHE'S HEARING. I BRING THIS
UP BECAUSE WE THINK THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT SECOND RESOURCES IN
TIME. FOR THE COMMISSION TO
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THIS NEWLY
PROPOSED PROGRAM. IT WOULD
INVOLVE NOT JUST DISTRIBUTING
GRANTS TO COLLEGE STUDENTS IS
CHRISTIAN CONNIE DOES BUT ALSO
DISTRIBUTING GRANTS TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. ENSURING THAT
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE
APPLIED FOR BUSINESS LICENSES
AND- BUILD A BUSINESS PLAN. WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING THAT
A PROGRAM THAT WOULD TAKE
SIGNIFICANT TIME RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
IT'S INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES IT IS TIME SENSITIVE
IN NATURE. JAYNE KAMIN SO GIVEN
THESE CONSIDERATIONS BEING
RECOMMENDED ACTING THIS COASTAL.
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE TRYING TO
CALL THE STATE TO TRANSFER FULL
TOMORROW SO I ATE WELL AND
COMING TOGETHER AT THIS TIME
BUT I AM HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ON ANY OTHER ITEMS
DESTINY CHRISTIAN BUDGET AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VEY
MUCH AND I WILL MOVE TO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LAYERED AND
SENATORS I'M J. BREMNER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN TODAY.
MR NATE COMMISSION IS GRATEFUL
TO SEE THE PROPOSED GOLDEN
STATE EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND TRAINING
GRANT PROGRAM INCLUDED IN THE
MAY REVISION WHICH WOULD HELP
US BETTER SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
AS THEY SEEK EDUCATIONAL AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES. OR
START THEIR OWN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE. CONFIDENT THAT WITH
THE APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING AND STAFFING
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL AS
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE AND
BUSINESS PARTNERS BUT THE
COMMISSION COULD EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING DISCONNECTED WORKERS.
A PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO BE A
MEANS OF DRAWING DISLOCATED
WORKERS BACK INTO POST
SCONDARY EDUCATION FOR UP
SKILLING AND RE SKILLING.
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS THE VERY
POPULATION THAT IS CURRENTLY
UNDER SERVED BY OUR TRADITIONAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS. AS WE
DISCUSSED AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING LAST WEEK. GRAHAM STILL
FEATURES OUTDATED RATIONING
DEVICES THEY KEEP OUT STUDENTS
OR OLDER WERE TAKING SOME TIME
TO WORK AFTER HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE ARE THE SAME STUDENTS IN
THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WHERE THEY FACE A ONE
IN EIGHT CHANCE OF RECEIVING AN
AWARD DESPITE HAVING
ELIGIBILITY BASED ON THEIR
FINANCIAL STATUS AND ACADEMIC
STAND. AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THESE GRANTS UNDER THE
GOLDEN STATE EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND TRAINING
GRANT. PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW US
TO RE ENGAGE THE SAME POTENTIAL
STUDENTS AND BRING THEM BACK
INTO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
WELL IT DROPPING THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK THAT. WE
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK WOULD
PROVIDE THEM WITH GREATER
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID TO
SUPPORT THEIR SUCCESS AFTER THE
ANIMAL. AND ALL LEAVE MY
COMMENTS THERE AND- BE PREPARED
TO TAKE ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S OF BREVITY. OF
WEBPAGES BEGIN WITH ONE
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE END- HE I WAS JUST
GOING TO ASK WHAT THE
RATIONALES FOR NOT ADDRESSING
THE STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS WITH.
THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM A
BROADER STRUCTURAL REDO SUCH AS
THE SENATE'S DEBT FREE COLLEGE
PROPOSAL RATHER THAN- THE OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
AROUND THAT. IN THE BUDGET.
HAVE A LIKE TABLETS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THANK
YOU CHAIR FOR THE QUESTION THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT HAVE A
DECISION ON ON THE PROPOSAL AT
THIS MOMENT. I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT BOTH THE COUPLE YEARS BY
DID AND THE MAIN REVISION
INCLUDING BASEMENTS TO REDUCE
THE AUTHOR- COST OF ATTENDANCE
FOR STUDENTS AND THIS PROPOSED
ON AUGMENTATION USE THE
MAJORITY OF THE ONE TIME FUNDS
THAT DID NOT HAVE THE SAME TYPE
OF PRESSURE A LIABILITY. TO THE
OVERALL STATE BUDGET SOME OF
THESE INVESTMENT INCLUDING
STUDENT HOUSING- INCREASED
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
CONFERENCE CHILD SAFETY SEAT
COUNTS AND THE REDUCED TEXTBOOK
COSTS FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE- FOUR
BILLION. ONE TIME GENERAL FINE.
WE WILL BE A SPY INTO DID YOU.
TO EXCEL AS A LAW BECAUSE
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT. WHICH
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
SITTING HOUSE. THANK YOU I
THINK. THAT IN SOME WAYS TALK
SO WELL ROUNDED BUT IT DOESN'T
MATTER BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
REALLY COMMITTED TO A
RESTRUCTURING OF THE- OF THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND I
THINK THAT WILL BE- I TALKED
ABOUT IT EARLIER IN THE HEARING
I THINK THAT WILL BE OUR
CONVERSATION THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
AND WE WERE REALLY. WHAT TO
WORK ON THAT AND DO THAT
SERIOUSLY SO APPRECIATE- YOUR
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION-
SENATORS OTHER QUESTIONS.
CENTERMAN. I WANNA BE KISSED-
ASK A SIMILAR VERSION OF THE
QUESTION I ASKED EARLIER- ON
THE GOLDEN STATE EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND TRAINING
GRANT PROGRAM- I COMPLETELY
APPLAUD THE GOALS OF THIS- I
GUESS MY QUESTION AGAIN IS TO
WHAT DEGREE DOES THIS DUPLICATE
EXISTING- PROGRAMS OUT THERE
JUST BECAUSE ANY TIME AGAIN YOU
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM- IT. MEANS
THERE'S ONE MORE THING IN A
STUDENT SEEKING AID NEEDS TO
FIGURE OUT- IT'S ONE MORE STEP
THEY HAVE TO TAKE AND IT'S MANY
MORE PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO HIRE TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM- SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS- IS IT
POSSIBLE TO ROUTE THIS THROUGH
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO A DEGREE
C. C. UNIQUE AND TO WHAT DEGREE
DOES IT DUPLICATE. EXISTING
PROGRAMS. NINE I GUESS THAT'S
FOR THE PART IN FINANCE OR CCC.
GOVERNMENT JOBS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION CENTER MAIN- THIS
PROGRAM IS VERY SPECIFIC. ADDED
TO THE PASSCODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS USING AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN AN AXE- IT IS
STAYING TEN OF THE PROGRAM TO
ASSIST INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC-
THEREFORE THEY ARE NOT EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT DIRECTLY ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS. OUR HOPE IS THAT
WE USE IN THIS FEDERAL ONE TIME
FUNDS WE CAN SUPPORT THE
DISPLACED WORKERS WERE SEEKING
BEING RESKILL AND UPSKILL
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES OR
ARE TRYING TO START A NEW
BUSINESS- I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY OF THE FEEDBACK TO MY
MANAGEMENT TEAM. ALL UP WITH
THE- YES IT'S NO I THINK YOU'RE
MICROPHONE- SORRY LET ME JUST
FOLLOW UP HERE. IT IS A NEW
PROGRAM I GET THAT BUT- TO WHAT
DEGREE DO ITS PURPOSE SEES- YOU
KNOW COULD THEY BE ROUTED
THROUGH EXISTING PROGRAMS OR DO
YOU NEED TO ESTABLISH SOMETHING
NEW TO ALLOCATE THIS.
PARTICULAR SET OF AID. WE ARE
LOOKING AT HOW THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE STRUCTURED- TWO US
SEES INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED AND UCLA- DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES WHERE HOPING TO HAVE
IT BE APPROACHED- HE HE BACK TO
MINE- COLIC BREANNA PRINCE WHO
HAS WORKED ON IT. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR AFTER YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR MEN I WOULD ECHO GOT
REALIZED THAT EARLIER COMMENTS
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING THIS
IS A PROGRAM TO REALLY DIRECT
YEAH THE MEDIA NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO'VE BEEN
DISPLACED DUE TO THE COLD IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SO WELL YES
WE DO THAT THE STATE HAS A
LARGE VARIETY OF FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE STUDENTS
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY TAILORED
SPECIFICALLY TO DISPLACED
WORKERS- MANY OF WHOM WE ARE
NOT CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
SO WE'RE SEEING THIS AS A WAY.
TO BETTER ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS
IN THE MOMENT. AND THEN I GUESS
I GUESS MY ONLY YOU KNOW
WITHOUT KNOWING ALL THE
SPECIFICS AND I TRUST YOU GUYS
TO DO THE NECESSARY RESEARCH
AND- BUT I GUESS MY- BROADER
POINT WOULD BE THAT ANY TIME
YOU SET UP A NEW PROGRAM. EIGHT
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET RELIEF
OUT QUICKLY. THAT'S NOT THE WAY
TO DO IT IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACTUALLY DO THAT IMMEDIATELY
TRY TO. REACH OUT TO DISPLACE
COVERT STUDENTS ARE WORKERS- I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS MORE
EFFECTIVE TO USE EXISTING
PATHWAYS THAT ESTABLISH THAT
STUDENTS AND WORKERS ARE AWARE
OF- THEY HAVE SOME PENETRATION
AND STAFF AND ALL THAT RATHER
THAN TRY TO BUILD UP SOMETHING
NEW SO. I GUESS MY STRONG BIAS
WOULD BE TO SAY THAT IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO ROUTE THESE FUNDS
THROUGH. EXISTING PATHWAYS AND
PROGRAMS- THAT WOULD BE FAR
PREFERABLE THAN TRYING TO
CREATE SOMETHING BRAND NEW ON.
BUT YEAH I CAN I TRUST YOU GUYS
AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW. TAKING
THIS SERIOUSLY AND LOOKING AT
THAT POINT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN- THAT
COMPLETES- THAT ITEM AND- I
APPRECIATE THE- THE COMMENTS
AND WE'VE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE STILL
GONNA HAVE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THE LAST ITEM- ON THE AGENDA
ISSUE SIX VARIOUS MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IN HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW. WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OHIO
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
AND STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE I
KNOW THAT EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
LIKE THE AND FOUGHT FOR WE ARE
RUNNING LATE AND STILL HAVE TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT SO I'M-
JUST. ASK EVERYBODY TO REFLECT
ON THAT WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DONALD
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN FIRST JENNIFER TALKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL BE PRESENTING ON THE
VARIOUS ISSUES- IN THIS ISSUE.
SHOW JUST START OFF- WE'LL
START OFF WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE ONE THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLLEGE
SERVICE PROGRAM. REVISION OF
THE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME OF
WHICH TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT
FUNDING AND FORTY FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS. TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLLEGE
SERVICE PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA JUNIOR COLLEGES.
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE UP TO
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PART TIME JOB OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND CRITICAL
ISSUE AREAS SUCH AS CLIMATE
ACTION EDUCATION AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. HELP IN DISASTER
RESPONSE. WORKING IN THAT. WILL
GAIN. EXPERIENCE WACHTER THEIR-
I WILL BE ELIGIBLE. FOR UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
COMPENSATION VIA SKYPE AND
CALLER SHIP. NEXT I'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
PROPOSAL. A MEMBER OF THE FOUR
BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT HOUSING- OUT EVENLY
OVER TWO YEARS TWO MILLION
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
BILLION AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FINANCE AUTHORITY WIL
ADMINISTER GRANTS THE THREE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AND-
STUDENT HOUSING PROPOSAL AIMED
TO ADDRESS HOUSING INSECURITY
BY COVERING THE UP FRONT COST
OF HOUSING CONSTRUCTION OR
HOUSING ACQUISITION AND
RENOVATION AND INCREASING THE
AVAILABILITY OF LOW COST
HOUSING TO DIRECTLY. ADDRESS
STUDENT DOCTOR TENDED. NEXT
I'LL BE TALKING BACK TO REACH
CHARACTERISTICS AND YOU CAN
CLASS. MAY REVISION INCLUDING
IN THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH BUDGET AIMED AT
ALIGNING HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEED. IN MINISTRATION
ALLOCATING THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND SET ASIDE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM FOR
REGIONAL TEACHERS SIXTEEN
COLLABORATIVE. THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. WOULD
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COLLABORATIVE
THAT INCLUDES. AT LEAST ONE
CAMPUS WHEN ALL THREE PUBLIC
SEGMENT PRE OCCUPATIONAL
PATHWAYS THAT LEAD TO HIGH
PAYING IN DEMAND JOBS AND A
DOCTOR RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY
THE HIGHER EDUCATION RECOVERY
WITH EQUITY TAX FOR. LASTLY
I'LL BE TALKING AT THE HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW. THE MAYOR
VERSION IS THREE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT AN
ALTERNATIVE CAMPUS PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAM HE RECENTLY IS
STATING GENERATED DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN CAN'T SHUT DOWN
THE PILOT WHAT HAD BECOME A
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE PROGRAM. AND
MAKING THE FUNDS AVAILABLE OVER
THREE YEARS WELL I HATE TO HATE
THANK YOU EXTEND IT AND
PRESERVE IT BENEFITS. WITHOUT
MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND ARE
ALSO JOINED BY REPRESENTATIVES
FROM HASTINGS THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL PLANT THE GORY THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH PLANNING AND
RESEARCH AND HEALTH AND
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I DO KNOW THAT THERE'S-
PEOPLE. FOR ANSWERING QUESTIONS
IN ADDITION TO OUR FOUR
PANELISTS WILL GO TO THE OHIO'S
OFFICE. FACING CONSTANT
TORRICELLI L. IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME ALL FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
THE LARGEST PROPOSAL WHICH IS
THAT A STUDENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPOSAL. WELL HERE WE
DON'T HAVE- HARD RECOMMENDATION
AND I'LL ALSO POINT OUT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
RELEASED THE ASSOCIATED TRAILER
LEGISLATION. SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROVIDE ON UNTIL THAT'S
RELEASED. BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE DID WANT TO RAISE A COUPLE
OF KEY ISSUES FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER AS YOU'RE WEIGHING
THIS PROPOSAL. THE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE IS THAT ON THE SURFACE
THIS WOULD BE A NEW DIRECTION
FOR THE STATE. OF. AND
SUPPORTING ACADEMIC FACILITY
PROJECTS- WITH HOUSING PROJECTS
BEING SUPPORTED. BY STUDENT FEE
REVENUE- IT'S ALSO A NEW
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING FORD ABILITY AND
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS
TRIED TO ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY
BY EXPANDING FINANCIAL AID.
BECAUSE THIS WOULD BE A NEW
DIRECTION THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
UNCERTAINTIES TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON
AFFORDABILITY- WE DON'T HAVE
HARD ESTIMATES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON. HOW MANY
BEDS THIS WOULD- CONSTRUCT BUT-
BASEDON DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. IT'S ALSO
LIKELY THAT THE PROPOSAL WOULD-
FIND- SPANNED A BED FOR A
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS BUT
WOULDN'T COVER. ME FOR ALL
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS.
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE SOME
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS WHO
WOULD WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT
OTHER STUDENTS WHO MIGHT NOT.
ANOTHER ISSUE TO THINK ABOUT IS
IMPLEMENTATION ABOUT WHAT WE
WANT WE'VE TALKED TO THE
SEGMENTS OF THE SEGMENTS HAD A
PARTICULARLY UNIVERSITIES AND
SOME YEARS RAMPED UP STUDENT
HOUSING- SO THEY THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED SOME ABILITY TO DO
THAT WE'VE ALSO HEARD- FROM
CAMPUSES IN THE PAST THOUGH
THAT THEY DO FACE SOME LOCAL
CONSTRAINTS IN EXPANDING
HOUSING- TO THE EXTENT THAT-
THEY FACE CONSTRAINTS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THAT THAT COULD IMPACT
THEIR ABILITY TO SPEND DOWN THE
FUNDS. AND THE FINAL THING
FINALLY SHOULD CONSIDER IS A
GIVEN THAT THIS WOULD BE SORT
OF A NEW WAY OF APPROACHING
HOUSING STUDENT HOUSING. WHICH
WOULD CONSTRAIN. OUR RENTS FOR
STUDENTS. TO RAISE A QUESTION
ONCE HOT ONCE THE FACILITIES
ARE BUILT- WHERE THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO MAINTAIN
THE FACILITIES LONG TERM. ON
THAT NOTE I AGAIN FOR THE
SECOND TIME I LEAVE IT THERE
AND- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
PHONE. THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. YES GOT MORGAN NO
NO FURTHER COMMENT ON THAT ON
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE- SIXTEEN
PROPOSAL THAT DLF PRESENTED ON
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
NEEDED. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATRINA JO HANSON AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND
THANK YOU FOR CONDUCTING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING. I'M C.
SURVEY- HAS ADMINISTERED AND
CREATED. AND IMPLEMENTED A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS- WE- CREATED FOR NEW
PROGRAMS IN THE LAST. TWELVE
MONTHS- TO ADDRESS TE ISSUES
RELATED TO CODE AND FINDING
RELIEF FOR KEEP FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS- WE ALSO ADMINISTER
OF THE STATE- CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM WHICH IS A ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM. WHICH FINANCES THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF EXISTING FACILITIES FOR
SCHOOL FACILITIES- SO WE ARE
EQUIPPED AND YOU KNOW GEARED UP
TO ADMINISTER SUCH A PROGRAM-
SHOULD THIS PASS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I ONE QUESTION FOR
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF HASTINGS
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT I'M JUST
GOING TO MAKE A COMMENT. THE
TWO OUT OF THREE THESE PROGRAMS
THOSE SERVICE PROGRAM AND THE
STUDENT HOUSING. STILL LACKED A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF DETAIL
ON THE RATHER THAN ASK
QUESTIONS. TODAY ABOUT THINGS
THAT DON'T HAVE ALL THE DETAILS
I THINK WE WILL JUST RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO. ENTER INTO
INTENSE CONVERSATIONS AND GO IN
ANY DIRECTION ONCE WE HAVE THE
DETAIL ON THOSE PROGRAMS AND-
THAT WOULD BE IN FOR IMPORTANT
TO US. IN A REALLY SORRY FOR
THE HASTINGS REPRESENTATIVE
BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE THE
PAPERWORK THAT I MEANT TO BRING
WITH ME A SENATE REPORT TO
TINO. BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION-
AIDS SCHOLARSHIP OR AID PROGRAM
AND IT INVOLVES- OF JERRY
STUDENTS OF SOME I THINK ARE
FOREIGN STUDENTS. AND THERE'S A
FEW PEOPLE IN IT NOW BUT NOT
THE FULL AMOUNT I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS SOUNDS RECOGNIZABLE. BUT I
WONDERED IF THE BUDGET DEALS
WITH THIS AND ANYONE. THE
CENTERS THAT DAVID STEWARDS
THAT CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
FOR UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW-
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SENATOR PORTMAN CHINO ON A-
REPLENISHMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARS PROGRAM. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. FUNDS WERE
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
FOR A MULTI YEAR PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE. CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN UNDER-
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO- RECEIVE A
SCHOLARSHIP AWARDS TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO RETURN TO CALIFORNIA TO
PURSUE THEIR LEGAL STUDIES AND
TWO OF. INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THEM PRACTICING LAW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY IN THE- IN THE
PRACTICE SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE CENTER'S OFFICE THAT WAS
NOT A- MAJOR REVISION PROPOSAL-
WE'RE HAVING A DISCUSSION.
LATER THIS WEEK FOR FURTHER
WORK WITH THE- STAFF ON THAT
SUBJECT. EXCUSE ME JUST KEEP US
INFORMED BY CLOSER THAT WE KNOW
IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE NEED TO
DO. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE OF LET ME
JUST ONCE AGAIN SAY WE
APPRECIATED. ALL THE PANELISTS
HERE AND THAT THERE'S TWO OF
THOSE FOR WHICH THEY'RE NOT
DETAIL MOST OF CONVERSATION. ON
THIS NOW THE ONE REMAINING
THINGS IN THE HEARING. IS
PUBLIC COMMENT AND IT'S ON ANY
ITEM WE'VE CONSIDERED TODAY AND
WE ARE RUNNING WAY OVER SO.
WE'LL SEE WHAT. R. F. AND I
WILL RELEASE THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THREE WEEKS
ONE HAS TO BE SOME MORE KNOWN-
BUT THE- LET'S GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT FIRST IN THIS ROOM.
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NO ONE THEN
MODERATOR- THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
ON THE TELECONFERENCES SYSTEM
THERE'S NOT. OF FOREIGN AGAINST
SO- COULD YOU PLEASE WIRED UP
AND NORMALLY WE LIMIT TO A
MINUTE IN PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE ROOM FOREVER I'LL SEE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN LINE AND
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO
MENTION THAT SO MODERATOR. DO
WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE LINE. WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE ON THE LINE YEP
ROC TWENTY QUEUED UP AT THIS
POINT I WOULD SAY AND I'LL GO
AHEAD AND GIVE THE INSTRUCTIONS
REAL QUICK HERE IF YOU DO NOT
WISH TO. MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR PROPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFF LINE IN PLACE
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. AND
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I FIRST. BEEN
MODERATOR JUST BEFORE YOU DO
THAT- I'M GONNA TRY TO LIMIT TO
THIRTY SECONDS BECAUSE- WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE ROOM TO GET
THROUGH EVERYBODY SO. AND IF
ANYBODY JUST WANTS TO BE REALLY
BRIEF THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND A GENERAL
GLOBAL POSITION. THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL FOR OTHER
PEOPLE. SO MODERATOR THANK YOU
LET'S KEEP HIM UP AND LET'S.
LISTEN TO THE PUBLIC. OKAY HERE
WE GO- YOU PROBABLY HAVE IT
OUT. WELL OVER TWENTY FIVE CUED
UP NOW AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY ONE YEAR LATER GOVERNMENT
REPUBLICAN AND- CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU FOR ENTERTAINING ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE FISH OF COURSE THE
TWO POINT ONE NINE WHEN THE
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF WEBSITE VISITORS
AND STUDENT ERSONALLY COLLEGE
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF MOST OF THE
GOVERNORS OPPOSE A SPECIALLY
THE THIRTY MILLION ON GOING
WHICH IS ESTABLISHED BASEMENT
CENTERS AND COORDINATORS ROADS
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IN THE
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE NANCY REAGAN
RAGE. WELL SUCH INCIDENTS
PRESERVING THE PROBLEM YOU'RE
CALLING ABOUT MONTREAL FOR
OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS AND
INSTEAD URGED USE OF PROPS YOU
THREE DOLLARS TO MEET THIS NEED
FINALLY DIRGE OCCURS WITH
OPTION TO COVER EQUITY PER
MONTH THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO GO OVER BECAUSE
YOU WERE LIKE STARTING BUT HI
I'M GONNA TRY TO HOLD PEOPLE.
TO THAT MODERATOR NEXT PERSON.
THANK THREE CALL- YOU KEEP CRUZ
RELIGIOUS CORRECT THANK YOU
SANDRA AND THEN IT TO ME FOR
YOUR ON HOW INSTITUTION AND I'M
PRESIDENT RESOURCES THAT WE
NEED AT THIS TIME- I'M CALLING
IT SUPPORT THE CALIBER AND
MODERNIZATION ACT AS THE BEST
BUT WE NEED IT. I WOULD HOPE
THAT THAT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
AT YOUR DISCRETION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THE COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. FIND FISH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THE LEGAL BAN ON
BEHALF OF THE EXTENDED
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS SERVICES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE ADDITION OF THE TRAILER
LEAVE AND FUNDING THE MERRY BY
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE
DISAPPOINTED BY THE LACK OF
FUNDING DEDICATED ARTIFACT YEAH
DEREK NICHOLS I'M HIRING AND WE
OFFER A GREAT SENATOR LET ME
THROW ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
STUDENT CENTER. YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ERICA
REMEMBER HAPPENING HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WILL SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUTREACH
AND ACADEMIC PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
TRAINING ON THE FINANCIAL AID
AND TO SUPPORT THE REGIONAL
COOPERATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHEN YOU JAMMED A LOT IN THERE
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH MANY
RODRIGUEZ MAGICIAN TRUST WES WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A ONCE IN A.
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO
REFORM THE BEST AND BROADER AND
MORE EQUITABLE FUNDING TRADE
SYSTEM THE TEAM GOING ON THE
EDGES SO THE MORE WE BACKED
REMINDED THE COMMITTEE THAT NOR
FOR ANY STUDENT TO TAP INTO
FINANCIAL SYSTEM WE NEED TO
FILL OUT A FOSTER CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT THAT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ENSURE A
LEASE HOW DO YOU STOP THE SWANS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I CAN MORNING COULD YOU
KNOW LEADING UP TO THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE
INCOME IF THE COURT WILL BUDGET
IMPACT CRITICAL TO ENSURING THE
VIABILITY BIRTH REQUIRE-
FINDING YOUR PEOPLE ON THE
FLOOR LET ME LOOK. BACK THE
CONTRACT ON THE TIRE AND-
ENSURING THAT ONE OF THE TOP
CHOICE OKAY HOW BECAUSE APPEAR
I. SECOND LECTURE BACKPACKING
I'M SHOCKED WITH WHAT ACCOUNT
WILL ON. CONNECTION AND FINALLY
REQUIRE THE CREATION OF A
VESSEL PARKWAY BUT YEAH LIVING
ROOM. ASK CAN'T REMEMBER IF I
CAN'T COMPLAIN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED PROVIDES INFORMATION
DIDN'T- WITH YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COLUMN CLICK CLICK THANK YOU
FOR MUCH FOR YOUR COM. AND TO
EVERYONE YOU CONNECT EXTEND
YOUR COMMENTS WITH WRITTEN
COMMENTS. TO THE COMMITTEE
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANKS SIX
FIVE ARE RIGHT. BY SIXTY FIVE
MINUTES GO AHEAD. EMILY RODEN
BETTER WITH THAT YEAH YOU WE
WERE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
INCLUSION OF LABOR IN THE
BUDGET BUT THE CLEAN
ELECTRICITY THE CLASSIFIED
BALLERINA BACK NEEDING THAT
INVERSION ADDRESS YOU'D LIKE TO
EAT THE EMPLOYEE ABOUT WHAT
THEIR JOB INITIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC BE RESTORED WITH THE
MONEY THAT WAS RESTORED IN THE
BUDGET- AND WE'D LIKE TO BE AN
IMPROVEMENT ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH FACULTY RATIO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL LYING TO TWO GOING.
HELLO MY NAME IS KRISTIN
EDWARDS AND I'M TAKING A BIG
RISK FOR COLLEGE I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THIRTY
MILLION. INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS. I WOULD ALSO ASK THAT
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE
REFLECTS THE LANGUAGE IN
EIGHTY. SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
ENSURING THAT EVERY CAMPUS HAS
THE BASIC NEEDS CENTER WITH
DEDICATED STAFF BUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO NEED EXTRA
HELP AND SUPPORT TO GET TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
THANKS SIXTY THREE YOUR UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DEBBIE
RASHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE BASIC
NEEDS AND ALSO ON A REQUESTED
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE REFLECT
THE PROVISIONS OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT ATTEMPTING TO COMBINE
BASIC NEEDS AND FINANCIAL AID
SERVICES SYSTEM WIDE AT THIS
TIME WOULD BE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF STUDENTS AND
CAMPUSES SHOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU
A LOT ALIKE TWELVE GO HEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH CHRIS AND I'M A
SOPHOMORE AT CENTER COLLEGE I
AM HERE THANK YOU EXPECT MY
POINT FOR THE THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
DIFFICULT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
BY TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCUMENT OKAY- WELL DOCUMENTED
SHORTAGE OF THAT THE BACKPACK
COMBINED WITH FINANCIAL IMPACT
TO COPE WITH NEW PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ARE UNABLE TO
ACCESS WHO ARE THE MOST BASIC
OF BATTLING CANCER WHICH MEANS
MORE ANIMALS WITH CONTINUING
SHELTER WHICH TOOK AN ADDED
BURDEN ON THE COUNTY CONTINUE
TO CARE FOR PLATES OF
EUTHANIZED THE ANIMAL. BUT ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER TAXPAYERS WILL
BE PAYING FOR THAT STOP BY THE
GRANTS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
IMPACT THE PROGRAM'S BEEN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT A DROP BUT
LUKAKU'S ANIMALS ENTERING
SHELTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
I THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD. THANK
YOU TO WHERE MARK MCDONALD MC A
YUP THE APPLE SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES PERALTA NUMBER DINO
COLLEGE. JUST A COUPLE POINTS
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THESE REAL
CUTS TEXTBOOKS. PROPOSAL BUT
BELIEVE THE GRANTS NEED TO BE
HIGHER ALSO WOULD REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL 1% BASE INCREASED TO
BRING COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
ALIGN WITH UCCS HUNAN CAN
TWELVE. ALSO AGREE WITH YOUR
COMMENT ON THE FUNDING FORMULA
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. I AM FIFTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CHRIS I'M A HUNTER LET'S DO
THAT AND WHAT STATE I ALONG
WITH MY FELLOW STUDENTS ARE
GRATEFUL FOR GOVERNANCE AND
REVISED BUDGET WHICH IS A
COMMITMENT TO INVESTING IN THE
NATION'S MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY. THE ANOTHER
NOTE YOU HAVE BEEN CLEAR THAT
WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE REFORM OF
THE CAL GRANT SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
OUR LOWEST. I ENCOURAGE THE
TENANTS WORKERS INCREASING
INVESTMENT IN THE COVER AND
SUPPORTING AT FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. BY INVESTING IN FORMING IN
THE CONFERENCE WITH THEM WE CAN
BUILD A FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
THAT. OPERATED IN EQUITY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. BY TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ONE BUT WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CSU STUDENT WE'D LIKE TO THANK
STATE LEADERS FOR PRIORITIZING
INVESTMENTS INTO THE THEATER
YOU. HAVE TO ENGAGE IN THE
NEGOTIATING THE FINAL BUDGET WE
HOPE THAT YOU INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL COURT INVESTMENT AND
THE COMMENTS OF SOME WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND INTEREST IN
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS WE BELIEVE
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM IS
NECESSARY. TO FULLY SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS. BUT THEN IT GOES BACK
WELL WE BUDGET OUTLINE PRIOR.
AND BACK TO. THE CURRENT SYSTEM
WE BELIEVE THOSE INVESTMENTS
MARRIED WITH AT FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. WATCHING THE COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING COURT THANK YOU
TRAILER FOR COMMITMENT ON THIS
ISSUE. AND I HOPE YOU'LL
SUPPORT THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. FIFTY
ONE NINETY ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TAYLOR RUSSIAN AT THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND ON
BEHALF OF A LARGE. IT'S NOT AN
ON GOING FOR YOU THE ACTING
NATURAL RESOURCES RATHER THAN
PULLING THE 5% INCREASE. AT THE
PRESENT IN THE REVISED AND
BROUGHT THE CONCERN WITH THE
REMOVAL OF THE LINE ITEM FOR
THE REASONS NOTED BY THE CHAIR
AND OTTOMAN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
BUYING SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GREAT WITH
THE ICC REPRESENTING OVER
EIGHTY PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES IN THE STATE WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOLDEN STTE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM
AUGMENTATION- IN REGARDS TO
THE- REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE- WE
WOULD STRESS THAT WE HAVE THREE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE IN THE
EXISTING COLLABORATIVE AND FAT
NOW AND WITHOUT THAT D. RF
PEAS- SIMILARLY REQUIRE- THE
INCLUSION OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
IN THOSE FUTURE COLLABORATIVE.
AND IN REGARDS TO A
COMPREHENSIVE- CAL GRANT
IMPROVEMENTS WE DISTRACTED IN
OVER TWENTY YEARS OF THE CAL
GRANT AWARDED INCREASED FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE SOME KIND OF CPI ADJUSTMENT
TO PROVIDE A LONG OVERDUE
INCREASED ABOUT WORK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH A
MODERATOR MEXICO. FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAKE A MARK
ON BEHALF OF THE STRUCTURE WILL
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE MEMBER PLANE WHICH CRASHED
INTO COMMON AND I SAID NOT.
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM BUT
WITH A COMMON ELEMENT QUITE
TRANSFER STUDENTS. BETTER
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES. IN
ADDITION I BELIEVE THAT A
COMMON ALABASTER THE NECESSARY
BUILDING BLOCKS THE FUTURE
CALLS RELATED APPLICABLES TO
CHECK BACK WITH YOU TRACK. BUT
AROUND CRADLE TO CAREER.
COLLEGES HAVE THAN CURRENT
ALABASTER AND BUT THAT REMINDS
BAD OF. HE ADDED THAT FOUND IT
TO BE ABOUT PRODUCT FOR THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I COULD.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BY
NAME IF YOU CAN READ WITH THE
ASPCA SPEAKING AT THE ANIMAL
SHELTER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM-
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WE
HAD A POLICY ON THE BOOKS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
YOU KNOW A DOCTOR FOR TREATABLE
ANIMAL SHOULD BE EUTHANIZED AND
WE'RE EXTREMELY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE PREEMINENT- AT THE READY ON
BEST PRACTICES IN RESEARCH. IN
IN SHELTERING AND- THE PROGRAM.
HELP US TO FINALLY MEET THIS
GOAL THAT'S BEEN ON THE BOOKS
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR LAYERED AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH THE REAR WITH
YOUNG INVINCIBLES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS. HELLO
THAT THERE BE IMPLEMENTING
LANGUAGE THAT REFLECT
PROVISIONS OF EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE THIS LANGUAGE WILL
GIVE CAMPUSES LIKE MINE
DEFECTED ABBAS IS LIKE EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BUILD I'M A
PROFESSIONAL EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN
TO DATE WHILE SOMETIMES LANE
SHARING THAT EVERY CAMPUS
OFFERS A BASS LINE OF SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. FORTY FIVE
EURO PLEASE AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JILL TUCKER AND I'M THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDREDS OF MUNICIPAL AND NON
PROFIT SHELTERS WE REPRESENT WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDS PROPOSED TO DEVELOP A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR ANIMAL
SHELTERS. CHILDREN'S RECEIVE NO
STATE FUNDING AND THE DISPARITY
OF RESOURCES AMONG THE AGENCIES
IF SIGNIFICANT MORE SUPPORTIVE
NEEDED TO ENSURE OUR STATE IS
ABLE TO THINK ABOUT HELPING
UNTREATABLE HATS AND
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
DISASTERS MANY SHELTERS ARE
FACING SIGNIFICANT BUDGET CUTS
TO THE CUPBOARD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. CREATING A CRISIS
THAT MAY VERY WELL
CONSTANTINOPLE LIVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU
NINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ALLISON CARDONA DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY ANIMAL
CARE AND CONTROL AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
ANIMAL WELFARE GRANT FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO UC
DAVIS CORRECTION. SHELTER
MEDICINE PROGRAM WE CAN
ADVOCATE FOR THAT AND NOT FIRST
OF ALL YOU SEE THERE IS. A
PREMIER ORGANIZATION THAT IS
PROVIDING BEST PRACTICE LIVING
DIED IN THE STANDARDIZED ANIMAL
SHELTERING ACROSS H. AND IN
ADDITION THE FUNDING WILL HELP
LOW INCOME. OWNERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CORPORATE ACCESS RESOURCES AND
YOU. VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. FORTY NINE PLEASE GO.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JAN CAPS
ON THE PROVOST AT- LOOKED AT
UNIVERSITY IN SPEAKING IN FAVOR
OF THE FUNDING FOR HIM NOT TO
BECOME A POLYTECHNIC INSTITUTE
IS VERY MUCH A POLYTECHNIC
ALREADY WITHOUT A DESIGNATION
AND WE CURRENTLY LEAD THE
NUMBER OF FINE MJORS ALLOWING
THE FUNDING WOULD HELP SUPPORT
IMMEDIATE BUILD OUT ADDITIONAL
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND HIGH WORK
FORCE. IN CALIFORNIA AREAS WTH
THAT- ARE LIMITED. ON DATA
CAPACITY LIKE MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING AND- ENGINEERING
ADDITIONALLY FUNDING WOULD
ALLOW US. TO BUILD UP PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THE PRIORITIES THE
STATE HAS IDENTIFIED LIKE
ENERGY SYSTEMS ENGINEERING
PROGRAMMING TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND APPLIED FIRE SIGN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE IT AND
YOU CAN REVISE AND EXTEND
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. FIFTEEN
YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ARGHA NEED
MANY PERCENT I TEACH AT THE- AT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE ANSWER
WITHIN THEM AT THE BACK OF THE
UNION- ERIC YEP YOU PRESENT
THERE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS AND ADDITIONAL HERE TO
PROVIDE. STABILITY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AT. BUT CALL UP A-
COLLEGES AND ADDITIONAL 1% TO
MATCH COLLECTING K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. YOU AND THE UC AS WELL
AS REMOVE THE CONTINGENCY HAS
LASTLY I. ASKED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ELIMINATE HELP
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON CENTER THERE MY NAME
IS CODY WHAT SHOULD YOU DO YOU
JUST YOU SERVICE ABOUT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE LOCATED IN LA
COUNTY I'M HERE TO EXPRESS M
SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
BECAUSE IT NEEDS. BUT ALSO
AFTER THE VEHICLE BODY LANGUAGE
THAT REFLECTS THE LANGUAGE IN
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE FOUR
BTC CENTER AND EQUITABLE
STOPPING AT EVERY GRADE
COLLEGES REQUIRE STUDENTS
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION THAT
MOUNTED ON THE COSBY AFTER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA IS
AMERICAN STUDIES CENTER I'M
CALLING TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR THE LINE ITEM INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISE AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL THE
PROPOSED INCREASE OF FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME FUND TO
SUPPORT ANALYSIS AND RESEARCH
ASSOCIATED WITH PREVENTION OF
HATE INCIDENTS EXPERIENCED BY
APEC MEETINGS WITH VERY TIMELY.
AT EIGHT O'CLOCK CONDUCT
RESEARCH ON YOUR CREDIBILITY
THE CALIFORNIA DEVELOP
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND
TRAINING TO ADDRESS RACIALLY
MOTIVATED MOTIVATED HATE
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORTING AND
CONTINUE FUNDING TARGET MANY
PARTNERS ATTRACTING THE RIGHT
BAND EIGHT AND EIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK AND- JUST THE
PART BE REFINING THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR
OF AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE
WERE TWENTY FIVE CALLERS AND WE
JUST CROSSED TWENTY FIVE
CALLERS. HOW MANY MORE ARE
QUEUED UP RIGHT. YEAH WE HAD A
MORE UP BUT THERE LET'S SEE I'M
THE KIND. QUICK SIXTEEN. I'M
GONNA TAKE THE NEXT FIVE
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL WE HAVE TIME
FOR THE ROOM AND THEN WE WILL
ALLOW EVERYBODY TO- TO MAKE
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
AFTERWARDS SO LET'S TAKE THE
NEXT FIVE CALLERS MODERATOR
LET'S GO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR NEXT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M GOING TO BE HAPPY
WITH YOU INDIVIDUALLY SIXTY
FIVE NINETEEN THOUSAND WORKERS
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
STUDENT HOUSING ITEM IN WORKERS
EVERY YOU CAN EXPECT AN AVERAGE
OF THIRTY EIGHT. PERCENT OF
INCOME HOUSING HM INSPECTORS
THAT PREVENTS STUDENTS FROM
ATTENDING YOU ARE AVAILABILITY
OF PORTABLE HOUSING AND AMOUNT
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT. SUPPORT
AND JUSTIN THE CURRENT PLAN TO
CHANGE ANYTHING CHRISTMAS
REQUESTING ANYTHING HELPING
ENSURE THE FRIEND BERNIE
CURRENTLY CONSULTING WORKERS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THIS
WITH YOU IN THE COMING DAYS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR. COMMENTS MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. SEVENTY EURO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LAURA BOB BREAKFAST INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS SUCCESS WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUED RECOGNITION OF THE
BURDEN OF NON TUITION COSTS AND
HAS RECENTLY PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
UNDERLYING COSTS THE MOBILE
STORAGE INVESTMENTS WOULD HELP
BUILD FOR THE FUTURE IN WHICH
TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS ARE WITHIN
REACH FURTHER STRENGTHENING
STRENGTHENING THE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STATE.
RECORDS DIDN'T RELY ON TODAY
THE FACT THAT THE KING COLLEGE
REMAINS A CRITICAL PRIORITY FOR
INVESTING IN A BUDGET THAT
INCLUDES ADDRESSING THE
CONTRACT PROGRAM STRUCTURE
ELEMENTS EACH AND BY EXTENDING
AN EMPOWERMENT AWARD TO AT
LEAST ALL STUDENTS WITH PELL
GRANT ELIGIBLE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND PROVIDING
ROBOTS ACT THAT THE WORDS FOR
NON TUITION COSTS. AS LAID OUT
IN THE CABINET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL THANK YOU.
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE ALSO. HELLO
MY NAME IS FROM AM THE MANAGER
OF THE CITY OF SENTIMENT FRONT
STREET ANIMAL SHELTER MANY OF
OUR SYSTEMS OF GOVERNMENT AND
NONPROFIT RATHER STATE DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PROPERLY
CARE FOR ANIMALS AND WE DO NOT
HAVE THE PROPER RESOURCES TO DO
SO I HAPPEN TO SUPPORT GOVERNOR
NATION BUT- PROPOSED FORTY FIVE
MILLION FUNDING TO THE UC DAVIS
SUBSEQUENT MEDICINE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND DEDICATED STAFF TO HELP THE
MOST UNDERSERVED SHOPPERS AND
COMMUNITY CARE ST WITH ONE TIME
FUNDING WILL HELP IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF BOTH THAT IN PEOPLE
WHILE ALSO HELPING CHICKEN AND
THAT'S WITH YOUR EUTHANASIA OF
HEALTHY INCREDIBLE ANIMALS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. SEVENTY
SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT
EITHER BUT I WITH THE K.
ESCALATION AND WE'D LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY TURN
THERE BUT GET MINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REFORM THE
CURRENT CAL GRANT PROGRAM. WAS
NEED A STEER IN THE BUDGET TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
AND FINANCIAL AID WELCOME
STRUCK THE BAR FOR THE CRADLE
TO CAREER DATA AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING TO ENSURE
ECONOMIC EQUITY IS AT THE
CENTER OF THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR. CALL
MODERATOR THE LAST CALLER.
THAT'S FINE. PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL COME FROM LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS MARK WITH
MONTANA AND- I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF AT COLLEGE CHECK THE
BALLOT BOX AND IN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS AND PROBABLY
CALIFORNIA. JUST CALLING TO
BOOK OUR SUPPORT FOR THIRTY
MILLION TO SPARKS DEBATE
BETWEEN COLLEGES- AND YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VEY MUCH- THEY LET ME
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE OF YOU THAT
WERE STILL ON THE LINE- RIGHT
NOW. IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO
TEST FOR TODAY WERE YOU DID
TESTIFIED IT WAS BRIEF AND YOU
WISH TO ADD YOUR COMMENTS. YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE-
BECAUSE YOUR COMMENTS INTEREST
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPOTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SO. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. IN
TODAY'S HEARING WHICH CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE. NUMBER ONE IS A
JERK.